THE FEBRUARY TWENTY SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON BEST
PRACTICES.
PRACTICES FOR REPORTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PROVIDING VICTIMS
PORT.
THE WELCOME YOU ALL TODAY WE
HAVE A VERY INFORMATIVE PANELS.
THAT'S GOING TO BE TALKING WITH
US ON THE TO CONTINUE OUR SERIES
EXPLORING THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND HOW WE
CAN CHANGE OUR POLICIES TO MAKE
THEM MORE PER PROTECTIVE.
OF OUR EMPLOYEES
ON AND WITHOUT I'M GOING TO GO
TO SENATOR MITCHELL AND TO THE
REST OF THE PANEL FOR THE
COMMISSION FOR OPENING COMMENTS.
DEAR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M AND IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE. ALL WORKING ON IN THIS
BY CAMEL I'M FORMAT AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEADING THE SENATE TAKE THE LEAD
IN SHAPING TODAY'S HEARING ON.
WE'VE ARE WORKING OUT A SYSTEM
IN WHICH.
TWO HOUSES KIND OF SHARING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. I JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WANTED TO KIND OF REMIND
US ALL OF THE APPROACH THAT
WE'RE TAKING. ON THAT I'M CHAIR.
IN THIS HEARING PROCESS OUR
FIRST TWO HEARINGS FOCUSED ON
REVIEWING BEST PRACTICES FOR
CHANGING CULTURE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. ON DEFINING
HARASSMENT I DID A FINE
CHALLENGES AND OF COURSE TODAY'S
HEARING WAS GONNA FOCUS I
REPORTED A PROVIDING VICTIM
SUPPORT.
BUT ARE LAST HEARING YOU MAY
RECALL I RAISED THE QUESTION
ABOUT.
HOW WE MANAGE AND HANDLE THE
ANONYMOUS COMPLAINT
AND REALLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
AS?
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT THE CHARGE
OF THIS COMMITTEE. IS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TO THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE A RECOMMENDATION
ON A NEW WAY OF DOING BUSINESS
IN THE STATE CAPITAL. A NEW WAY
OF DOING BUSINESS THAT BOTH
HOUSES WILL BUY INTO SO WHETHER
YOU'RE AN EMPLOYEE AND YOU WORK
IN THE SENATE OR THE ASSEMBLY.
YOU WILL KNOW ABOUT THE NEW.
BICAMERAL.
PROCESS BY WHICH THESE ISSUES
WILL BE HANDLED I'M I'M HOPING
TODAY'S WITNESSES TODAY'S GROUP
OF EXPERTS.
AROUND THE REPORTING ISSUE CAN
TOUCH A BASIS ON.
CAN TOUCH ON THE ISSUE AROUND.
OF ANONYMOUS COMPLAINTS.
IF INDEED THAT'S THE BEST WAY
TO INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
PEOPLE ARE COMFORTABLE. ARM OR
IF THERE'S ANOTHER WAY WE CAN
REALLY GET AT THIS ISSUE I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING ON
THE VARIOUS WAYS IN WHICH
TECHNOLOGY IS NOW BEING USED TO
SUPPORT OUR REPORTING. AND JUST
WILL JOIN YOU IN THANKING ALL
THE WITNESSES WHO WILL BE
JOINING US TODAY I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO LEARN AND
BROUGHT MY OWN SKILL SET AND
HORIZONS IN TERMS OF HOW WE.
STEVE INFORMATION AND FIGURE OUT
A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN BUILD A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR BOTH
HOUSES OF OUR LEGISLATURE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU DO ANY OF THE OTHER
HOME MEMBERS WANT TO SPEAK.
YES SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MITCHELL.
FOR A LITTLE PRIVATE
CONVERSATION WE HAD ON.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH?
IT'S ALL RIGHT NOW IT'S A GOOD
LISTENING.
TIME. OUT MANAGER LAST WEEK IN
THE SENATE WE HAD A RATHER
UNIQUE HISTORICAL EVENT.
AND SO I STARTED GOING THROUGH.
SOME OF THE LITERATURE THAT
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN AS. OUR OWN
TRAINING.
I IN THE SENATE. AND AND TRYING
TO READ THROUGH IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN. AND AND AND AND I'LL ALSO
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
CRITICISMS LIKE THE LA TIMES
SAYING. YOU KNOW THERE'S REALLY
NOT CLARITY AND THAT BECAME MY
CONCLUSION IF WE WERE TO HAVE
SPOKEN ON THE FLOOR THANK.
IT'S VERY VAGUE SO AS WE LISTEN
I'M WONDERING MADAM CHAIR IF WE
JUST.
IF WE START BUILDING ONE OF
THOSE DASHBOARDS AND SAID THIS
IS A GOOD IDEA WHEN YOU TO
IMPLEMENT WE ARE TO INCLUDE THIS
IN THE MIX. WHEN WE DEVELOP
POLICIES OR MAYBE IF I COULD
HAVE PERMISSION AT TIMES TO SAY
HEY HAVE YOU READ OUR POLICY AND
WHAT WOULD YOU CHANGE. AS WE.
BUILD TOWARDS SOMETHING.
THAT WILL BE VERY HELPFUL TALL
AMIDST THOSE ARE MY ANDREAS ON
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S REALLY GREAT
INPUT AND WE HAVE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY TAKING NOTES.
WHENEVER ONE OF THE MANY
MEMBERS MENTIONS AN IDEA THAT
THEY'D LIKE TO BRING BACK FOR
DISCUSSION ARE MAKE SURE IS
INCORPORATED AS WE MOVE OUR
POLICIES FOR IT AND I ENCOURAGE.
ALL OF YOU TO FEEL FREE TO DO
THAT AND CERTAINLY TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PANELISTS
THEY'RE HERE TO BE RESOURCES.
ANTA TO YOU KNOW WHY I KNOW THAT
A LOT OF THEM HAVE BEEN WATCHING
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING HERE AND
DEFINITELY HAVE OPINIONS. ABOUT
THE WAY WE DO THINGS AND THE WAY
THAT YOU KNOW THEY WOULD
RECOMMEND FOR CERTAIN CHANGES BE
MADE SO I YOU KNOW THIS IS OUR
TIME WITH THEM TO REALLY. GET
THE MOST THAT WE CANNOT OF THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND THEIR EXPERIENCE.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
JUST REALLY BRIEFLY BEING ABLE
TO HEAR ABOUT BEST PRACTICES FOR
REPORTING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
VERY CRITICAL OF THEM. YOU KNOW
IT'S GOOD THAT WE'RE AT THIS
POINT BOMB IN OUR HEARINGS.
ONE OF THE BIG THINGS IS THE
CONFUSION INVOLVED WITH YOU
KNOW.
AN INCIDENT HAPPENS AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT IT'S NOT BLACK AND
WHITE THERE'S SO MANY LAYERS IN
NOTICES.
SOMETHING I SHOULD TALK ABOUT IS
IT WORTH BRINGING FORWARD USED
DON'T FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT AND I
CALL IT THE THREE R'S. THE
RESPECT.
THE RESPECT FOR THE VICTIM AND
WHAT THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
RESOURCES HAVING RESOURCE
AVAILABLE AND THEN RESOLUTION
WHICH IS GETTING TO.
YOU KNOW.
THE THE END OF IT GETTING A
RESOLUTION FOR THE VICTIM.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE FOR NOW.
TERRIFIC I'M. THAT ONE THING
THAT I WILL ALSO MENTION IS AN
ISSUE THAT MAY BE ONE OF THE
PALACE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IS
WHETHER. WHATEVER THE PENALTIES
THAT ARE.
TO ANY OF THESE ISSUES.
EVER PREVENTS A WITNESS FROM
COMING FORWARD.
YOU KNOW IT WHETHER THAT
PERSONALLY A FAX.
VICTIM BECAUSE OF MAYBE THE
PERSON'S EMPLOYER OR WHETHER
THEY'RE WORRIED OF YOU KNOW THEY
WANT A CERTAIN TYPE OF RESPONSE
ARE AFRAID THEY'RE NOT GONNA GET
IT SO THAT WOULD BE TO SOMETHING
I WOULD. THROW OUT AS MAYBE
SOMETHING FOR SOME OF THE
PANELISTS DISCUSS IN WITHOUT AN
OCCULT OUR FIRST PANELIST.
OUR OUR LET THEM INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND THEY COME UP FROM
THE FIRST PANEL IS ON BEST
PRACTICES AND CHALLENGES TO
REPORTING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
NEWTON NEW XIN NATHAN THAT THE
US CHIEF TALENT OFFICER AND
CHIEF HUMAN RESOURCES OFFICER
FOR THE MUSEUM OF NATURAL
HISTORY IN LOS ANGELES. COUNTY
AND ASHLEY KLEIN JIMENEZ PROJECT
MANNER MANAGER FOR CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
AND IS ALWAYS WILL HOLD OUR
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF THE
PANELISTS PRESENTATIONS.
AND.
.
WITHOUT I WILL INVITE OUR PANEL
TO.
I TO SPEAK OF MS I'M NATHAN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIRWOMAN FRIEDMAN AND
CHAIRWOMAN MITCHELL AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I KNEW XIN NATHAN. I
CHIEF TALENT OFFICER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY MUSEUM OF NATURAL
HISTORY.
I APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT CHARM.
THE WORLD'S LARGEST HR
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETY
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND MEMBERS
INCLUDING TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
IN CALIFORNIA.
SURE MEMBERS IN TURN INFLUENCED
THE LIVES OF OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION INDIVIDUALS IN THE
WORKFORCE.
ABOUT ONE IN THREE AMERICANS.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL THE NINETEEN
NINETIES THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE WORKPLACE ROSE TO SOCIAL
CONSCIOUSNESS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE IN THE
CASE OF HARRIS VERSUS FORKLIFT
SYSTEMS INC THE US SUPREME COURT
RULED THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT WAS
NOT LIMITED TO ACTS THAT RESULT
IN PHYSICAL. OR SEVERE
PSYCHOLOGICAL INJURY.
THEREBY INCLUDING PERVASIVE
SEXIST REMARKS INNUENDO AND
ADVANCES UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
ABUSIVE OR HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT.
AT THE END OF THE OTHER END OF
THE DECADE IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT WITH BURLINGTON
INDUSTRIES.
VERSUS ALLER IF AND FACT
FARAGHER VERSUS CITY OF BOCA
RATON THE SUIT SUPREME COURT
RULED THAT EMPLOYERS ARE LIABLE.
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT EVEN WHERE
NO PROFESSIONALLY ADVERSE ACTION
AGAINST THE CLAIMANT OCCURRED.
HOWEVER THE EMPLOYER MAY DEFEND
ITSELF BY SHOWING IT TOOK
MEASURES TO PREVENT OR
IMMEDIATELY CORRECT ANY SUCH
INSTANCES.
BUT THE NEED FOR EMPLOYER TO
PROTECT ITS EMPLOYEES AND DEFEND
ITSELF.
SO THE SEAT FOR HUMAN RESOURCES
IMPLEMENTING PROCEDURES ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE.
THESE GREAT CHANGES IN OUR LAWS
IN OUR HISTORY AND CULTURE.
WERE BROUGHT ABOUT BY MANY BRAVE
PEOPLE.
PARTICULARLY WOMEN WHO ARE NOT
AFRAID TO VOICE THEIR
EXPERIENCES UNTIL THEY WERE
HURT.
BUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS NOT
LIMITED TO WOMEN.
IT HAPPENS TO MEN AND THOSE
WHOSE GENDER IDENTITY FALLS
ANYWHERE ON THAT SPECTRUM.
IT CAN HAPPEN TO ANY OF US.
COMMON WORKPLACE BREAK BASS
RESPONSES BY THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE SEX SEX BASED
HARASSMENT ARE TO AVOID THE
HARASSER.
DENY OR DOWNPLAY THE GRAVITY OF
THE SITUATION. OR ATTEMPT TO
IGNORE FORGET OR INDOOR THE
BEHAVIOR.
THE FEAR DISBELIEF.
OF THEIR CLAIM.
IN ACTION ON THEIR CLAIM.
BLAME OR SOCIAL OR PROFESSIONAL
RETALIATION.
I SERUMS CEO AND PRESIDENT
JOHNNY C. TAYLOR NOTED IN
JANUARY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
CULTURE TRUMP'S POLICY.
AND WORKPLACES MUST CREATE A
HOLISTIC CULTURE OF NON
HARASSMENT THAT STARTS AT THE
TOP.
PART OF HAVING A POSITIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE WORKPLACE IS ENSURING
THAT WHEN SOMEONE FEELS THEY
HAVE BEEN A VICTIM OF WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT. OR HAS WITNESSED
HARASSMENT OR BEHAVIOR THAT
VIOLATES VIOLATES THE CULTURE OF
THE ORGANIZATION. THE EMPLOYER
HAS A PROCESS TO ADDRESS ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS BEST
PREVENTED AND CONFRONTED WHEN
THE CHANNELS ARE COMMUNICATION
ARE SAFE.
SWIFT AND UNENCUMBERED.
THEREFORE THE FIRST AND MOST
CRITICAL STEP FOR CHANGING
CULTURE AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
PROVIDING AND ACCESSIBLE
REPORTING PROCESS.
FOR THOSE CONFRONTING HARASSMENT
IN THE WORKPLACE.
THE NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM AND
HIM OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROVIDES ITSELF PRIDES ITSELF ON
ITS COLLEGIAL ENVIRONMENT.
WE ENCOURAGE OUR EMPLOYEES TO
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
WORKPLACE ISSUES WITH COLLEAGUES
REGARDLESS OF STANDING.
IF SUCH CONCERNS REQUIRE
GUIDANCE OR GRIEVE IN NATURE
SUCH AS WORKPLACE HARASSMENT ARE
SUPERVISORS MANAGERS AND
DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO
BRING THE INFORMATION TO HUMAN
RESOURCE SAID.
WE SHOULD RESOURCES AND A
DISCREET AND TIMELY MANNER.
IN ADDITION TO ENCOURAGING AN
OPEN DOOR POLICY WE HAVE
RECENTLY LAUNCHED A PROGRAM
CALLED SPEAK UP AND HM.
ANY CHANCE STANDS FOR NATURAL
HISTORY MUSEUM. WE IMPLEMENTED
THIS PROGRAM LAST YEAR AS A WAY
OF COMMITMENT TO OUR VALUE OF
INCLUSIVITY AND ALLOWING
MULTIPLE CHANNELS OF HEARING AND
LISTENING TO THE GOOD THE
CONCERNS OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN PROGRAM
IS OPERATED BY A THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATION.
ALLOWING OUR EMPLOYEES TO REPORT
ANY WORKPLACE ISSUES WITH THE
OPTION OF CONFIDENTIALITY AND
ANONYMITY.
ONCE A CLAIM HAS BEEN MADE OVER
THE PHONE OR THROUGH EMAIL THE
COLOR REALLY RECEIVE A CASE
NUMBER AND INSTRUCTIONS FOR
FOLLOW UP.
THE MATTER WILL BEND THEN BE
FORWARDED TO ME FOR REVIEW
INVESTIGATION AND ACTION.
THE RESPONSE WILL CONTAIN
SPECIFICS ON WHAT.
ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN OR WILL BE
TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE CONCERN.
WE'VE EVEN TAKEN MEASURES TO
ALLOW FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT ABOUT ANYONE IN THE HR
DEPARTMENT.
WHICH ARE THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATION WILL FORWARD TO OUR
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR REVIEW.
THIS PROGRAM AND OTHERS LIKE AT
ARE A MEANS OF EMPLOYEES ARE OUR
NEEDS FOR EMPLOYEES TO REPORT
WITHOUT SHAME OR FEAR OF
RETALIATION.
AND WITH THE OPTION OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
THERE'S NO NEED TO REPORT THE
ISSUE TO YOUR SUPERVISOR OR EVEN
YOUR SUPERVISOR'S SUPERVISOR IF
THE EMPLOYEE DOESN'T WANT TO.
PROVIDING A SERVICE LIKE THE
SIGNALS TO EMPLOYEES THAT THEIR
CONCERNS MATTER AND WILL BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
IT EXEMPLIFIES OUR CONTINUOUS
EFFORTS TO HEAR THE VOICES OF
OUR STAKEHOLDERS BY ANY MEANS
POSSIBLE.
IT ALSO HELPS LAY A FOUNDATION
OF TRUST AND BUILDS A CULTURE
THAT IS CONSTANTLY LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE A SAFE.
AND COLLABORATIVE WORK
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS FREE FROM
HARASSMENT.
THROUGH WHATEVER MEANS ACCLAIM
HAS BEEN REPORTED THAT CLEAN
MUST BE HANDLED THROUGH
CONSISTENT PROCEDURES.
HAVING PROCEDURES IN PLACE
INSURERS THAT THE CLAIM THAT
FLOW THROUGH A PREDICTABLE
CYCLE.
IN GENERAL THAT CYCLE SHOULD
INCLUDE THE CLAIM THE
INVESTIGATION THE FINDINGS AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION.
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS ALL
RELEVANT INFORMATION MUST BE
PROPERLY DOCUMENTED.
DOCUMENTATION SERVICE TO
FUNCTIONS IT ASSISTS IN THE
DETERMINATION OF CORRECTIVE
ACTION TO BE TAKEN. AND IS
EVIDENCE THAT ACTION HAS BEEN
TAKEN.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF ANY KIND IS
ALWAYS SERIOUS AND SHOULD
ACCORDINGLY BE TREATED AS SUCH.
REGARDLESS OF THE HIERARCHY
WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION.
IT SHOULD NOT MATTER TO WHOM THE
CLAIM WAS MADE. ONCE IT HAS BEEN
REPORTED THE PROCESSOR OF THE
INFORMATION MUST TAKE IT TO
THOSE WHO WILL PERFORM AN
UNBIASED INVESTIGATION.
THAT INVESTIGATION MUST BE
COMPREHENSIVE IN NATURE. AND YET
LIMITED IN THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED.
TOO MANY PARTICIPANTS MAY NOT
ONLY CONTAMINATE THE
INVESTIGATIONS. AB. BUT MAY
NEGATIVELY AFFECT EMPLOYEES
TRUST AND DAY TO DAY EXPERIENCE
AMONG HIS OR HER PEERS.
YET IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO RESPOND.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
PREVENT.
PREVENTION REQUIRES EDUCATION
AND TRAINING OF OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND MANAGERS
HOWEVER EVEN EFFECTIVE TRAINING
CANNOT OCCUR IN A VACUUM IN MUST
BE PART OF THE HOLISTIC CULTURE.
OF NON HARASSMENT THAT STARTS AT
THE TOP.
WHEN THE TERM SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IS USE WHAT COMES TO MIND OF
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOT THIS SMALLER
BUT PERSISTENT AND INTOLERABLE
ACTS
IT IS THE EXTREME ACTS
THE OX WE HEAR ABOUT ON THE NEWS
THAT COME TO MIND.
ROGER AILES BILL COSBY.
BILL REILLY HARVEY WEINSTEIN
YET HARASSMENT CAN TAKE MANY
FORMS AND EMPLOYEES NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BEHAVIOR THAT
MAY BE SMALLER IN SCOPE BUT
STILL PERSISTENT. AND INTO IT AN
INTOLERABLE ACTS OF HARASSMENT.
WE MUST THEREFORE DEFINE WHAT
CONSTITUTES HARASSMENT FROM THE
BEGINNING OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
EMPLOYMENT.
WE MUST PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
IT IS. WHY IT IS A PROBLEM
HOODOO REPORTED TO HOW IT WILL
BE ADDRESSED WHERE THEY CAN FIND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND WHEN TO
EXPECT CLOSURE?
THIS IS THE KEY TO ENSURING THAT
OUR ACCESS AND PROCEDURES ARE
PROPERLY UTILIZED.
EDUCATION MIGHT MUST TAKE THE
FORM OF CLEAR AND PUBLIC A
WRITTEN POLICY.
EASY TO LOCATE AND EASY TO
REFERENCE.
EDUCATION SHOULD BE INTERACTIVE.
I CANNOT SHY AWAY FROM TOPICS
THAT MAKE US UNCOMFORTABLE WE
MUST SPEAK ABOUT IT FREELY. AND
EMPOWER ALL MANAGERS TO HELP
EFFECTIVELY BUT CONFIDENCE AND
COMPASSION.
WE MUST INFUSE CIVILITY WITHOUT
A WITHIN OUR WORK CULTURE AND
EMPOWER OUR COLLEAGUES TO SPEAK
UP AS BYSTANDERS WITNESSING
UNWELCOME BEHAVIORS.
WHAT'S A CLAIM HAS BEEN MADE WE
ARE NOW ON NOTICE TOPPED.
THE LONGER IT TAKES TO RESPOND
TO A SEXUAL A LOT HARASSMENT
CLAIM THE LESS FAITH AN
INDIVIDUAL COMPLAINANT HIGHS IN
HR'S RESPONSE.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THAT FAITH TO
BECOME BRITTLE.
WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO LIVE UP TO
IT.
NEVER THE LESS MORE HUMAN AND IN
PERFECT.
WEAKNESSES IN POLICY AND
PROCEDURES MAY AND WILL BE
DISCOVERED EARLY ALONG THE WAY.
THEY SHOULD BE CORRECTED AS THEY
ARE DISCOVERED AND THE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES AUDITED REGULARLY
IN BETWEEN.
LEADERSHIP MUST ASK ITSELF
IS THIS PROTOCOL NECESSARY IS IT
EFFICIENT.
HOW DO WE GAUGE OUR CURRENT
EDUCATIONS EFFECTIVENESS?
SHOULD WE DO A FOCUS GROUP.
AN ANONYMOUS SURVEY HOW CAN WE
BEST COMMUNICATES EVERYONE ANY
CHANGES.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH FOR EMPLOYEES
TO HOLD THEIR LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE LEADERS MUST HOLD
THEMSELVES AND THEIR PEERS TO
THE SAME STANDARDS.
THIS REQUIRES UNIVERSAL
COMMITMENT TO MAINTAINING A
HARASSMENT FREE WORKPLACE.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES MANAGERS TO
BE RETRAINED IN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION TRAINING
EVERY TWO YEARS.
WHILE THIS LAWS IMPORTANT IT
CANNOT REPLACE THE ROLE THAT
LEADERSHIP AND THE ORGANIZATION
PLAYS IN CREATING AND
MAINTAINING A POLICY. THAT
INCLUDES ACCESS PROCEDURES AND
EDUCATION.
OUR SENIOR LEADERS MUST LEAD BY
EXAMPLE FOR THE SET THE TONE OF
ANY ORGANIZATION ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE LAW WITH BEST
PRACTICES.
LEADERS MUST SELL SERVE AS ROLE
MODELS FOR A DIVERSE INCLUSIVE
AND RESPECTFUL WORKPLACE BY
REFUSING TO TOLERATE
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR. BY
ADDRESSING IT.
SPEEDY AT LEE WHEN IT OCCURS.
AND POPULAR CULTURE HUMAN
RESOURCES IS OFTEN THE RUNNING
JOKE.
THE DEPARTMENT TO BE FEARED OR
SCORNED AS UNNECESSARY TASK
MASTERS.
HR DEPARTMENTS NEED TO
CONSISTENTLY REVIEW IMPROVE AN
ADVOCATE FOR PROGRAMS THAT
CREATE AND FOSTER A SAFE
PRODUCTIVE WORK ENVIRONMENT.
THAT IS CONDUCIVE TO CO
ELEVATING OUR COLLEAGUES.
IT HAS OFTEN BEEN SAID THAT THE
PITFALL OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN IN
HOLLYWOOD WASN'T WATERSHED
MOMENT.
BUT WE WILL HAVE MANY MORE SUCH
MOMENTS AS OUR CHILDREN NURTURE
THE WISDOM VESTED IN THEM.
WE SEE IT NOW IN THE MEAT TO AND
NEVER AGAIN MOVEMENTS.
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REMAIN ON
BLUSHING BY THE CONTEMPT OF
SOCIAL MEDIA. OR POLITICAL
PROVOCATEURS WILL BRING US
CLOSER TO RESTORING JUSTICE IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
REMAIN OPTIMISTIC IN MY VIEW
THAT WE CAN STILL BRING CHANGES
AS PROFESSIONALS. AS IMPERFECT
BUT AMBITIOUS HUMAN BEINGS.
AND THAT THE FUTURE BUT INDEED
HOLD A MORE KIND SELF AWARE AND
JUST WORKED.
SURE PLEDGES TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS IT ADDRESSES THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
I CLIMBED A MENACE.
THAT AFTERNOON HERE MANY.
HER CHAIRMAN JOHN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ASHLEY KIND
JIMENEZ AND I AM A PROJECT
MANAGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR ODDS WERE MORE COMMONLY KNOWN
CAL CASA. AND ALSO ACCOMPANIED
BY MY COLLEAGUE JOHN FINLEY.
COME CASA PROVIDE LEADERSHIP AND
VISION AND RESOURCES TO EIGHTY
FOUR RAPE CRISIS CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND A VARIETY OF
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE NATION
COMMITTED TO ENDING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE IN ALL ITS FORMS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS A FORM OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE THAT IMPACTS
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS' BEYOND
THAT THE INCIDENT.
AB HOW CASA WE WORK TO CENTER
THE NEEDS OF SURVIVORS THROUGH A
TRAUMA INFORMED APPROACH THIS
APPROACH RECOGNIZES THE IMPACT
OF TRAUMA ON THE SURVIVOR.
AND ACTIVELY RESISTS RETRY
MONETIZING NAM.
WHEN IT COMES TO REPORTING
INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SURVIVORS FEES NUMEROUS BARRIERS
AND MANY SURVIVORS DELAY
REPORTING FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
ONE OF THE REASONS IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE COMPLEXITY OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND THE INTIMATE NATURE
OF THE INCIDENT. IT IS COMMON
FOR SURVIVORS TO FEEL ASHAMED
AND EMBARRASSED OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO
SHARE WITH ANYONE.
ADDITIONALLY INDIVIDUALS MAY NOT
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS OR THE
PROPHECIES FOR FILING A
COMPLAINT. AND MAY EXPERIENCE
NORMAL REACTIONS TO TRAUMA THAT
CAN INCLUDE IGNORING OR BURYING
THE SEXUAL. VIOLENCE IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE AND CONTINUE IN THEIR
DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES.
IT IS IMPORTANT NOT SURVIVORS
ARE PROVIDED WITH CONFIDENTIAL
RESOURCES FOR SUPPORT AND THAT
THEY ARE AWARE OF THE VARIOUS
REMEDIES PROPHECIES AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
SURVIVORS MAY ALSO CHOOSE NOT TO
REPORT OR DELAY REPEATS
REPORTING OUT OF FEAR
SPECIFICALLY FEAR OF THE
CONSEQUENCES.
SURVIVORS MAY FEAR LOSING THEIR
JOB AND EXPERIENCING RETALIATION
FROM THEIR EMPLOYER IN COLOR
CARS AS WELL AS THE PERSON WHO
CAUSE THEM HARM.
THERE IS A FEARING BEING LABELED
A TROUBLEMAKER AND THE IMPACTS
THAT CAN HAVE ON SOMEONE'S
PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
THERE'S ALSO FEAR THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE BELIEVED OR IF THEY ARE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
COMPLAINTS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN BRUSHED OFF HIS JOKES.
I OR NOT A BIG DEAL OR JUST HOW
THINGS ARE.
SURVIVORS ALSO HOLE NUMEROUS
SOCIAL IDENTITIES INCLUDING RACE
NATIONALITY SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS GENDER IDENTITIES SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND LANGUAGE.
HISTORICAL IN MULTI GENERATIONAL
OPPRESSION BASED ON THESE AYE
DENNIS DIS INTERSECT WITH SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND CAN CAUSE FURTHER
BARRIERS AND REPORTING.
SURVIVORS MAY FEEL THAT THE
PERSONAL SOCIAL AND PROFESSIONAL
CONSEQUENCES OF REPORTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ARE FAR TO GREET.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY WORRY THAT
THE COMPLETE WILL NOT BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
WELL THE TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THE
BARRIERS REPORTING ARE VERY REAL
THERE ARE STEPS THAT EMPLOYERS
CAN TAKE TO ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND START TO SHIFT
THE CULTURE TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SURVIVORS ARE
SUPPORTED. OUR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CAN BE PREVENTED.
STRONG POLICY CENTER CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT ORGANIZATIONS WILL
SUPPORT SURVIVORS AND HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE HARM
THEY HAVE CAUSED.
WE MUST ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
POLICIES CAN BE OVERRIDDEN WHEN
UNDERLYING BELIEFS AND VALUES
THAT HAVE SUPPORTED A CULTURE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ARE NOT
ADDRESSED.
EMPLOYERS SHOULD ESTABLISH CLEAR
POLICIES THAT ARE COMMUNICATED
EFFECTIVELY APPLIED CONSISTENTLY
AND REVIEW OFTEN AND PROMOTE A
CULTURE OF RESPECT WHERE
EVERYONE IS VALUED.
THIS REQUIRES SHIFTING AWAY FROM
NORMS THAT VALUE CLEANING AND
MAINTAINING MAINTAINING POWER
OVER OTHERS TO NORMS THAT
SUPPORT EQUITY.
LEADERSHIP CAN MODEL RESPECT FOR
PEOPLE'S BOUNDARIES ENCOURAGE
BYSTANDERS TO SPEAK UP AND MAKE
SAFETY FOR ALL A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON GOING TRAINING WHICH IS
SOMETHING NOT HOW CASA PROVIDES
SHOULD ALSO BE PROVIDED TO
LEADERSHIP AND SUPERVISORS ON
HOW TO PROMOTE A POSITIVE
RESPECTFUL IN SAFE CLIMATE FOR
EMPLOYEES.
ALL EMPLOYEES SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TRAINING ON HOW TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND SPEAK UP WHEN THE
WITNESS HARMFUL BEHAVIORS.
LEADERS CAN CONDUCT CONFIDENTIAL
ANONYMOUS SURVEYS TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON ORGANIZATIONAL
CONDITIONS IDENTIFY AREAS THAT
NEED IMPROVEMENT AND DRIVE
ACTION TO IMPROVE THE CLIMATE
EXPERIENCE BY EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYERS CAN ALSO BE PROACTIVE
BY MAKING SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT AND ONGOING
CONVERSATION.
SILENCE ALLOWS PEOPLE TO GO
UNCHECKED
CONDONES UNACCEPTABLE BEHAVIOR
AND MAINTAINS THE STATUS QUO.
TALKING OPENLY AND REGULARLY
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT SHIFTS
THE CULTURE OF VIOLENCE THAT AS
WELL ALLOWED SEXUAL VIOLENCE TO
FLOURISH.
WE ONLY HAVE TO LOOK TO COLLEGE
CAMPUSES TO SEE HOW A CULTURAL
SHIFT AROUND SILENCE CAN
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO REPORT
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
COLLEGE CAMPUSES HAVE COMMITTED
TO BETTER ADDRESSING PREVENTING
AND RESPONDING TO SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
MANY HAVE SEEN INCREASES IN
REPORTS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
THIS DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
NOT MORE SEXUAL ASSAULT HAVE
OCCURRED BUT RATHER THAT
CAMPUSES HAVE STARTED TO CREATE
CLAIMANTS WHERE SURVIVORS ARE
MORE COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD
AND REPORTING THEIR EXPERIENCES.
THIS IS A GOOD THING.
WE MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE THE ROLE
INSTITUTIONS AND WORKS TO CLOSE
THOSE GAPS
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE WOMEN A
ROUTINELY ISOLATED AND
INTIMIDATED ARE RIGHT FOR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
IN CLOSING SUPPORTING SURVIVORS
IS CRUCIAL FOR PROMOTING A
CULTURE OF INTOLERANCE FOR
SEXUAL VIOLENCE WE MUST PAY
ATTENTION TO THE VARYING
EXPERIENCES AND NEEDS OF
SURVIVORS. AND WE MUST ALSO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING SOCIAL
AND CULTURAL NORMS THAT HAVE
ALLOWED SEXUAL VIOLENCE RUNS
RAMPANT IN OUR INSTITUTIONS AND
COMMUNITIES AND COMMIT TO
CHANGING NAM. THINK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
QUESTIONS NOW AND I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION IF YOU DON'T MIND
JUST TO START OFF.
.
SO CLEARLY THERE ARE CHALLENGES
TO. ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD HERE THERE WAS SEXUAL
VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AYE IN THE ASSEMBLY SUPERVISORS
ARE GIVEN AN EXTRA TWENTY
MINUTES OF TRAINING. BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT IN TWENTY
MINUTES MAYBE ALL YOU CAN DO IS
TELL THEM HOW TO REPORT. AND BY
THE WAY WE DON'T REQUIRE PEOPLE
TO REPORT TO THE SUPERVISORS
THAT CAN ACTUALLY REPORT
DIRECTLY TO HUMAN RESOURCES THEY
CAN REPORT TO A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. BUT IT SEEMS THAT
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES OF
OF HELPING PEOPLE.
FACE THOSE CHALLENGES THAT IS A
LOT OF ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
ON MANDATORY REPORTERS AND
SUPERVISORS TO KNOW HOW TO.
TAKE THOSE REPORTS AND TO MAKE
EVERYONE THAT THEY COME IN
CONTACT WITH UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE IS A WAY TO REPORT THAT
THAT YOU KNOW HOME AND AND TO BE
MORE ENCOURAGING OF REPORTING
WENT WHEN THESE WHEN.
THERE ARE. ISSUES IN THE
WORKPLACE SO WHAT WHAT DOES.
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING LOOK LIKE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS IS THERE
ANY BEST STANDARD OUT THERE.
PACIFIC WE FOR MANDATORY
REPORTERS AND SUPERVISORS.
.
I I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT'S THE
SAME TYPE OF TRAINING MAYBE
THAT'S GIVEN TO TO THE MEMBER
THE PEOPLE WANT WE'VE HER ARE ON
THE OTHER END OF THE TELEPHONE
OR WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT BUT. DO YOU
HAVE ANY IDEAS OF HOW WHAT WE
CAN LOOK TO.
TO BEEF UP WHAT'S CLEARLY.
I AT THIS POINT IN AN ADEQUATE
AMOUNT OF TRAINING THAT'S GIVEN
TO THE THAT SORT OF FRONT LINE
OF INDIVIDUALS.
SURE THINK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN.
SO I WOULD SAY THAT I.
BECAUSE I CAL BECAUSE SO WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSED ON.
PROVIDING A TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH I FIND NOT TO BE.
A VERY SIGNIFICANT PLACE TO
START IS HAVING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN SOMEONE
COMES FORWARD TO REPORT OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT THERE'S A LOT OF
TRAUMA THAT IS ALSO COMING WITH
THAT. AND.
WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY NEED JUST
BORN KNOWING HOW TO DEAL WITH
PEOPLE AND THEIR TRAUMA.
AND SO TRAINING AROUND WHAT
TRAUMA LOOKS LIKE HOW TRAUMA
IMPACTS PEOPLE ON IS IS IT CAN'T
BE DONE IN TWENTY MINUTES AND IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT. AIMS WE
WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING TOWARDS US HOW PEOPLE
RESPOND.
TO A SURVIVOR WHEN THEY HAVE TO
CLOSE DISCLOSE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CAN HAVE A REAL IMPACT ON
WHETHER THEY CONTINUE FORWARD.
I'M IN THE REPORTING PROCESS
WHETHER THEY GET COUNSELING I'M
REALLY WHAT THEY DO NEXT TO.
DEAL WITH THEIR TRAUMA AND HEAL
FROM THAT
SO I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT.
HAVING PEOPLE UNDERSTAND A THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
SURVIVORS GIVING PEOPLE OPTIONS
GIVING SURVIVORS OPTIONS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND IT'S THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION AND LET THEM KNOW
WHAT RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE AND
WHAT OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL.
TERRIFIC THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL.
MA'AM.
STAY IN ON THE ISSUE OF TRAINING
AND AND CULTURE CHANGE IN THE
ROLE OF TRAINING WITHIN IT. ALL
BUT WHICH I'VE BEEN READING A
LOT ABOUT.
LOTS OF YOU KNOW MIXED FEELINGS
ABOUT THE ROLE OF TRAINING
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ABOUT LACK OF
EDUCATION IT'S BEHAVIOR CHANGE.
SO I WONDER IF.
IT IT FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
EXPERIENCE IF IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO KIND OF START.
BEFORE THE BEGINNING.
AS CNN.
BEGIN TO AFFECT CULTURE CHANGE
IF IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
CHECK IMPLICIT BIAS
TO TEST IMPLICIT BIAS
JUST SO ENSURE GOING TO THE
TRAINING EVERYONE HAVE TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF UNCLEAR ABOUT.
THEIR CURRENT PERCEPTIONS
AROUND.
GENDER BIAS. BEFORE WE BEGIN TO
DIDN'T CORRECT THEIR BEHAVIOR
ANY COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE ON
THAT EITHER IF YOU.
NEVER ACTUALLY AND RIGHT NOW
LOOKING AND SO WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA BRING IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING TO OUR MUSEUM AND ALL
STAFF AND. NOW IT THAT THAT
DOESN'T JUST ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS IT YOU KNOW
ADDRESSES INCLUSIVITY RACE
EQUITY SENSE OF BELONGING
BRINGING YOUR WHOLE SELF TO
WORK.
I AM SO ABSOLUTELY SPECIALLY
BECAUSE BE SERVED ONE POINT
THREE MILLION PEOPLE ON IN
PUBLIC WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
EVEN WHEN OUR VISITORS ARE
COMING TO THE MUSEUM WHERE NOT.
BRINGING OUR OUR BY A CEASE ART
THERE ARE IMPLICIT BISI SORT AND
IN NOT WELCOMING SET CERTAIN
GROUPS. SO I THINK.
THAT WOULD BE ACTUALLY VERY
VITAL TO HAVE CONTINUOUS
IMPLICIT BIAS. AND TO CHANGE
THOSE AT.
CHALLENGE DOES GENERAL IDEAS
THAT PEOPLE HIVE OF RULES OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT
SEXES RACES.
OF ALSO ARE ALL ABOUT.
IT DOES I REALLY TAKES UNPACKING
I'M SO MUCH OF WHAT WE HAVE ALL
GROWN UP AND AS A SOCIETY.
AND SO THERE IS A LOT OF OF
THINKING ABOUT ISSUES BROADER
ISSUES OF OPPRESSION AND RULES
THAT WE'VE ALL PLAYED. ON AND I
AGREE THAT I IT IT'S NOT THE
EDUCATION THAT'S THE ISSUE IT'S
IT'S HOW WE INTERACT SO IT'S THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE PUT INTO PLACE
AND THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
CREATE.
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I WOULD
AGREE THAT WE DON'T WANT TO JUST
BUILD A SYSTEM. TO REPORT AND
CREATE SAFE REPORTING AFTER THE
FACT
WE HAVE A GOAL AROUND PREVENTION
AS WELL SO THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
THE QUESTION. IN TERMS OF
CULTURE SHIFT IN THE ROLE
TRAINEE PLAYS IN THAT TO TWO
MORE QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR IF I
MAY. UM.
TO.
METS NATHAN HOW MANY EMPLOYEES
OBNOXIOUS MUSEUM OF WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEES AND A SEVEN HUNDRED
VOLUNTEERS PER ENTOMOLOGIST
GOAL.
SO OUR VOLUNTEERS INCORPORATED
IN NEED TO GO THROUGH TRAIN IN
THE REPORTING SO THAT ALL THAT
SO YOU'RE STRUCTURE. IMPECCABLE
VOLUNTEERS A AN EMPLOYEE TAKE IT
DAY TO GO THROUGH TRAINING YOU
MENTIONED.
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO LIMIT THE
NUMBER PARTICIPANTS WAS THE WORD
YOU USED.
INVESTIGATIONS I ASSUME YOU
MEANT THE NUMBER PEOPLE
CONDUCTING INVESTIGATE CORRECT
OKAY I WANT TO MAKE SURE I WAS
CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
AND HOW IN BOTH OF YOUR
EXPERIENCE HAVE YOU ARE MANAGED
ANONYMOUS REPORTING.
I HAVE.
I HAVE AND THIS NEW SYSTEM THAT
WE HIVE SPEAK UP ANY CHEN.
.
EVER SINCE WE INSTITUTED WE HOP
HOT ABOUT SEVEN ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINTS AND THEY'VE BEEN.
.
NOT.
THEY'VE BEEN.
VERY SOFT TOUCH ISSUES THAT A
BIRD BEEN BROUGHT TO US LIKE.
A AND MANAGERS BEHAVIOR LET'S
SAY TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE'S
WEIGHT WHICH WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
SO IT HASN'T BEEN ANYTHING
THAT'S BEEN HEAVY DUTY.
BUT.
STILL WE LOOK INTO IT WE ADDRESS
SAID RESPOND.
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS
ANONYMOUSLY REPORTED WILL
RECEIVE A RESPONSE FROM US.
AND AND I.
THIS IS PROBABLY AN UNFAIR
QUESTION AND I'M GOING TO SAY
THAT AND THEN AFTER ANYWAY.
GIVEN YOUR EXPERIENCE WHY DO
YOU ASSUME THOSE WERE ANONYMOUS
WAS IT FEAR OF RETALIATION OR
WHAT DO YOU THINK MAY HAVE BEEN
THE MOST.
FACTOR.
I AM NOT SURE EXACTLY I THINK
NOT SOMETIMES PEOPLE FEEL THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO THROW OTHER
PEOPLE UNDER THE BUS BUT IT'S
JUST THAT. IT'S A SMALL BEHAVIOR
THAT NEEDS CORRECTION AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN
GIVING THEIR NAME GOT IT IN ONE.
AND LAST QUESTION FOR ME IN THIS
IS DIRECTED TO MS KLEIN JIMENEZ
BASING YOUR EXPERIENCES WITH
COLLEGES.
EVEN.
THE POPULATION YOU GET WHAT I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE GONNA HEAR ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY THAT
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS IN A
COUPLE OF TOOL THAT ON THE
MARKET NEXT. I'M WONDERING.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE IF
TECHNOLOGY. IS HELPFUL WITH
REPORTING.
I THINK IT CAN BE I THINK WHEN
IT COMES TO ANY LARGE
INSTITUTION WHETHER IT'S A
COLLEGE OR I'M WHAT HAVE YOU.
AYE WE NEED A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH AND SO THAT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE TRAINING THAT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE CHANGES TO THE
ENVIRONMENT BY MY INCLUDE
TECHNOLOGICALLY IN AND.
APPLICATION BASED FEATURES SO I
THINK THAT IT DEFINITELY DEPENDS
ON.
THE WHAT THE GOALS ARE IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE CULTURE IS
OF THE ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO IMPACTS BUT I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THERE CAN
BE A PLACE FOR IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THINK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. I HAVE
A QUESTION ON I THINK IT WAS.
MISS CLIMB THE MENACE THAT SAID
WE NEED TO PUT STRONG POLICIES
IN PLACE.
SO I'M WONDERING HOW WE DO THAT
WHEN WE HAVE A ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY HERE AT THE CAPITOL. BUT
THAT REALLY HASN'T WORKED AS
WE'VE SEEN SO WHAT KIND OF
STRONG POLICIES TO BE PUT IN
PLACE SO THAT ARE ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY ACTUALLY WORKS.
BUT I QUESTION IT MIGHT NOT BE
AN ISSUE THAT THE POLICY ITSELF
IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH BUT AGAIN I
THINK I MENTIONED DOT.
A CULTURE A TOXIC CULTURE CAN
REALLY UNDERMINE EVEN THE PAST
POLICY AND SO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS.
REALLY SHOULD BE AT PLAY ON NOT
ONLY ME AND IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THAT THE POLICY MAY NOT BE
STRONG ENOUGH BUT IS THE POLICY
CLEAR IS IT EASY FOR FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT YOU SEE. AS A
HAS BEEN COMMUNICATED TO PEOPLE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY.
SO I LOOK AT THE
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS.
THANK YOU.
HE AND SOME OF THE LITERATURE
THAT THE.
CAO COSTA GAVE AND THEN ALSO MS
NATHAN IN YOUR COMMENTS YOU
TALKED ABOUT BY STANDARDS
BYSTANDERS.
IS THERE SPECIFIC TRAINING YOU
GIVE TWO BYSTANDERS.
AND TELLING THEM WITH THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IS IN REPORTING.
BUT THERE IS TRAINING OUT THERE
FOR BYSTANDER REPORTING HOWEVER
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WEEK WE AND.
PRESENT TO ALL EMPLOYEES AND
MANAGERS WHEN WE DO ANY TYPE OF
TRAINING AND IN BUILDING THAT
CULTURE THAT VOICES MATTER.
AND THAT.
THIS IS AB AND ENVIRONMENT THAT
IS SAFE FOR ALL EMPLOYEES AND WE
TREAT EACH OTHER WITH CIVILITY.
SO WITH ITS BUILT IN OUR CULTURE
IT IS.
.
YOU KNOW INCLUSIVITY AS ONE OF
OUR VALUES
SO.
IT'S IT'S IT'S WE'RE SURROUNDED
BY IT AND WE TRY TO TOUCH IT
EVERYTIME WE KAREN.
AND AND POWER ARE EMPLOYEES TO
BEHAVE IN THOSE WAYS.
REALLY LOOK.
BYSTANDER INTERVENTION OUT FROM
AN ADVOCACY IN PREVENTION PUT ON
STANDPOINT AND SO. FOR SO LONG
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE HAS BEEN THIS
VERY PRIVATE ISSUE IT'S NOT MY
BUSINESS I DON'T WANT TO GET
INVOLVED.
AND SO INCLUDING INVOLVING
BYSTANDERS IS REALLY SAYING THAT
THIS IS A COMMUNITY ISSUE. WE
ALL HAVE A ROLE IN PREVENTING
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
AND SO IT'S REALLY PROVIDING
PEOPLE WITH THE TOOLS AND THE
KNOWLEDGE.
TO BE ABLE TO INTERVENE WHETHER
ON ITS VERBAL COMMENTS OR AYE
PHYSICAL ACT.
THAT WOULD CAUSE HARM.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT OPTIONS YOU
TALKED ABOUT RESOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND OPTIONS.
ONCE THE PERSON HAS MADE A A
REPORT AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
AN ANONYMOUS REPORT BUT A REPORT
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
ARE THE OPTIONS.
LESS AT THAT POINT IN THAT A.
DO THEY HAVE LESS OPTIONS OR DO
THEY HAVE MORE OPTIONS AT THAT
POINT.
IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU DO NOT IN
THIS REPORT.
YOU COULD STILL DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE GOING TO CALL THE
POLICE YOU COULD STILL DECIDE SO
MANY OF THE THINGS WHETHER
YOU'RE GOING TO BE INVOLVED OR
NOT.
ONCE YOU'VE MADE THE REPORT NOW
ARE THEY IN THIS SYSTEM AND THEY
HAVE TO NOW GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING THAT IS BEING
OFFERED.
AND FOR US AND WHEN WE RECEIVE A
COMPLAINT ABOUT HARASSMENT AND.
WE WE TRY TO CREATE A SPACE FOR
A THAT INDIVIDUAL TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO TALK ABOUT
ALL OF THAT AND THEN. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS.
I WILL ASK IS.
DO YOU FEEL SAFE RIGHT NOW IN
THIS SITUATION AS WE CONDUCT
THIS INVESTIGATION AND FIND OUT
THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT HAS
OCCURRED.
SO IN THAT SPACE OF TIME BEFORE
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONDUCT THE INVESTIGATION IN A
TIMELY MANNER. BECAUSE.
YOU'RE YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE THAT
THAT PERSON IS WORKING.
AROUND PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE
PERPETUATED NOT ACT.
SO IT'S CRITICAL FOR HR
DEPARTMENT OR WHOEVER IS
HANDLING YOUR AND RESPONSE TO.
TO TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE WITH
THE VICTIM.
GOING TO ASK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THE ANONYMOUS IF I MAY.
ANONYMOUS COMPLAINTS.
I.
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING COMPLETELY
HOW THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
IF SOMEONE WANTS TO REPORT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THEY CALL
THE HOTLINE.
IS THE INVESTIGATION OF YOU SAID
EARLIER ABOUT THAT THOSE ARE
SOFT COMPLAINTS ARE SOFT THEY
HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN HIDE MANY
MAJOR.
YOU KNOW BIG ISSUES THEY'VE BEEN
YOU KNOW I JUST IN LIKE.
HOW THIS PERSON SAID THIS?
SO EACH IS AN ANONYMOUS
COMPLAINT TREATED THE SAME AS.
A FACE TO FACE COMPLAINED
NORMALLY.
AND SO THE WAY IT'S HANDLED IS
WE'VE HIRED A THIRD PARTY WHO
RECEIVES THE COMPLAINT.
AND THEY REALLY THAT INFORMATION
TO US AND I'M ABLE TO SEND A
RESPONSE TO THIS ANONYMOUS COME
COMPLAINANT. UP WITHOUT REALLY
KNOWING WHO THEY ARE SO WE STILL
CAN HAVE DIALOGUE WITHOUT.
ME KNOWING WHO IS FILE THAT
COMPLAIN AND ASK QUESTIONS AND
AND MAYBE ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME
FORWARD IF IT'S IF IT'S A REALLY
GRAVE AND YOU KNOW. INCIDENT
THAT HAS HAPPENED TO THEM.
AND THAT I PROVIDE THE RESPONSE
AFTER.
INVESTIGATION AND ACTION HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
AND USE THAT INFORMATION
DISCOVERABLE.
I AM YES I MEAN IT'S NOT CLOAKED
UNDER ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
COMMUNICATION SO NOWADAYS.
ALRIGHT SO EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
COMPLAINING ANONYMOUSLY.
THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS
EVENTUALLY THEIR IDENTITY COULD
BE.
DETERMINED.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
FOR AN ATTORNEY I HAVE NOT
THOUGHT THAT THROUGH.
BUT GOOD BECAUSE MY QUESTION IS
WHO WHO IS THE OWNER OF THAT
INFORMATION RIGHT IS IT TO THE
ORGANIZATION LIKE HERE THE STATE
THAT HIRES THAT.
ENTITY TO ACCEPT THE ANONYMOUS.
COMPLAINTS
OR DOES IT BELONG TO THAT
ENTITY.
THAT THAT IS A A CONCERN FOR ME
WARM.
AND AYE I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT BUT I DO HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO GET THAT FOR YOU
I'M HAPPY ONE TO FOLLOW AT. BUT
I WOULD I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
AN IMPORTANT FACTOR KNOW THAT
WE'VE STARTED. THE WE'VE.
.
PROGRAM BUT THAT IS THAT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU FOR SAYING
WERE.
KEEPING IT ANONYMOUS O. BUT IT
IS DISCOVERABLE O. LEGALLY THEN.
THEY NEED TO NOTE THAT THE
VICTIM THAT MAKES THE REPORT.
DOES NEED TO KNOW.
.
I JUST IT JUST AN OBSERVATION
WHEN YOU'RE GIVING YOUR YOUR
YOUR TALK MS OF NATHAN.
A LOT OF WHICH HE SAID HAD TO DO
WITH THE LETTER C..
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION
COLLEGIALITY IN TRUST
CONFIDENTIALITY CONSISTENT
PROCEDURES COMPREHENSIVE INVEST
INVESTIGATION A CULTURE OF NON
HARASSMENT AND CIVILITY. THERE'S
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT LETTER C..
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE I MOVE TO THE
NEXT.
.
PANEL A PEOPLE PERSON APPEARS
WANNA ASK A QUESTION ON BECAUSE
SOMETHING. SOME MEMBER REYES
MENTIONED ABOUT THE ANONYMOUS
REPORTING.
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE WHEN
REPORTS COME IN. THERE'S
ACTUALLY WROTE A REPORT PUT INTO
PERSONNEL FILE.
ABOUT ALL KINDS OF INCIDENTS IN
REPORTS.
HOW DO YOU? PUT ANONYMOUS
REPORTS AND IN A PERSONNEL FILE
SOMEWHERE AND IF SO HOW YOU HAVE
DUE PROCESS
WITHOUT.
THE.
I'M A PERSON WHO'S BEEN ACCUSED
BEING ABLE TO EVEN KNOW WHO THE
INDIVIDUAL IS WOULD YOU ONLY
ACCEPT THOSE FOR INVESTIGATION
BUT.
MAY HELP WHAT HOW DO YOU
EVALUATE WHAT YOU GOING TO DO
THAT INFORMATION GIVEN THAT IT'S
ANONYMOUS.
SO I WOULDN'T LEAVE RECIEVER
PORTS AND THAT IS ANONYMOUS AND
AND WE DO KEEP A FILE. IT
DOESN'T GO INTO ANYONE'S
PERSONNEL FILE IT'S KEPT
SEPARATE.
BUT WE DO. TRY TO. SEE IF
THERE'S ANY CORROBORATION TO THE
COMPLAINT THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD. AND AND MAKE A
DETERMINATION AFTER DOING AND
THAT COMPREHENSIVE
INVESTIGATION.
AND IT IT YOU KNOW IT DEPENDS
WHAT THE SITUATION AS IT COULD
BE REALLY GRAVEN IT COULD BE
SOMETHING. ABOUT A COMMENT
SOMEONE MADE THAT WAS UNWELCOME.
IF NOTHING TO ADD NIGHT OKAY SO
MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
.
HOW SHOULDN'T SOMEONE WHO
WITNESSES SEXUAL HARASSMENT?
?
SEE IF.
THE VICTIM SAYS THEY DON'T WANT
GET INVOLVED THEY DON'T WANT
PORTED.
.
HE KNOWS THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
THE WAY TO GO OR WHAT HAVE YOU
SEEN. I MEAN YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO WITNESSED
THINGS TO COME FORWARD AND.
YOU KNOW.
PICK OUT TO.
HOW WOULD THAT BE HANDLED IN THE
BEST WAY?
WELL AGAIN FROM ADVOCACY
PERSPECTIVE.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING OUT WHAT THE
SURVIVOR WANTS AND WHAT THE
SURVIVOR NEEDS AND IS CLEARLY.
I AND EXPRESS THAT THEY DID NOT
WISH TO REPORT THE INCIDENT.
.
THE FROM A TRAUMA INFORM
STANDPOINT DIET.
TAKING.
THERE WHAT THEY HAVE ASKED FOR
AND DOING OFFICE SAID WOULD READ
COULD BE RE TRAUMATIZING.
HOWEVER THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
THAT PEOPLE MIGHT PEOPLE TO AND
ADDRESS THE SITUATION SO CAN NOT
PERSON HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE PERSON WHO YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON THE INCIDENT AND
WHAT HAPPENS.
IS THERE ANOTHER WAY THAT THEY
COULD PERHAPS.
INSTILL SOMETHING THAT COULD
CHANGE THE SITUATION WITHOUT
HAVING YOU KNOW THIS PERSON TOLD
ME THAT THIS HAPPENED.
AND REALLY KIND OF THROWING THE
SURVIVOR.
UNDER THE BUS IF YOU WILL.
SO I THINK DOT WHEN WHEN WE
LOOK AT IT FROM AN ADVOCATE
ADVOCACY PERSPECTIVE WE REALLY
LOOK AT WHAT THE SURVIVOR WANTS.
AND IF THAT MEANS THAT THEY
DON'T WANT IT TO BE REPORTED.
DOING SO MAY CAUSE I RETIREMENT
HAZY XIN.
DESERVE THE OPTION YOU KNOW OF
SOMEONE TO SAY WELL WE WERE OUT
YOU KNOW AT A RECEPTION. AND SO
ON SO. WHOEVER THEN THE PERSON
IS.
.
DID THIS TO AN UNNAMED PERSON
YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE IT
SAY THERE ARE OTHER CLAIMS OUT
THERE THAT YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
IT CAN ACTUALLY HELP
CORROBORATE.
SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
BEING SAID WITHOUT IDENTIFYING
THE VICTIM.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO.
OBSERVE WHAT THEY'RE SEEN AND
TO BE ABLE TO.
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THAT.
WHILE ALSO TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
WHY SOMEONE WHO HAS SUFFERED
HARM WANTS TO SEE HAPPEN.
REALLY QUICK.
AND YOU MIGHT HAVE TO HELP ME
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IT EVEN.
PHRASE WHAT I'M TRYING TO ASK.
SINCE WE'VE BEEN STARTING THESE
HEARINGS I THINK IN NOVEMBER.
YOU KNOW.
WE STARTED HEARING ABOUT ISSUES
THAT HEAD.
CRUDE.
YEARS AGO A YEAR AGO OR YOU
KNOW.
NOTHING CURRENT EVEN.
AND.
THE I GUESS THIS IS MORE DRESSED
OUT WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE THE
PERPETRATOR.
THE KNOW WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST
WHERE. NOTHING HAPPENS THEY
STROVE TO WORK THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE ANY ISSUE THE. YOU
KNOW THE VICTIM.
S. FILE COMPLAINTS THEIR
SUFFERING ALL THESE THINGS
HAPPEN PEOPLE MOVED AROUND.
PEOPLE FIRED I YOU KNOW ALL
THAT'S IN THE PAST.
AND NOW WE'VE KIND OF MOVE
FORWARD TO THIS CURRENT TIME
WHERE. YOU KNOW IT'S MORE LIKE
NOW PEOPLE ARE STEPPING DOWN
PEOPLE ARE.
PUT A LEAVE PEOPLE ARE YOUNG
PAID PAID A YOU KNOW KIND OF A
DIFFERENT.
WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND IN BEST
PRACTICES WHEN A COMPLAINT COMES
AND HOW THE?
THE PERPETRATOR WAS DEALT WITH
ISN'T ALWAYS A CONSISTENT NO
MATTER WHAT THE CLAIM OUR HOUSE
THAT.
DON'T WITH.
I MEAN IS THERE APPEARED OF TIME
WHEN THEY.
NOTHING HAPPENS WHILE THINGS ARE
LOOKING AT IT OR.
AND ON A FROM ASKING THE RIGHT
THING BECAUSE NUMBER ONE TO BE
SURE THAT WE DEAL IN A WAY
THAT'S EFFECTIVE WITH. THE
PERPETRATOR.
AND NOT KIND OF NOT SURE WHAT
YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE TO FIND OUT IF THAT
THE.
COMPLAIN IT IS WORKING IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY AND IS GOING TO BE
AFFECTED BY THE BEHAVIOR US AS
YOU GO THROUGH THE INVESTIGATION
IS CRITICAL TO. TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE COMPLAINANT IS SAFE
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME AND.
.
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY WORK YOU
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE PEOPLE
AROUND FOR THAT TEMPORARY
PERIOD.
AND THAT'S WHY WE WANTED
CONDUCT THE INVESTIGATIONS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND HAVE A
RESPONSE READY AND INACTION.
IF.
THERE ARE SEVERAL COMPLAINTS
COMING IN ABOUT THE SAME
PERPETRATOR THEN. THAT'S A TRAIL
AND THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
MAY YOU THINK YOU KNOW WHAT WE
OFTEN HEAR FROM SURVIVORS INSIDE
NOTHING WAS DONE THAT THERE WAS
NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND MANY SURVIVORS WILL WILL
SAY THAT DIDN'T NECESSARILY.
WANT SOMEONE TO.
MAYBE EVEN BE FIRED BE
PROSECUTED ME WHAT WHAT HAVE YOU
BUT THEY WANT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY THEY WANTED THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THIS
ACTUALLY DID HAPPEN.
AND SO I THINK THAT FROM A
SURVIVOR PERSPECTIVE THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT BUT THERE IS SOME
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
YEAH AND IT JUST REMINDS ME A
LITTLE OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
A FEW OF THE VICTIMS IN THIS
BUILDING WHICH IS.
CERTAINLY IF YOU STOCKS OF TOLD
ME THAT WHEN THEY HAD FILED
COMPLAINTS THE FIRST AND THEY
WERE ASKED TO DO BY. OUR HR
DEPARTMENT WITH
HE SAID WELL IF YOU TOLD HIM HOW
IT MAKE HOW IT SAYS MAKES YOU
FEEL. WHICH TO ME IS JUST
INCREDIBLY INSENSITIVE.
AND IT WOULD NOT MAKE ANYBODY
WANT TO REPORT IF THAT'S THE
WORD THAT THEY SOMEHOW ARE
SUPPOSE TO. OWN OR CONTROL OR
RESPOND TO THEIROWN HARASSMENT
AND THAT KIND OF WAY. A SENATOR
MORE LEFT.
.
IN DEALING WITH BEST PRACTICES.
BEEN THINKING ABOUT.
THE CHAPTER MY WIFE.
MANY YEARS AGO TWO DECADES AGO
WHERE I TOOK OVER.
A DEPARTMENT IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT WAS
THAT THEIR INVESTMENT POLICY
STATEMENT WAS A JOKE AND SO WE
DECIDED TO.
PARA NEW INVESTMENT POLICY
STATEMENT.
YOU WERE TOLD AT THAT TIME I
BELIEVE IT WAS TO MUNICIPAL
TREASURES ASSOCIATION OF.
UNITED STATES AND CANADA.
THAT THEY HAD OUT A MODEL ON HOW
YOU COULD PREPARE YOUR AYE
INVESTING POLICY STATEMENT AND I
LOOKED IT UP.
I DIDN'T SEE THIS PUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO BUT BUT THEY HAVE
EIGHTEEN POINTS OF WHAT SHOULD
BE IN YOUR. IPS.
AND WE'VE BEEN.
CONTACTED PEOPLE IS THAT WHAT
YOU TRY TO GET CERTIFIED.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WE WOULD WE
NEED TO DO TO GET THE RIGHT AND
NUMBER POINTS TO GET CERTIFIED
SO. SO WE TRY TO BUILD. THE
MODEL INVESTMENT POLICY
STATEMENT FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE AND. WE GOT THE
CERTIFICATE.
AFTER ALL THAT WORK AND WE GOT
LIKE UBER TEASED BY ALSO GREAT
NOW YOU HAVE A CERTIFIED.
POLICY BUT WE GOT IT. WE GOT IT
DONE SO I'M. I'M LOOKING FOR THE
MODEL IN SO I'M ASSUMING THAT
YOUR BOTH IN SOME KIND OF HR
ASSOCIATION.
THAT'S MAYBE NATIONAL. AND I
HAVEN'T MIGHT DONE THE GOOGLE
SEARCH YET BUT.
WHAT WHAT WOULD THAT?
ASSOCIATION BE AND DO THEY HAVE
A SIMILAR PROCESS OF.
ASSISTING.
IN HELPING YOU.
PROVIDE THE COMPONENTS OF WHAT
UP A MODEL.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR HR.
MANUAL WOULD LOOK LIKE.
I CAN ANSWER THAT I AM ACTUALLY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF SOCIETY
FOR HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
WHICH IS THE LARGEST.
ORGANIZATION THAT'S NATIONAL
THE TWO HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY HAVE OFFICES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN FACT.
BUT THEY HAVE A BIG TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE THEY HAVE A HELP LINE
PEER.
HR MEMBERS CAN CALL. AND I GET
INFORMATION ON BEST PRACTICES ON
TRAINING IT'S IT'S A WORLD OF
INFORMATION THAT'S. READILY
ACCESSIBLE TO ANY HR
PROFESSIONAL THERE'S ALSO LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME IN AND.
.
I SACRAMENTO AS WELL.
HR ASSOCIATIONS THAT CAN.
WHEN CAN EASILY OBTAIN AYE
GUIDELINES ON BUILDING POLICIES.
SO DO THEY CERTIFY YOUR
POLICIES.
I'M.
THE JUNE NOT THAT I KNOW OF NO
NO CERTIFICATION OF POLICIES BUT
THEY HIVE AND.
.
TRY TO EMULATE NAM BLANKING ON
THE NAME.
.
SO SOME BEST PRACTICES FOR
REFERENCE BUT NOT SOMETHING THAT
IS CERTIFIABLE.
AND WE WERE TRYING TO TRANSFER
ONE SET OF SKILLS.
TO ANOTHER AREA. WE WOULD THEN
HAVE TO ABIDE BY THIS INVESTMENT
POLICY STATEMENT AND IF WE WERE
NOT IN COMPLIANCE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO REPORT THOSE
VARIANCES YEAH MAYBE WE BOUGHT
THE RUN. YEAH YOU KNOW RATED
INVESTMENT VEHICLE WHATEVER.
.
AND WE'VE BEEN HIRED OUTSIDE.
FIRMS TO.
CHECK ON OUR COMPLIANCE IS
THEY'RE. A SIMILAR.
CONSULTING GROUP OR SOME KIND
OF.
INDUSTRY GROUP THAT. REVIEWS HOW
YOU'RE MANAGING TO YOUR POLICY.
I BELIEVE THE IPS IS UNDER A
RISA APSA UNDER DO WELL THAT
MEET YOU REQUIRES THAT.
ORGANIZATIONS WHO DO HIVE A
RETIREMENT PLAN HIVE WHEN IN
PLACE.
AND THERE IS NO SUCH THING THAT
I'M AWARE OF HOWEVER THERE ARE
PLENTY OF CONSULTANTS WHO CAN
ASSIST IN BUILDING.
.
POLICIES AND ASSISTING WITH
SUPPORTING AND NOT AND UPPER.
SO.
IN THAT LINE OF THINKING. YOU'VE
HAD AN INCIDENT YOU RESEARCH
THAT YOU'VE INVESTIGATED
YOU'VE MET WITH THE PARTIES YOU
COME TO A CONCLUSION.
AND THEN YOU'D YOU DEAL WITH IT
TERMINATION OR WHATEVER THE CASE
IS. MINUTES OVER DO YOU EVER GO
BACK AND ASK.
THOSE PARTIES.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FAIR OR WAS
IT APPROPRIATE?
IS THE DICE YEAR IN A ROW YOU
KNOW SO THERE'S A LOT OF
EMOTIONS GOING ON BUT.
BUT BUT HOW DO WE KNOW THAT.
THAT WHAT WAS DONE WAS.
MAYBE THE BEST BECAUSE THIS IS
YOU KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT.
WITH THE MOTION SIR. I'M JUST
WONDERING ZERO A REVIEW PROCESS.
WELL I'M NOT HERE REPRESENTING
EACH OUR DEPARTMENT.
BUT I CAN SAY THAT I AM I CALL
COST SO WE HAVE PROVIDED A LOT
OF CONSULTATION AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE
TO COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
AROUND THERE POLICIES AND BEST
PRACTICES AND WE DO HAVE SOME.
LITERATURE ON RESOURCES THAT I
AM HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU ALL
AROUND THAT.
AND YOU KNOW I MENTIONED
CONFIDENTIAL ON CLIMATE SURVEYS
AS A TOOL FOR LOOKING OUT WHAT
DOES THE CLIMATE.
LOOK LIKE WHAT WATER PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOWARD THE FEELING
ABOUT.
POLICIES THAT OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
PRACTICES THAT ARE IN PLACE SO
THAT MAY BE A TOOL.
THEN.
.
FOR THE MUSEUM YOU HAVE FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES ARE ANY
OF THEM.
BOARD MEMBERS THAT ARE.
ELECTED. BY.
THE CONSTITUENCY.
WHERE UNDER LA COUNTY SO WE DO
YOU HOT WHERE UNDER THAT? WERE
UNDER THE TWO MEMBERS THAT ARE
PART OF
THAT.
.
YEAH I DID SO THEY'RE APPOINTED
BY YES THEY ARE PLENTY OF TEN OF
THEM EXACTLY OKAY HANDSOME POINT
IT. AND I'M.
YOU TREAT THEM JUST LIKE THEY
WERE EMPLOYEE OF THEY WERE NO WE
DON'T THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
SEPARATE.
.
I ORIENTATION.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN.
SO IT'S NOT UNDER MY DEPARTMENT.
IT'S DONE SEPARATELY.
IT'S I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHO WE GET TOO LITTLE TOO
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES HERE. TO
HAVE EXTRA EMPLOYEES IN THAT WE
HAVE ELECTED'S.
SO.
YOU HAVE A SEPARATE POLICY THEN
FOR THE I GUESS WILL CALM POINT
IT'S.
I CAN CHECK INTO A LOT AND
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU MANAGER IT'S AN
ADVISORY
CORRECT CORRECT.
YEAH THEORETICALLY THE PROBABLY
NOT IN THE WEEDS AND ON THE
PURPOSES THAT MUCH YOU KNOW
MEETINGS BUT.
I'M JUST LOOKING FOR A MODEL
YEAH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THIS
PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INPUT REALLY REALLY APPRECIATED
I THINK SO WITH THAT I'M GOING
TO BRING UP OUR SECOND PANEL.
DOLE'S FOCUSES ON REPORTING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT
NO LOGICAL ADVANCEMENT.
THIS IS GOING TO CONSIST OF JEFF
IRVINE FOUNDER PRESIDENT RICHARD
DOT COM.
BETH SCHROEDER COFOUNDER OF
CANDOR. AND LEYVA FLEMING.
TITLE FIVE COORDINATOR TYPES OR
TITLE NINE COORDINATOR FOR
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
AS YOU.
MAKE YOUR STATEMENTS FEEL FREE
TO ADD ANY INTRODUCTIONS THAT
YOU FEEL ARE RELEVANT.
OR ANY.
INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR
BACKGROUND SAID MIGHT BE AYE
INFORMATIVE AS TO YOUR
STATEMENTS AND THANK YOU AGAIN
VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY.
OKAY I HAVE A MISTER IRVINE IS
BEING THE FIRST ONE. AND YES IF
THIS CHARGE IS KAPUT NEWBIE NAME
BADGES THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
.
TESTING.
THANK YOU.
AGAIN I'M JEFF FOR VINE ON THE
FOUNDER BRIDGET.
WE BUILD.
SCHOOL SAFETY CAMPUS SAFETY AND
BUSINESS PLATFORMS
ALL AROUND THE. ALL AROUND
CREATING SOCIAL SAFETY NETWORKS.
.
I'MALSO HERE TODAY WITH DOCTOR
GLENN LIPSON WHO IS ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES.
AND WHAT WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
HIM.
IN THE SCHOOLS.
UP AND DOWN THE EAST COAST I
LIKE DOCTOR LIVES AND TO SPEAK
FOR A MINUTE AND INTRODUCED
HIMSELF AS WELL.
EVERYBODY.
MY.
WHICH IS THE SPARTAN OKAY.
AGAIN HELLO EVERYBODY I'M OF OF
CLINICAL INFERENCE EXIT COLLEGES
SO SO BY BACKGROUND I'VE BEEN
TESTIFYING FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
IN THE AREAS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
BACK IN THE LATE SEVENTIES
RECRUITED THE FIRST POLICIES I
WAS A STUDENT AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT FOR THE UC SYSTEM.
I TESTIFIED IN CASES THAT HAVE
INVOLVED BANKS POLICE
DEPARTMENTS FIRE DEPARTMENTS
SCHOOLS.
UP GOVERNMENT'S.
ENTITIES SOAPS A SCENARIO OF
THAT.
I'D DEFINITELY WORK ADAM I
DEALT WITH BINDING ARBITRATION
CLAUSES IN SOMEONE'S RIGHT TO
SUE THAT CASE WENT TO THE
SUPREME COURT. WAS AN EXPERT
INVOLVED IN THAT.
AND THIS IS AN AREA THAT I'VE
WORKED I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
ASSEMBLY FOR WHAT IT IS DONE
WITH ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. WITH THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS IT ADDED BULLYING
IN THE WORKPLACE AND THEN THIS
YEAR. UNITED GENDER IDENTITY AND
GENDER DIFFUSION IS THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED.
I ALSO BELIEVE.
I BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE
CENTRAL FEATURES IN BUILDING
SAFE WORKPLACES IS ALSO FOCUSING
ON ETHICS FOR GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES AT YOUR E. BE.
THREE FOUR BILL.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT WATER
APPROPRIATE RELATIONSHIPS THOSE
BECOME.
VERY IMPORTANT.
I WAS PRESENTING WITH ARE NOW
ACTING DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN SAN
DIEGO SUMMER STEPHAN. ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF SOCIAL MEDIA TO
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS TO
THE UP.
STOP HARASSMENT ABUSE AND RAPE
PREVENTION OF THE U. S. ARMY.
AND THROUGH THIS WORK I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. MEET JEFF
HIRVONEN AND AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE
WORLDWIDE WEB TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING THE OBJECT HAITIAN OF
WOMEN HOW YOU LOOK AT MINORITIES
IN GROUPS.
ONE OF THE THINGS IT BECAME
APPARENT TO ME AS WE NEED TO
HARNESS THIS.
SENSE OF ISOLATION THAT PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ACT WITH EACH
OTHER ANYMORE THAT NOT EVEN
CONVERSING ANYMORE THEY JUST
TEXTING EVEN WHEN THEY'RE OUT
ON.
DATES IN THEIR RESTAURANTS HOW
DO WE HELP PEOPLE CAN ACT. THAT
WE NEED TO USE SOME OF THE SAME
REMEDIES AND ACCOMPLISH THAT
THROUGH A PLATFORM THAT ASSISTS
PEOPLE.
IN LEARNING HOW TO INTERACT
REPORTING AND I WAS INTRODUCED
TO JEFF THROUGH INSURANCE
COMPANIES BECAUSE IN MY ROLE I
WORK WITH HR. REMEMBER
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION ARE BELONG TO SHARM.
DO WITH ALL THOSE ALL THOSE
SORTS OF ISSUES.
AND WHAT I BASICALLY FOUND IN
CONNECTING WITH JEFF IS THAT
THERE WERE RESTORATIVE PRACTICES
IN HERE AND THIS WAS BROUGHT UP
BY THE BY THIS COMMITTEE. WE'RE
LOOKING AT PREVENTION
WE DON'T WANT TO COME IN AS SOON
AS THEIR VICTIMS HOW DO WE HELP
PEOPLE PAY ATTENTION SO WE CATCH
THINGS EARLY ENOUGH WHERE THEY
DON'T PROGRESS.
TO WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF HARM.
AND WE HAVE FOUND A GENERATION
THAT IS MORE READY TO SEND
SOMETHING.
ARE THEY SEE SOMETHING THEY SEND
SOMETHING AND WE'VE CREATED IN
THIS PLATFORM INABILITY TO
RECEIVE SOMETHING THAT IS
SUPPORTIVE AND YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
ABOUT THAT. IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
WHAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
ON.
FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN ONLINE IS
THE BUILDING OF SOCIAL MOVEMENTS
SO PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL ALONE BUT
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO DO
NOT KNOW HOW TO CONNECT.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THESE PATHWAYS
WERE ABLE TO PREVENT THINGS AND
ONE OF THE MAIN PATHWAYS.
IS THE PROBLEM WITH ALCOHOL
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE EVENTS
TAKE PLACE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
INTOXICATED SO WE REALLY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE THINGS
HAPPEN AND HAD RESPOND. AND.
FOR ARM EVERYONE
SO THEREFORE WARNED AND WE AVOID
THESE TYPES OF EVENTS.
SO.
BRIDGET HAS SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS LIKE MYSELF IN ORDER TO
SAY WHAT ARE THE PATHWAYS
HOW CAN WE DO ASSESSMENTS HOW
CAN WE COLLECT DATA HOW COULD WE
RESPOND IN REAL TIME WHERE
PEOPLE FEEL SUPPORTED. AND WHAT
INFORMATION CAN WE PROVIDE THEM
THE THREE ABLE TO MAKE IT
THROUGH THESE EVENTS.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER IRVING BEFORE
YOU BEGIN I THINK I JUST ASK YOU
WE DIDN'T HAVE YOU INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA SO BEFORE YOU LEAVE
IF YOU COULD GIVE YOUR FULL NAME
TO THE SERGEANTS AT PERHAPS AND
THE BIO LATER. SO WE COULD BE
INCLUDED THE RECORDKEEPING OF
OUR AGENDA TODAY THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR OUR PROCESS.
THEY ABSOLUTELY.
SO BACKING UP TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE CONTEXT OVER THE LAST
EIGHT YEARS.
I BEEN WORKING WITH THE GROUP OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN THE
AREAS OF.
PSYCHOLOGY.
TITLE NINE.
FIRST AMENDMENT FOURTH
AMENDMENT.
.
SCHOOLS EDUCATORS PARENTS
TEACHERS AND THE LIKE AND WE
BUILT THESE PLATFORMS ALREADY IN
LAUNCH HIS PLATFORMS IN SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AS EVERYONE THING THAT'S
BEEN SAID BEFORE IT'S ALL TRUE.
ITS ABOUT ALL THE SEAS IT'S
ABOUT TRUST IT'S ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND SO AS WE BACK UP AND WE LOOK
AT WHY HAS CULTURE CHANGE SO
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND IT HAS BEEN IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND IT'S BECAUSE
COMMUNICATION HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY.
AND WITH THAT CHANGE
COMMUNICATION.
THE CULTURAL CHANGE CAME.
WE A BRIDGET AND SAFE CAMPUS ON
EVERYTHING THEY WERE DOING ITS
ALL AROUND HARNESSING THAT SAME
SOCIAL TECHNOLOGY THAT SAME PUSH
TECHNOLOGY. THAT SAME IMMEDIATE
FEEDBACK LOOP.
IN ORDER TO CREATE DIGITAL PEER
PRESSURE.
TO CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CREATE POSITIVELY IN A RESTORED
OF ENVIRONMENT.
WHITE NOW WE ARE ALL OVER RUN
IMMEDIATELY.
BY THE IMMEDIATE POST THERE'S NO
TIME TO REACT.
THERE'S NO TIME TO CORRECT
PUBLIC SHAMING IS NOW THE NORM.
EVERYTHING THAT'S GETS POSTED
THAT'S NOT TRUE AND OR HURTFUL
OR HARMFUL.
REGARDLESS OF PERSPECTIVE IS
PUBLIC SHAMING AND IS THE MOST
DIVISIVE TOOL HUMAN BEING HAS.
SO WE COME AT THIS.
THE PROBLEM AND ITS GLOBAL
PROBLEM A IN EVERY CULTURE
CUTTING ACROSS EVERY RACE.
EVERY EVERY TYPE. YOU KNOW IT
EVERYONE'S HAS THE SAME PROBLEM
AROUND THE WORLD
SO THE WHOLE IDEA IS TO.
CHANGE THE CULTURE AND IT'S IT'S
ABOUT LEADERSHIP AT THE TOP.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
LEADERSHIP.
TAPPING THE STUDENTS
OR THE MEMBERS.
OR THE LOBBYISTS OR THE BUS
DRIVERS OR THE PARENTS AND
EMPOWERING THEM.
TO SET THE STANDARDS THAT YOU
WANT IN TERMS OF CULTURE TO
OPTIMIZE CULTURE VARIES IS SAY
THESE WORDS VERY HARD TO DO.
OUR PLATFORMS ARE BUILT ON THE
RESEARCH OF DR DOROTHEA
SUPPLIES.
SHE IS THE LEADING RESEARCHER
AND OWLING HUSSMAN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE COUNTRY OF THE
LAST TWENTY TWO YEARS TO HOUSE.
OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
ILLINOIS FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS
NOW SHE WORKS OUT OF FLORIDA.
BUT HER.
WHOLE.
RESEARCH WAS BASED ON HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU CREATE MORE POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE RIGHT. AND YOU
CAN ONLY DO THAT BY ALIGNING.
THE PARENT AND TEACHER IN THE
CHARACTER EDUCATION OF THE
STUDENT.
SAME APPLIES TO ANY CAMPUS AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL OR TO ANY
WORKPLACE.
SO IT'S ABOUT SETTING STANDARDS
AND TO VININGS TO FINDING.
TO THAT END AS WE LOOK AT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WHICH WERE FOCUSED ON
HERE TODAY. AND I'VE PARTNERED
WITH THE WE SAID ENOUGH.
.
GROUP OUT OF OUT OF SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE THEY HAPPEN VIA HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH ME AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING SCHOOLS ON PRIVACY.
AND ISSUES ALONG THOSE AND. BUT
AS WE FOCUS ON SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
AND SOCIAL SEXUAL HARASSMENT YOU
HAVE TO START BUTTON FINDING IT.
AND AND MAKING IT EASY TO DEFINE
AND AN EASY TO UNDERSTAND.
AND SO AS WE PUT TOGETHER OUR
SYSTEMS WE WANTED TO DO THAT ON
BOTH A VISUAL BASIS WITH ICONS.
THAT A NON THREATENING AND ON
TRIGGERING.
AND BUT ALSO WITH DEFINITIONS
THAT ARE UNDERSTANDABLE ACROSS
ALL THE VARIOUS GROUPS THAT ARE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE REALIZED
AS WE LAUNCH THESE PLATFORMS IN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY IS THAT. YOU WANT THE
DETERRENT YOU WANT PREVENTION.
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALWAYS SET
STANDARDS ON A FACE TO FACE
BASIS AND WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
INTERPERSONAL LOOKED EACH OTHER
IN THE EYE AND HAD
CONVERSATIONS.
UNTIL THE PHONE CAME ALONG RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T HAVE TO LOOK PEOPLE
IN THE I MEAN JUST PRESS THE
BUTTON HITS AND THEN MAYBE THEY
GOT IT MAYBE THEY DIDN'T MAYBE
THEY INTERPRETED CORRECTLY. OR
MAYBE THE HOT.
BUT IF YOU CAN TAKE THAT'S IF
YOU REALIZE THAT.
DIGITAL PEER PRESSURE IS NOW
ACHIEVABLE RIGHT FACE TO FACE
PEER PRESSURE IS ALWAYS BEEN
ACHIEVABLE FOR IN THIS ROOM WERE
ALL GOING TO ACT A CERTAIN WAY.
BUT IF YOU CAN CREATE DIGITAL
PEER PRESSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY.
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN THINGS
START TO GET BETTER.
BECAUSE YOU CHANGE THE RISK
REWARD AROUND THE BAD BEHAVIOR
YOU'VE CHANGED YOU BROUGHT THEM
OUT OF THE ANONYMOUS STARK INTO
THE LIGHT. AND IN DOING THAT YOU
NOW START TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE CAN
BENEFIT FROM IN TERMS OF MOBILE
TECHNOLOGY IS DATA.
AYE MEAN DATA WORKS WE WILL USE
IN SO MANY POSITIVE WAYS RIGHT
NOW AROUND THE WORLD.
WE CAN DO IT AROUND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ABUSE BOWLING
HARASSMENT.
AND YOU CAN DO IT BY STARTING
GATHERS DATA HAD A TIME AND
OFTEN. AND IF YOU CAN GATHER
THAT DATA YOU CAN START TO SEE
TRAIN TRENDS AND AS YOU START TO
SEE TRENDS YOU CAN BECOME
PROGRESS PREDICTIVE.
AND THAT ALLOWS LEADERSHIP TO
SET POLICY AND DIRECT LIMITED
RESOURCES MORE EFFECTIVELY.
I LOOK AT THE WORLD AS
EVERYTHING THE TRANSACTION I
LOOK AT YOU I SMILE YOU SMILE
BACK AT THE POSITIVE TRANSACTION
I LOOK AT YOU YOU DON'T SMILE
BACK. THAT'S A NEUTRAL OR
NEGATIVE.
IT'S HARD TO THE NUMBER
TRANSACTIONS ON A BEHAVIORAL
LEVEL THAT GO ON EVERYDAY THAT
CAN BE CONSTRUED AND OR
MISCONSTRUED. PHENOMENAL NUMBERS
RIGHT NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
GENERALLY MANAGE FROM THE TOP
DOWN STRATEGY BUT IT IS
SOMETHING WORK CAN BE FROM A
COMMUNITY WIDE.
STANDARD WHERE EVERYONE'S
WATCHING EACH OTHER'S BACK.
SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME.
WORKING WITH VARIOUS ALL THE
VARIOUS GROUPS FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES ON THE
FINANCIAL SIDE TO LEGISLATORS TO
LEADING LEGAL MINDS ON PRIVACY
AND LIABLE.
TO PUT TOGETHER A PLATFORM THAT
ACTUALLY COULD WORKED EVERYONE'S
INTEREST.
AND SO TODAY I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
SHORT VIDEO. ON THE WE SAID
ENOUGH. WHICH WE ARE GOING TO
LAUNCH SOMETIME IN THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR WEEKS.
AND THAT WAS DESIGNED TO GATHER
DATA.
NOT POINT A FINGER TO DEBT BUT
UNDERSTAND THE METRICS AND THE
THE EXPANSIVENESS OF THE PROBLEM
AS IT RELATES NOT ONLY
CALIFORNIA BUT AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WITH THAT DATA WHICH WILL
SHARE WITH RESEARCHERS AND
LEGISLATORS AROUND THE WORLD ON
A DE IDENTIFIED BASIS.
START TO SEPARATE POLICIES.
AND AM NOW MORE INFORMED
POLICIES.
TO THAT AND SO WHY DON'T I PLAY
THE VIDEO BECAUSE OF TOUGH TOO
MUCH AND. THEM WHEN GOVERNMENT.
MY FIRST TIME.
WELCOME TO WE SAID ENOUGH
ADDITIONAL PLATFORM THAT CREATES
A COMMUNITY OF SURVIVORS
VOLUNTEERS AND ACTIVISTS TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE SOCIAL SUPPORT
TO VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BULLYING.
STARTED THREE.
IF I REPORT PRESS THE PLUS
BUTTON AT THE BOTTOM OF YOUR
SCREEN AND ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
IN A PROPOSED.
WHEN DID THE INCIDENT HAPPENED.
BUT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH
SCHOOL COLLEGE OR IN THE
WORKPLACE
HOW YOU INVOLVED I WAS THE
VICTIM AYE PARTICIPATE AYE SIDE.
WHAT WAS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE AGGRESSOR WAS SOMEONE YOU
KNEW?
CHAIR RELATIVIST IMPROVISER
I'M A BUSINESS.
WE PHYSICALLY THREATENED YES OR
NO.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE WOULD
HAVE?
SELECT VERBAL ABUSE HARASS IN
THE WORKPLACE HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND LIKE DETACHING
REPUTATION ON SHAMING ANY
MILLION ASIAN.
FROM THERE YOU CAN SELECT WHAT
HAPPENS
THE WORKPLACE ONLINE AT A BAR
AFTER WORK ON A AIRPLANE ON THE
BUSINESS.
AS
PARAMOUNT'S IN THE RELATIONSHIP
IN TERMS OF THE WORKING BY.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF WHETHER IT
IS PHYSICAL A PURELY SOCIAL AND.
WAS ANYONE WHO WITNESSED THE
INCIDENT.
DIDEVERYONE NOW JUST ME.
FOR A FEW PEOPLE.
AFTER THAT
IN WRITING AND.
YOU MAY WANT OF COURSE.
SERVICE REMINDERS YOU AS YOU CAN
TO REVEAL EVERYTHING
BUT AGAIN.
NOW GREATER THE TERM
CONDITIONS
FOR HE SAID THAT THE REPORT.
IF YOU DO IT PART OF MATHIS.
ACTORS AND RESOURCES
TO HELP YOU.
THE WE SENATE THAT HELP NOW
IT'S DESIGNED TO
THE USERS
MEANING THAT THEY'RE NOT ALONE.
CORD IS DOCUMENT.
I DON'T ACT THE.
AND.
EACH NUMBER OF THE MAP IS
ASSOCIATED
TOTAL NUMBER REPORT
FILED IN THAT AREA.
AS THE USERS IN WAS IN AND OUT
THE.
PHONE NUMBERS.
DAHLE DATING TO.
WHEN THE USER CLICKS ON A DOT.
DO YOU SEE OF AN ANONYMOUS.
CORD AND.
WILL MISCONDUCT
WITHIN THAT PARTICULAR AREA.
IN THE OPERATING
THE MATH THERE
WOULD ALLOW THE USE.
THE MAP OVER ANYTIME.
FOR THE DATA.
CAN YOU TO REPORT.
YOU REPORTS MADE ANONYMOUSLY.
FOR.
AND THE ME TOO OR I SUPPORT YOU
BY.
CREATING A COMMUNITY OF LOVE AND
FOR.
BEWARE THAT.
THE WORLD.
SHARE X.
AND WE OUTSIDE.
IN ORDER TO DONATE TO THE
NOT FOUNDATION.
ON THE MENU ON THE LOWER LEFT
HAND.
AND THEN CLICK.
WITH A LITTLE HARD TO SAY.
IT WAS A LITTLE HARD TO SEE BUT
IT'S ALL ICON.
DEFINITE
EVERYTHING.
MAKING IT EASY TO COMMUNICATE A
PROBLEM ACCURATELY AT THE TIME
THE PROBLEMS HAPPEN AT THE TIME
THE BOUNDARY CROSSINGS HAPPENING
AND RECORD IT. AND THEN LEAVE IT
UP TO YOUR CHOICE AS TO WHETHER
YOU CAN REPORT IT NOW AT A LATER
DATE.
THAT'S EMPOWER.
HAVING FEEDBACK LOOPS WHEN
YOU'VE BEEN HARASSED IN A
CERTAIN WAY AND SOMEONE ELSE CAN
IDENTIFY YOU WITH YOU AND
SUPPORT YOU ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
DON'T. YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT ALONE
AND WE KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WHEN YOU'VE BEEN HARASSED
OR ABUSED OR BEATEN UP OR
POLICE.
IS TO IMMEDIATELY FIND SUPPORT
WHETHER WITHIN YOUR COMMUNITY
WITHIN YOUR FAMILY OR ELSEWHERE.
AND SO THESE TOOLS ARE JUST THAT
THEIR TOOLS THERE TOOK
COMMUNICATION TOOLS.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO YOU KNOW
BOUNDARY TOOLS
WHICH WE HAVE ON A FACE TO FACE
LEVEL BY DEFAULT.
ON A DIGITAL LEVEL WE CAN NOW
HAVE.
Q..
SURE THEY'LL BE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU IN A MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO MISS
SCHROEDER.
CUTE FACE OUT FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE OPPORTUNITY OF
AND CHAIR WOMEN ARE.
THAT'S FRIEDMAN AND MAKE
MITCHELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE RULES COMMITTEE. ON MY
NAME IS SPECIAL LATER AND.
I'M HERE AS A COFOUNDER OF
CANDOR. AND POWER THE TECHNOLOGY
PANEL BUT I AM ANYTHING BUT THE
TECHNOLOGY SPECIALIST AYE YOU
NEED MY CHILDREN TO HELP ME. ON
JAN MY COMPUTER.
SO I MY BACKGROUND IS AS A
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST
I'VE BEEN OF A PARTNER IN A LAW
FIRM AND I'M BEEN PRACTICING
LABOR EMPLOYMENT OFF THE LAST.
HIT SAY THIRTY THREE YEARS.
SO THAT IS MY BACKGROUND AND I
HAVE BEEN HONORED TO BE A PART
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN APP
CALLED CANDOR. WHICH HAS
LAUNCHED A LITTLE UNDER A MONTH
AGO. AND.
I CAME UP WITH THE IDEA FOR
CANDOR BECAUSE OUT OF MY
FRUSTRATION.
OF BEING A LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
A. PARTNER IN ATTORNEY AND
WATCHING PEOPLE NOT BRING OF.
REPORTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
OTHER THINGS FORWARD.
WE DID NOT DEVELOP CANDOR AS A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TAP IT'S SORT
OFIRONIC THAT WE ARE THAT THIS
WATERSHED MOMENT IN TIME. AND IS
SITTING HERE BEFORE A GROUP OF
YOU STEAMED A COLLEAGUES.
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE AND THAT
WE'RE HERE IN WITH THIS. THIS
ISSUE IN THIS INTERESTING POINT
IN TIME TO MEET TO MOVEMENT.
BUT WE ACTUALLY STARTED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CANDOR.
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
.
IT'S MY EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY.
WORK WITH BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT I'VE BEEN HEARING SEVERAL
OCCASION.
MEETING WITH MANY OF YOU
THAT USUALLY MY CLIENTS AS
BUSINESS OWNERS.
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING WHEN
CLAIMS OF HARASSMENT. COME UP IN
FLAMES AND OTHER.
KIND OF THOUGHT ISSUES OF RACIAL
HARASSMENT OTHER KINDS OF
WRONGFUL CONDUCT ONCE THEY KNOW
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
BUT.
TOO OFTEN THOSE ISSUES DON'T
DON'T ARISE DON'T COME TO THE
RIGHT PEOPLE AND THAT PEOPLE
DON'T BRING THOSE CLAIMS
FORWARD.
IN FACT THE ACTING CHAIR OF THE
EEOC I THINK RECENTLY SAID THEY
BELIEVE THAT ONLY ONE IN FOUR
CLAIMS OF HARASSMENT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
ARE MADE.
AND THE REST LIMON AHMED.
WHEN I TAKE DEPOSITIONS A PEEP
ABOUT PEOPLE IN LAWSUITS.
I AND THEY TESTIFIED THAT THEY
DON'T BRING THEIR CLAIMS FORWARD
BEFORE FILING LAWSUITS
USUALLY IT'S BECAUSE.
FOR EXAMPLE THEY.
COULDN'T FIND THE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER OR THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO REACH THAT ARE.
THE HER YOU KNOW THE E. R. HR
PEOPLE OR THEY LOST THEIR HIT
THEIR HANDS HIM LOOKS AT AYE
DRAFT IS VERY FRUSTRATING THAT'S
BEEN LONGTIME DRAFTING THOSE
HANDBOOKS THAT PEOPLE CAN'T
FIND.
THE POLICIES ARE GREAT I KNOW
HOW THE POLICIES ARE WRITTEN
THEIR GREAT COMPLAIN POLICIES I
CAN TELL YOU. BUT PEOPLE LOSE
THOSE POLICIES THEY GET THEM
THEY READ THEM AND THEN THEY
TOSS THEM ASIDE.
NO ONE HAS THE POLICIES.
SO.
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO FIND A WAY
THAT PEOPLE WOULDN'T LOSE THE
POLICIES PEOPLE WOULDN'T LOSE
THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBERS
PEOPLE WOULDN'T.
SAY THEY COULDN'T GET A HOLD OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY WERE
THERE TO HELP THEM.
SO ONE DAY OUT OF FRUSTRATION
AFTER LISTENING TO PEOPLE
TESTIFY OVER AND OVER IN A LARGE
CLASS ACTION I WAS INVOLVED IN.
I WOKE UP IN MIDDLE THE NINETIES
AND HOW WE CAN TO HELP THESE
PEOPLE NOT LOSE. THOSE PHONE
NUMBERS AND THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBERS AND THOSE HOTLINE
NUMBERS
I THOUGHT. YOU KNOW WHAT PEOPLE
NEVER LOSE THESE DAYS.
THEIR PHONES THERE ARE PHONES.
SO THAT YOU KNOW SOMEONE TO COME
UP WITH NOW.
AND MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE PRETTY MUCH THESE DAYS.
TO LOSE SOMETHING.
SO A YEAR AND A HALF AGO I
THOUGHT OF THIS IDEA.
AND WE STARTED THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF WHAT IS NOW CANDOR.
AND.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING
THAT ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM HAS
SAID TODAY ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF TRAINING.
THE IMPORTANCE OF OF WORKING
WITH VICTIMS OF THE IMPORTANCE
WAS CREATING A CULTURE OF
RESPECT BECAUSE. I DO ALL THOSE
THINGS.
I WORK WITH MANAGERS I TRAIN.
MANAGERS I TRAINED STAFF I HAVE
SPENT MORE TIME IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS BY THE WAY TRAINING STAFF
AND MANAGERS THAT I WANT TO TELL
YOU.
I COULD PROBABLY DO THIS FULL
TIME.
AND BODY WEIGHT BIG SUPPORTER
OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE TWO
AND ALL THE CHANGES OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
ARE BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO GO IN THE
WORKPLACES AND WORK WITH
EMPLOYEES AND MANAGERS AND DO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
I SEE OUR APT IS ONLY AN ADDED.
PART OF ALL OF THAT.
BUT ONE THING WE DO BRING TO THE
TABLE IS THE ABILITY OF
EMPLOYEES TO REACH OUT AND GET A
HOLD OF SOMEONE.
WHEN MAYBE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT. THEIR LOSING SLEEP AND
THEY.
CAN'T FIND ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT.
BECAUSE AS BEEN SAID BY MY
COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT.
SOMETIMES THESE DAYS PEOPLE JUST
IN THE PAST.
THEY CAN'T WALK INTO A ROOM.
AND. ARE APP GIVES PEOPLE THE
OPTION.
OF SWITCHING THE BUTTON TO THE
LEFT AND MAKING ANONYMOUS IT
ISN'T AUTOMATICALLY ANONYMOUS
BUT THEY CAN CREATE A PROFILE.
WITH THEIR NAME ON IT AND
ANYTIME THEY CAN MAKE IT
ANONYMOUS AND THEN YOU CAN
CHOOSE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
IN AN ANONYMOUS FASHION.
NOW ARE AT.
DOES NOT NECESSARILY
CHARACTERIZE ANYTHING IS
HARASSMENT IN FACT WE HAVE THREE
OPTIONS THEY SAY. YOU CAN MAKE A
SUGGESTION. YOU CAN ASK A
QUESTION AND YOU COULD ASK FOR
HELP.
BECAUSE WE DON'T ASSUME THAT
THIS IS A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
REPORTING I REMEMBER I DIDN'T
DEVELOP IT THAT WHAT. THIS IS
JUST A COMMUNICATION TOOL.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE EMPLOYEE
ENGAGEMENT WE THINK THAT OPENING
UP COMMUNICATION.
IS WHAT MAKES EMPLOYEES FEEL
MORE FULFILLED.
IN FACT ALL THE MILLENNIALS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
EMPLOYEES ONE BEING GAUGE THAT'S
WHAT. MAKES PEOPLE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT BEING A PART THE
WORKPLACE.
AND IN GENERAL THAT MAKES
PEOPLE.
FEEL VALUED AND INCREASES.
YOUR PRODUCTIVITY THE WORKPLACE
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM.
BUT OF COURSE.
PART OF THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
COURSE YOU KNOW THESE DAYS HAS
BEEN HARASSMENT AND YOU CAN
CONTROL TO THAT ISSUE TO.
SO.
AS PART OF THIS COMMITTEE OF
COURSE THAT'S WHERE ADDRESSING
AND IT CAN BE USED FOR THAT TOO
SO WE HAVE A SHORT.
VIDEO.
USUALLY DO THIS.
.
LIVE AND I APOLOGIZE AGAIN SINCE
TECHNOLOGY IS MY MY STRENGTH.
.
I'M GOOD PRESS DEATHS.
IT IS OUR LITTLE PRE RECORDED
VIDEO.
AND.
YEAH SO THIS IS OKAY.
FULL.
BUT.
SO THIS SHOULD BE A SCREEN THAT
YOU WOULD GET PULLING THEM BACK.
RIGHT SO YOU CAN YOU CAN ONLY.
ON THE BACK.
YEAH.
WHAT I GET? SAGA PERFECT WHAT SO
START. BECAUSE THIS WOULD BE HOW
COME UP WHEN YOU HAVE A YOUR.
PROFILE ESTABLISHED.
AND YOU HAVE THE OPTIONS I HAVE
AN IDEA OF THE QUESTION I'M
HELPING YOU CLICK ON ANY OF
THOSE.
AND THEY WOULD GET FILED IT
DOESN'T THERE'S A AYE DEPLOYER
DASHBOARD.
THAT WOULD BE ON THE EMPLOYER
SIDE.
SO DEPENDING ON WHICH ONE OF
THESE COMES UP IT WILL GET.
FILE ON HIM.
SEPARATELY YOU CAN ORGANIZE IT
SEPARATELY.
SO EMPLOYEE WOULD PUT SHOES AT.
AND THEN AT THAT POINT.
LET'S SAY THE DESIGNEE HELP
WHICH WOULD PROBABLY HOW WOULD
WOULD REGISTERED IF IT'S A
HARASSMENT COMPLAINT.
SO THEY CAN SHOW THEIR NAME.
AND YOUR NAME COME UP.
AND AT THAT POINT THEY CAN PICK
WHO THE MESSAGE GOES TO NOW WHEN
THE EMPLOYER SETS IT UP FOR.
YOU KNOW HOWEVER WHOEVER BY THE
LATE.
IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE HOW IT'S
DESIGNED SO IF IT WERE FOR.
LIKE THIS YOU CAN DECIDE WHO.
THE MESSAGES BEGETS SEND TO AND
IT WOULD BE SHOWN. BOTH THE
PERSON'S NAME AND THEIR JOB
TITLE BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE.
FOR SOME COMPANIES YOU MAY KNOW
SOMEBODY AS HUMAN RESOURCES ARE
YOU MAY KNOW THEM BY THEIR NAMES
SO WE WOULD WANT THEM TO KNOW.
AND AN EMPLOYEE MAY FEEL
COMFORTABLE LETTING EVERYBODY IN
THAT GROUP THAT A COPY BUT THEY
MAY SAY WAIT A MINUTE I DON'T
WANT THIS PERSON A COP BECAUSE
OF A PROBLEM WITH THAT PERSON.
SO I'M GONNA DE SELECT.
ONE OR A COUPLE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
SO YOU CAN SEE DIESEL LET SOME%
OF THESE PEOPLE BUT NOT ALL OF
THEM BECAUSE THOSE BE THE PEOPLE
WHO WOULD NORMALLY GET A COPY.
THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE CAUGHT
REVIEWERS WHO WOULD BE LIKE YOUR
CECE'S
SO FOR EXAMPLE.
I LIKE TO WORK WITH RESTAURANTS
SO YOU WOULD THOSE PEOPLE WOULD
BE MORE FOR EXAMPLE MAYBE YOUR
G. SEES.
OR YOUR HR PEOPLE BUT MAYBE I
WANT MY MANAGER AT THE
RESTAURANT TO GET A COPY NINE
MAY NOT WHAT MY MANAGER WITH A
COPY BUT IT WOULD BE MY CHOICE.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT CHOICE IT ALSO
WOULD SHOW YOUR LOCATION.
NOW IF YOU GO TO.
HI MY NAME.
FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT WOULD MAKE ANONYMOUS.
ONCE SYNONYMOUS.
I DON'T KNOW IF I GET A COPY WHO
THAT PERSON IS COMES UP
ANONYMOUS NOT ANY POINT IN THE
ANONYMOUS CONVERSATION IF I'M
THE PERSON SENDING THE MESSAGE.
I CAN CHOOSE TO REVEAL MY NAME
AS YOU SEE IT THERE AS ANONYMOUS
NO ONE WILL SHOT KNOW YOUR
IDENTITY UNLESS YOU LATER. SHOES
TO REVEAL IT.
BECAUSE AS A CONVERSATION IS
GOING FORWARD.
I MAY DECIDE I FEEL COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH THAT I WANT TO REVEAL MY
IDENTITY.
BUT I MAY NOT AND THAT'S
COMPLETELY ON ME AS THE PERSON
SENDING THE MESSAGE.
SO.
IF YOU SEE HERE THEN THEN SEND A
MESSAGE TO AND YOU GET THE
CHOICE OF WHO THE PERSON GETS
SENT TO.
AND THEY GOT THOSE CHOICES.
SO THEY GET DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AND THEY CONSIDER TO BY THE WAY.
AREN'T YOU CAN ALSO.
AS WELL SEE IMMINENT.
THEIR OPTIONS AS THE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES YOU CAN SEND IT AND I
THINK WE'RE UP TO LIKE TWELVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES IF YOU CAN
SEND IN BUDGET CLICKING ON THE
TRANSLATE BUTTON.
AND HE'S A DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
YOU CONSENTED TO OF THE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS AT THE
COMPANY HAS. THEN ONCE IT'S
CHOSEN YOU CAN SEND THE MESSAGE.
AND THEN ISN'T THERE'S AN
IMMEDIATE MESSAGE THAT IS SENT.
THAT'S THE ANONYMOUS MESSAGE.
THE GOOD MEDIA MESSAGE SENT AND
OF COURSE THE BE A CUSTOMIZED
MESSAGE THAT SENT BY THEM.
OBVIOUSLY EMPLOYER.
GETS PINK IMMEDIATELY.
NOW I CAN SEND PHOTOS AS WELL.
OR VIDEOS.
IF THEY NEED TO.
BECAUSE IF WE OBVIOUSLY KNOW THE
SOMETIMES THOSE ARE THOSE ARE.
THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO ATTACH
IT TO SEND.
THEY MAY BE PIECES OF EVIDENCE
THAT MAY BE THINGS THAT THEY
WANT US TO SEE.
IN THE WORKPLACE.
SO I CAN GET ATTACHED.
AND THEN THE CITY THE INBOX AT
THE EMPLOYEE WOULD HAVE THAT
WOULD HAVE THEIR MESSAGES AS
WELL. ORGANIZED.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO A COPY OF
HANDLE POLICIES SO THE EMPLOYER
HAS HIM A POLICIES OR FORMS OR
ANYTHING THAT THEY WANT ON THE.
I MEAN OF PHONE.
THAT WOULD BE A COPY SO THAT WE
ALWAYS HAVE ACCESS TO THAT SO
THEIR RESOURCES ARE ALWAYS THERE
AND HAD ANY ORGANIZATIONAL MAN
IN THAT THE EMPLOYER WANTS THEM
TO SEE THEM.
AGAIN BECAUSE I GET FRUSTRATED
THAT NOBODY EVER KEEP COPIES OF
THEIR HANDS.
THAT WE WORK SO HARD TO WRITE.
SO THAT THEY ARE AS WELL.
NOW.
THEN.
IN ADDITION TO THAT.
THIS WOULD BE A COPY OF.
WHAT BR SORRY WITH THE WHAT?
EMPLOYER DASHBOARD WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
SO THE EMPLOYER DASH FOR HIS
ENTIRE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
WHICH IS WHICH IS. ALL THE
MESSAGES THAT ARE CAPPED
AND THE CAN BE ORGANIZED AND
FILED BY BY THE EMPLOYER. THEY
CAN MEET TAD SO THEY CAN BE.
NORMALLY WE HAVE A WHOLE DEL
MURPHY THE YOU CAN MEET HAD THEM
COLOR CODING SEARCHABLE.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE NOW AS
WE'RE DOING VERSION TWO IS YOU
CAN KEEP NOTES.
AND YOU CAN SHARE THE NOTES
SO YOU CAN KEEP NOTES ALONG SIDE
THE WHOLE TIME IN REAL TIME CITY
MAKE NOTES ALONGSIDE AND THEN
YOU CAN ALSO HAVE THE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO THIS.
IT ALSO SHARE NOTES AMONGST
THEMSELVES THEN OF COURSE YOU
CAN EXPORT ALL OF THAT IF YOU
NEED TO HAVE SOMEONE LIKE YOUR
ATTORNEY. HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
THAT.
SO BECOME THE ENTIRE CASE
MANAGEMENT SAYS.
SO AGAIN WE DON'T EXPECT THAT.
COMMUNICATING BY AN APP IS GOOD
EVER REPLACE HUMAN INTERACTION I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE A FIRST
STEP IN AN INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN WE WOULD HOPE THAT
PEOPLE WOULD COMMENT ON HAVE A
LIVE INTERACTION. BUT THERE MAY
BE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE
NEVER REVEAL THEMSELVES AND THEN
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE. NO
COMMUNICATION AND THIS OBVIOUSLY
THEN YOU COULD HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES AND THINGS THAT ARE
PART OF AN INVESTIGATION.
IT'S GONNA BE AN INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW PART OF OUR OF OUR.
METRICS TO LOOK AND SEE HOW WE
CONTINUE TO INVESTIGATE THE
CLAIMS THAT REMAIN ANONYMOUS
HUNDREDS AND TIME THAT SOMETHING
WE HAVEN'T.
HOW A LOT OF AL AND LOT OF
INTERACTION WITH BUT WILL LEARN
AS WE GO UP?
BUT ONE THING WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DO IS INCREASE OUR ABILITY TO
GET INFORMATION AND HOPEFULLY
INCREASE PEOPLE COMING FORWARD
SO THAT WE DON'T LOOK AT. ONE IN
FOUR PEOPLE COMING FORWARD.
IN THESE RASKIN CLAIMS WILL
INCREASE THIS TO MAYBE TWO WEARS
THREE OUT OF FOUR PEOPLE COMING
FORWARD. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
I WHAT WE WILL BE DOING DOWN THE
LINE AND WELL AS BEING ABLE TO
ALSO INCREASE THE ABILITY OF
THIS AND USE IT FOR THINGS LIKE
TAKING SURVEYS. HAS BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT AND
INCREASING OUR ABILITY TO
MEASURE METRICS AS WELL.
ABOUT THINGS LIKE NOT JUST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT EMPLOYEE
ENGAGEMENT EMPLOYEE MOODS THAT
KNOW HOW EMPLOYEES FEELING ABOUT
SHOWING. ISSUES IN THE WORKPLACE
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING DOWN THE ROAD
WITH OUR DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
BACK.
AGAIN IT'S ANOTHER WAY TO ENGAGE
EMPLOYEE WORKFORCE AND TAKE THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE EMPLOYEES.
IN THE WORKPLACE AND THAT'S LIKE
I SAID MY COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT
SAID THIS IS A WAY THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
US THESE DAYS WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE THAT.
FUMIGATION TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MISS FARMING. NEAR.
OR THE CLIPPERS.
THAT.
PERFECT. ALRIGHT ALL GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
LEAH FLEMING I AM THE TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND OF MY ROLE HERE IS TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR INSTITUTION WHERE
JUDGE WHO INSTITUTION CATHOLIC.
COLLEGE OR TITLE NINE OFFICES
VERY PLEASED ABOUT THREE YEARS
I'M SO LIKE MANY UNIVERSITIES
AND THIS COMING AGE OF MANY MORE
REPORT. I'M BEFORE THIS ME
COMPLETES AROUND SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT WERE PRESENTED
TO THE UNIVERSITY WOULD EITHER
GO THROUGH HR ARE THE STUDENT
CONDUCT OFFICE.
NOW MOST COLLEGE CAMPUSES YOU
HAVE TITLE NINE OFFICES THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED ON THE
UNIVERSITY SIEU EDUCATION
PREVENTION AS WELL AS TRAINING
FOR THE INSTITUTION. AND ANY I
AM ANYTHING ELSE THAT ARISES SO
HERE THE UNIVERSITY SAN
FRANCISCO MY ROLE IS TO DO ALL
OF THE ABOVE.
I'M SPECIFICALLY WHY TALK TO DAY
ABOUT DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
WHICH WE ENGAGE OUR STUDENTS AND
A LOT OF THAT ENCOMPASSES SOCIAL
MEDIA AND APPS IN LETTING THEM
BE AWARE. OF WHAT THOSE MAY LOOK
LIKE.
SO I'M SURE EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM KNOWS THE TITLE NINE IS UP
TO FIFTY ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS IS
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. DATING VIOLENCE
STALKING AND THE ISSUE THOSE
MACHINES DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
IS.
ALL OF THESE CAMPUSES HAVE TITLE
NINE OFFICES.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LOOKS LIKE THEY DON'T
KNOW A STOCKING LOOKS AT THE END
OF THE DEFINITIONS OF THOSE
THINGS SUFFER COLLEGE CAMPUS
REALLY IMPRINTS YES HAVE A
POLICY. THE MAKING SURE STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND AND KNOW THAT POLICY
LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT'S THE ROLE
OF THAT ON COSTS CAMPUSES SO
BEFORE OUR STUDENTS EVEN ENTER
OUR CAMPUS HERE AT THE
UNIVERSITY SAN FRANCISCO. EITHER
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR
OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL IS THEY
HAVE TO DO A COURSE OF THE CALL
TALK ABOUT IT.
IT IS AN ONLINE PLATFORM AND
GOES OVER DRUGS ALCOHOL AND
TITLE NINE BEFORE THEY EVEN COME
TO OUR CAMPUS WILL ALSO BEFORE
YOU CAN CHECK INTO YOUR
RESIDENCE HALL ON MOVING DAY.
YOU HAVE PAT HAVE COMPLETED THIS
COURSE.
THEN ONCE THEY GET ON CAMPUS
THE FIRST PERSON THAT THEY SEE
THEY GO THROUGH YOU KNOW WE IN
THEIR ROOMMATES BUT BEFORE THEY
GET A LITTLE SLEEP IN THEIR
LOVELY BEDS THEY MEET ME.
AND WE TALK ABOUT FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES BEFORE THEY ENTER THE
RESIDENCE HALLS IS WE HAVE A NEW
VIDEO INITIATIVE CALLED WE GOT
YOU. ANY GOES OVER ALL OF THE
ISSUES ARE HAPPEN BECAUSE CAMPUS
SOMETHING MAY HAPPEN THAT NIGHT
THEY MAY GET INVITED TO A PARTY
THAT NIGHT WE WANT THEM TO KNOW.
ALL OF THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
SO WE DO THAT VIDEO AND THEN
GUESS WHT ABOUT FIVE DAYS LATER
THEY HAVE FRESHMAN ORIENTATION.
AND THEY'RE GOING THROUGH A TWO
HOUR ORIENTATION ON NOT JUST
TITLE NINE. BUT DIVERSEY
MICROGRAPHS AND BISON WHAT IS
THAT LOOK LIKE ON THIS COLLEGE
CAMPUS IF I EXPERIENCE THIS HOW
DO I REPORT WHO DO I GO TO. IT'S
ALL THE THINGS ARE INITIATIVE
THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
I'M OUR POLICY AT THE UNIVERSITY
SAN FRANCISCO ENCOMPASSES ALL OF
THESE THINGS MANY TIMES WHEN YOU
HEAR IN THE MEDIA SUPERCROSS
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LOOKS LIKE NOT ABLE
TO DEFINE WHAT STOCKING LOOKS
LIKE SO WE GO OVER WHAT ALL OF
THESE ARE. HIS ALL THESE ARE
POLICY VIOLATIONS WE WANT TO
CREATE CAMPUS I'M IN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE STUDENTS FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING FORWARD AND BE ABLE TO
REPORT THESE ISSUES THAT ARE
HAPPENING.
I AM SO ONE OF THE BIG PIECE OF
THAT WE FOCUS ON AND WE KNOW A
LOT THAT'S HAPPENING IS THERE'S
ALL DIFFERENT MEDIA PLATFORMS
THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT SO YOU
CAN SEE ON GOOGLE. THEY HAVE
THIS DATABASE FOR THEIR DISABLED
A RIGHT EVERYTHING ON A GOOD A
GOOGLE DATABASE SAYING THIS IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THEY'RE ALL TYPES OF ACTS THAT
ARE GOING AROUND SO WE ENCOURAGE
OUR STUDENTS TO USE WHAT WORKS
FOR THEM THEIR CONSENT APPS.
THREE OF THE ONES THAT WE HAVE
PURSUED USER WE CONSENT IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY WANT
TO USE THERE'S ALSO LEGAL FLING
WHICH IS A NEW APP AS WELL. BUT
SOME OF THE THAT'S A VERY
PROBLEMATIC.
WHEN IT COMES TO WRITING GOING
OUT BUT I GET CONSENT FROM YOU
VIA THAT OUT BUT THEN I CAN GET
IN THAT ROOM AND I DEFTLY
CHANGED MY MIND.
I'M SO WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS SO WE KNOW THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE USING TENDER
THEY'RE USING SALSA PLEASING.
MEDIA'S UPDATING SOCIAL ONLINE
IS A DATING SO HEY'RE ALSO NINE
TIMES OUT OF TEN GOING TO USE
OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA FOR REPORTING
AS WELL.
SO THE ISSUE WE KNOW THIS
ALREADY THAT ONE IN FIVE CALLS
WOMEN ARE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ONE
IN TWELVE COLLEGE MEN. AND ONE
IN FOUR THAT IDENTIFY AS
TRANSGENDER I'M NOT FOR ME OR
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ON COLLEGE
CAN.
IN YOUR DEPARTMENTS HERE JUST
THINKING OF THAT PROBABLY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORKING YOUR
WORKPLACES HAPPENED SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED OR HAVE BEEN IN SOME
TYPE OF INCIDENTS.
AND SO KNOWING THAT IN DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS THE TRIGGERS THAT
OCCUR COMMENTS THAT ARE SAD THAT
ARE HARASSMENT TO MANY PEOPLE
ARE THAT'S NOT A BIG DEAL THE
FOR SOMEBODY WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN THEIR.
TIME PRIOR IN THEIR COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
KNOW THAT.
I WOULD SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE TRANSITION OF
OUR STUDENTS WE ALSO YOUR CHANCE
YOU WILL YOU'RE GONNA GO
SOMEPLACE ELSE.
BUT HOW DO WE HOW ARE WE HAVING
THOSE CARS USE HOW REALLY
CHANGING THE CULTURE NOT JUST ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES BUT IT WORK
PLACES AS WELL.
SO WHY DON'T PEOPLE REPORT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN HER IS IN
THE OTHER PANEL THEY DON'T THINK
IT'S SERIOUS.
THEY MAY HAVE A CRIMINAL PLOT
PASSED
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS MAYBE.
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE COMING
FROM DIFFERENT COUNTRIES. UP WE
HAVE A LOT OF INTERNATIONAL
STUDENTS HERE AT THE UNIVERSITY
SAN FRANCISCO IN THERE ISN'T
THERE SOME CONCERN ABOUT THAT IF
I REPORT THIS.
BUT IS IT GOING TO LOOK LIKE NOT
JUST FOR ME. BUT FOR THE OTHER
INDIVIDUAL.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT NINETY
PERCENT OF ASSAULTS ARE
COMMITTED BY.
PERPETRATORS ARE CONTINUOUS.
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS.
AND OVER HERE THE UNIVERSITY SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE USED CALLISTO
HOW MUCH THE NEW REPORTING OUT
I'M NOT EVEN JUST NAPA WEBSITE.
YOU CAN USE OUR PHONE AS A MAP
IS A WEBSITE. IT HAS SUPPORT
SERVICES SUITS CAN CLICK ON
THERE AND GET ALL SUPPORT
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. BUT THE
GREAT THING ABOUT.
CALLISTO AND ALL OF YOU UP
THERE TO HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
WERE PASSED OUT. IS AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN GO IN THERE AND
SEE DETAILS.
SO I TALK TO MY SINCE I'LL GIVE
EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE MY STUDENTS
MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN OUR
MAY HAVE HEARD OF THE MUSIC
ARTIST DRAKE. VERY POPULAR
DECIDED MUSIC VIDEO THAT CAME
OUT SO I WILL TELL MY STUDENTS
IF I WAS OUT AT A CLUB AND I MET
DRAKE I WOULD BE VERY EXCITED.
I WANT TO TELL EVERYBODY ABOUT
AYE MAYBE GOING TO JOURNAL ABOUT
IT.
ITS OWN CALLISTO WAS THE PRIVATE
A DATABASE MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
KEEP THEIR NOTES ON THEIR PHONES
THEY HAVE AN ONLINE DIARY TO
HAVE ETERNAL NOT THE SAFEST
THING IF YOU'RE IN A STOCKING
RELATIONSHIP PER YEAR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION.
THAT PERSON CAN EASILY GET INTO
ALL OF YOUR INFORMATION CALLISTO
LAOS WITH INDIVIDUAL GOING TO
CREATE A PRIVATE PASSWORD. AS
WELL AS A PARAPHRASE OF THE VERY
HARD TO GET INTO THAT SITUATION
BUT THEY CAN GO IN THE QUEUES
JOURNAL. I WON I DATE IT WAS
GREAT AMAZING THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT WHATEVER THEY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT.
IN OF SITUATIONS DON'T GO WELL.
SO THE STOCKING SITUATION DOES
OCCUR EVEN GOING CLOSE TO
CONTRACT THOSE BEHAVIORS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW MANY TIMES WITH
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL SOLDER
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
IS TRAUMA THERE'S MEMORY WHERE
THEY FORGET.
SO BY TRACKING WAS IN THESE
INCIDENTS GOOD BAD INDIFFERENT.
IF SOMETHING DOES HAPPEN WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK AND ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS WHAT HAPPENED.
ON YOUR FOR YOUR FRESHMAN YEAR
THEY HAVE THIS INFORMATION
THEIR.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS THERE'S A
SUSAN GONNA CAN SAVE THE DETAILS
AND IS JUST THERE FOR THEM THEY
CAN GO IN AT ANY POINT THEY CAN
GOING TO LEAVE ANY
WHAT THEY CAN DO IS I GUESS AND
YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT TO REPORT
THIS RIGHT NOW.
THEY CAN CLICK REPORT AND I GET
SINCE DIRECTLY TO MY OFFICE THE
TITLE NINE COORDINATOR I'M THE
ONLY PERSON WHO HAS ACCESS TO
THAT.
THE OTHER GREAT THING ABOUT
CALLISTO WHICH I THINK IS VERY
INTRIGUING TO MANY IS THAT THE
THAT THERE'S AN OPTION TO WAIT
FOR OTHERS.
WE KNOW MANY TIMES SURVIVORS OF
ANY TYPE OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
NEED NEVER HARASSMENT THEY DO
NOT WANT A REPORT BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THIS MAY HAVE JUST
HAPPENED TO ME.
BUT IF THIS WAS HAPPENING TO
SOMEBODY ELSE
IF THIS WAS A REPEATED PATTERN.
I WOULD WANT TO DO SOMETHING.
IT'S O. CALLISTO ALLOWS FOR
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT THE FIRST LAST
NAME IT WE USE FACEBOOK YOU ARE
OUT BUT OTHER CAMPUSES USE EMAIL
ADDRESSES AND IF IT'S A. THIRD
ALSO NOW THE TACK RELEASE EMAIL
ADDRESSES.
THAT IF SOMEBODY ELSE WAS THE
FIRST NAME THE SAME FIRST LAST
NAME IN THAT PIECE BUT YOU'RE
OUT. WHAT HAPPENS IN IT'S I
MYSELF WAS HAD IN MY CORNER I
WITH ALL OF THOSE REPORTS?
THEY ALSO GET NOTIFIED THOSE
THROUGH THAT THERE IS A MATCH.
SO IT ALLOWS FOR THERE TO BE
POWER IN NUMBERS BECAUSE WE KNOW
MANY TIMES INDIVIDUALSMAY NOT
WANNA SPEAK OUT BECAUSE THERE'S
THIS FEAR THAT THIS IS JUST
HOPPING TO ME.
I LOVE THIS IS JUST THE OUTER
FACE A CLOSE DON'T A LOOKS LIKE
IT'S YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO THE
TOP THERE YOU CAN SEE WHERE IT
SAYS REPORTING OPTIONS SO THEY
CAN CHOOSE TO REPORT HERE. THEY
CAN CHOOSE TO USE OUR ONLINE
DATABASE WERE COLLEGE CAMPUS SO
THEY CAN CHOOSE REPORT
ANONYMOUSLY THERE IF THEY WANT
TO THEY CAN COMMENT ON TO OUR
OFFICE THEY CAN CALL. TWO ONE
THING TO REMEMBER THOUGH
REPORTING IS TO HAVE ALL TYPES
OF OPTIONS.
CALLISTO FOR US IS JUST ANOTHER
TOOL IN OUR TOOLBOX.
STUDENTS CAN USE FACULTY AND
STAFF CAN USE IN MULTIPLE WAYS
OF REPORTING AND WHAT IT'S
REALLY JUST WHAT WORKS FOR THEM.
BUT HERE'S ALSO THEY CAN SEE
SUPPORT SERVICES.
ON THE INSIDE INTERNAL ROUTE
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT CALLISTO IS
OUR THE TITLE NINE COORDINATOR
WHO'S DOING ALL THE PREVENTION
EDUCATION I'M ABLE TO SEE WHEN
STUDENTS ARE USING CALLISTO.
SO FOR US I AM ABLE TO SEE
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER SPRING BREAK
EVERY YEAR I HAVE A LOT OF
REPORTS
CAN ABLE TO SEE THAT. LAST YEAR
U. S. THAT SINGLE TAMAYO. WE
DON'T KNOW WHY THAT WAS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE HAVE UPTAKE
OF REPORTS THE BEGINNING OF THE
SEMESTER IT WOULD RECALL COLLEGE
CAMPUSES CALL THE FIRST SIX
WEEKS.
THAT'S WHERE WE KNOW.
MOVE ACROSS COLLEGE CAMPUSES
THAT'S ALMOST SEXUAL ASSAULT
MOST SEXUAL MISCONDUCT DOES
OCCUR.
SO THROUGH KHALISTAN ABLE TO SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON MY CAMPUS
AND ABLE TO SEE WHAT PAGES
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO USE OUR OWN
THEY'RE GOING TO HOW TO SUPPORT
A FRIEND.
MORE MOST COMMONLY USED RAGED
PAGES BECAUSE WE WERE RETRAINING
OUR STUDENTS NOT JUST REPORT FOR
THEMSELVES WHAT HOW CAN YOU HELP
YOUR ROOMMATE HOW CAN HELP YOUR
TEAMMATE.
I'M SEVERAL MINUTES PAGE HERE IS
HOUSE YOU CAN GO IN SO THAT THE
CREEK THEIR PASSWORD ANY TO
CONFIRM IT. UP IF THEY'RE
STUDENT.
CREATING THE EMAIL ADDRESS AND
THEN THEY CAN JUST ONCE SAFE
CREATE THE DOCUMENT HERE YOU CAN
SEE WHERE IT SAYS AT IT THEY CAN
DOWNLOAD THE PDF.
AND THEY CAN DELETE IT IF THEY
DON'T WANT DON'T GO THROUGH IT
ANYMORE.
THAT YOUR PARTY NOW ARE WE FOR
OTHERS
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THIS TO
YOU IS ONCE THEY DO DECIDE TO
SUBMIT WE GET ALL THAT
INFORMATION.
AND SO WE ARE MOVING FOR TO AN
INVESTIGATION WE DON'T HOW TO
START WITH TELL ME WHAT
HAPPENED.
IRONY HAVE YOU DOCUMENT YOUR PDF
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
SO ABLE TO GAUGE IS NOT REACH
TRIGGERING OF SURVIVORS ARE
COMING FORWARD AND STARTING
OVER.
ALSO JUST A QUESTIONING WITHIN
CALLISTO IS VERY TROM INFORMED A
WE KNOW OFTEN TIMES THINGS DO
NOT HAPPEN IN CHRONOLOGICAL
ORDER SIR QUESTIONS DON'T GO IN
CHRONOLOGICAL ORDER AS WELL.
AND SO JUST ON THE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS AND PORTAL WHERE THE
CAMPUS RIGHT APPROACH.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE INVOLVED
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO TO WORK.
I'M SO FROM WHEN THEY FIRST
ENTERED THE RESIDENCE HALLS TO
WHETHER THEY'RE WORKING WITH
THEIR PREVENTION EDUCATORS TO
OUR ATHLETICS EVERYBODY ON OUR
CAMPUS. DOES GET TRAINED.
I'M FROM OUR FRESHMAN ON THE
FIRST INNER TO FACULTY AND STAFF
WERE MANDATORY REPORTERS TO OUR
STUDENT LEADERS. THEY ARE NO
THEY KNOW AND ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT OUR RESOURCES THERE KNOW
OUR POLICY.
THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND
SO THEY HAVE A LOT OF REFERENCES
AND ACROSS CAMPUS THEIR BULLETIN
BOARDS.
AND SO REALLY TRANSITION
TRANSLATING THAT INTO VERY THAT
WAS JUST A STUDENTS KNOWN ARE
AWARE OF THEIR REPORTING OPTIONS
GUNNERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW. THEY'RE NOT GONNA
REPORT.
I'M IN CHANGING THE CULTURE IS
IMPORTANT HERE AT THE UNIVERSITY
SAN FRANCISCO. ARM BEFORE IF
OFFICE LET'S DEVELOP IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE HAD ABOUT
SIXTY REPORTS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS.
WE DEFINITELY NO MORE THAN
FIFTEEN INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT WERE HAPPENING.
THE STUDENTS DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
TO GO. THERE WAS A TRUST THAT
I'M NOT GOING HR AS A STUDENT I
DON'T GHOST YOU CONDUCT Y. OUT
OF THE DISCIPLINARY OFFICE.
SO BY CREATING AN OFFICE ON
SPECIFICALLY FOR SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT REPORTING HAS DEFTLY
INCREASED ARE REPORTING TO OR
THIS PAST THIS
SO MASTER EVEN RIGHT NOW OUR RD
OVER A HUNDRED REPORTS.
SO WE'VE DEATHLY SENIOR
TRANSITION OF OFF LOT MORE TRUST
WE'RE DOING EDUCATION. ON YOU
ALL KNOW APRIL COMING UP THE
SUCH A SLOT AWARENESS MONTH
REDOING A LOT OF EDUCATION
THROUGH OUT THE YEAR.
ON THAT AND INFORM STUDENTS OF
WHAT OTHER OPTIONS FOR
REPORTING.
KNOWING THE POLICY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT POLICY
LOOKS LIKE IN A LOT OF THAT DOES
INVOLVE TACK.
BY PROVIDING MULTIPLE WASTE GAS
SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO DO THINGS A
PERSIBA MONEY OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE ON THEIR PHONE ALL DAY
EVERYDAY.
IT EVEN SERVER EDUCATION
PREVENTION WERE DOING SNAPCHAT
FILTERS WERE SAYING MESSAGES HEY
WE HEARD WAS HAPPENING OVER HERE
AND HE IS.
WE CAN SEE THAT.
WE CAN SEE THAT APPROPRIATE
RIDING ON THE DASHBOARD SO LET'S
WE START HAVING CONVERSATIONS IN
USING SOCIALLY TO REALLY REACH
PEOPLE WHERE THEY'RE AT.
THIS JUST ACROSS
BUT THAT'S JUST OUR INFORMATION
HERE SPECIFIC ROUTE CALLISTO BUT
PICKING A COLLEGE CAMPUS
APPROACH ARMS ALL THAT WE DO SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT HERE ANY QUESTIONS
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER.
REALLY REALLY INTERESTING.
LET ME JUST ASK SO I UNDERSTAND
FROM EACH OF YOU.
.
YOU ALL ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
HOW APPS HAVE SOME SORT OF NOTES
COMPONENTS
PEOPLE CAN TYPE THINGS AND.
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THEY IF THEY TYPE
IN THE NAMES OF?
OF PERPETRATORS BEACH APPEARS.
SO IN ARE SYSTEMS THERE CLOSE
SYSTEM SO IT'S AN OPT OUT
SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT OPTING IN
IS REALLY HARD TO DO RIGHT NO I
MEAN THEIR NAMES THE NAMES OF OF
THE PERPETRATORS. IF THE
PERPETRATORS NAME IS LISTED IN
THERE THEN IT HAS TO BE FOLLOWED
UP WITH AN A PROCESS THAT HAD
HAS TO GO ON THAT GOES ON WITHIN
WITHIN THE IN THE COMPANY.
WITHIN THE COMPANY OR WITHIN THE
SCHOOL AND IS ANY OF THAT MADE.
COULD NOT BE PUBLICLY SEEN MANY
OF THESE APPLICATION.
AND NOW IT'S ALL CLOSED ALL THE
MODERATORS WHO RECEIVE THE
REPORTS ARE TRAINED AND WHAT THE
LAW IS FEDERALLY ON A STATE
LEVEL TITLE NINE TOTAL SEVEN.
AND WHAT THE WHISTLEBLOWER LAWS
ARE IN EVERY STATE BECAUSE
IDENTITY THREAT IS THE BIGGEST
THREAT THAT WE ALL FACE TODAY.
SO UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU HAVE
TO DO.
AND INVESTIGATION THAT IT'S
SAFE AND NON THREATENING.
TO BOTH THE VICTIM AND TO THE
AGGRESSORS OR OR PERPETRATORS.
SO AS WE IN OUR SYSTEMS NOT ONLY
DO YOU GET REPORTED WHAT WENT ON
AND HE WAS INVOLVED YOU THEN DO
YOU REAP USE AND. DO YOUR ACTUAL
INVESTIGATION EVERYTHING'S
TRACKED IN THE TIMELINE
EVERYTHING YOU DID AND THEN THE
SYSTEM AUTOMATICALLY SUGGEST
STORED UP PROCESS HE'S NEXT
STOPS MAKING THE RIGHT CHOICES.
AND SO THOSE WERE BROUGH UP
INVOLVE EVERYTHING FROM HELP
LINES TO CONVERSATIONS
THE LESSONS BOTH FOR THE VICTIMS
AND FOR THE AGGRESSORS BECAUSE.
THE VICTIMS OBVIOUSLY NEED
SUPPORT SERVICES AND THERE'S
FOLLOW UP UNDER TITLE NINE THAT
YOU HAVE TO DO. AN ON THE
AGGRESSOR SIDE WE BELIEVE
RESTORED DISCIPLINE FOR THE MORE
LAST FOR THE LESSER INFRACTIONS
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN.
AND UNDERSTAND SO. OUR THAT'S
OUR PROCESS WORKS.
NO IT'S IN BOTH.
SO WHEN THE SYSTEM WE BUILT IN
AUTOMATIC EVERYTHING'S MEDITECH
IN TERMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
RESOURCES SUPPORT RESOURCES
STATE AND LOCAL THE COMMUNITIES
CAN UPLOAD A META TAG ALL THEIR
OWN INFORMATION IN REAL TIME.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES CAN ALL
BE UPLOADED MEDITECH AND PUSHED
BECAUSE PUSH TECHNOLOGY IS THE
KEY. NO ONE WANTS TO FIND
ANYTHING ANYMORE ANY TYPE OF
STATIC WEBSITE OR OPT IN
APPROACH WHICH IS WHAT I CALL.
STATIC.
DOESN'T GET MAXIMUM ENGAGEMENT
IN ORDER TO CHANGE COMMUNITY
CULTURAL BEHAVIOR YOU WANT TO
START WITH EVERYONE. BEING IN
THE SYSTEM OF SOMEONE STOPPED
OUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T IN A DROP
DOWN OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT'S FINE BUT IF YOU START
FROM A HUNDRED PERCENT AND YOU
END UP AT NINETY PERCENT VERSUS
STARTING AT FIVE PERCENT TRYING
TO GET TEN PERCENT.
THE DESIRED IMPACT ON CULTURE
DIGITAL PEER PRESSURE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU
GOT YOUR LICENSE YOU CAN OPT IN
TO GIVING YOUR EYES AND GIVING
YOUR ORGANS IN THE U. S. SO WE
HAVE FIVE PERCENT PARTICIPATION.
OVERSEAS IN SCANDINAVIA YOU OPT
OUT AND THEY GET NINETY FIVE
PERCENT SO IT'S ALL ABOUT MAKING
IT EASY RIGHT MAKING THE CHOICES
EASING. SAMPLES PATH IS ALWAYS A
PATH WE WANT SO AS WE BUILT THIS
WE BUILD IT IS CHOICE
ARCHITECTS.
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT EASIEST
FOR. THE VECTOR THE AGGRESSOR
THE BYSTANDER THE PERSON ON THE
TIMELINE CORD INFESTED DRESS
THAT THE POLICE TO HAVE TO GET
INVOLVED OR DON'T HAVE TO GET
INVOLVED THE PARENTS WHO HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP. AND SO ON SO YOU HAVE
TO GRAEME THEORY EVERY SCENARIO
THAT'S OUT THERE. AND FIGURE OUT
OKAY WHERE WE GONNA END UP HERE
AND YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT THE RISK REWARD OF
STARTING THAT PROCESS AT THE
BEGINNING.
SO IN FORMING YOUR STUDENTS YOUR
EMPLOYEES YOUR LOBBYIST.
HEY HERE'S THE RISK OF HE SAID
SHE SAID RIGHT.
WITHOUT WITNESSES WITH WITNESSES
AND HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THIS PARTICULAR EVENT TAKES
PLACE AND SO HERE ARE THE THREE
THINGS YOU OF THIS CHOICE. AND
TITLE NINE.
YOU KNOW IF IF YOU ALLEGE BEING
SEXUALLY HARASSED OR RAPED OR
DATE RAPED RIGHT YOU HAVE THREE
CHOICES NO TIMELINE COORDINATOR
YOU CAN HANDLE IT INTERNALLY.
SECURITY CAN HANDLE IT ON CAMPUS
OR YOU GO TO THE POLICE. ALL OF
THESE HAVE TO BE GIVEN TO THE
ALLEGED VICTIM AT THE TIME
AND THEY THEN HAVE TO AGREE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO ONE OR
THREE.
OR NONE AND COMMUNICATE THAT
BACK TO THE UNIVERSITY SO WE
BUILD ALL THESE CHECK LOOPS INTO
OUR PUSH TECHNOLOGY AGAIN WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE THE RISK. OFF THE
INSTITUTIONS BACK TO THE
INDIVIDUALS IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS THE BOARD
WHETHER IT'S SCHOOLS WHETHER
IT'S CAMPUSES WHETHER IT'S
CORPORATION.
IT IT WITH OUR ATHLETES
THE COMMUNICATIONS SOLELY
BETWEEN THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
EMPLOYER.
SO IT'S ALWAYS CONFIDENTIAL
EVERYTHING'S ENCRYPTED WE HAVE
ALL THE.
DAD COMPLETELY SECURE SO IT'S A
COMPLETE DIRECT LINE SO. ANY
NAMES ANY PHOTOS ANYTHING THAT'S
THAT'S TRANSMITTED IS COMPLETELY
SECURE SO IT WOULD BE JUST ONE
WAY COMMUNICATION SO THERE'S NO
ISSUE ABOUT ABOUT DUMB.
YEAH ANYTHING BEING PREACHED.
AND THE SAME ARE FOR CALLISTO IF
STUDENTS CHOOSES TO BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO REPORT THE CAN
USE.
WHEN WRITING YOU CAN CHOOSE THAT
THE WAY TO RAISE YOUR VOICE YOUR
HEALING WITHOUT REPORTING ABOUT
ONCE YOU DOES SHE IS TO REPORT
THAT INFORMATION TO OUR OFFICER
WAIT FOR OTHERS ONLY RECEIVE
THAT REPORT. WE DO HAVE THE
PERPETRATORS NAMES WHAT HAPPENS
THEN IS AYE CONTACT.
I.
THE SURVIVOR FIRST LET THEM KNOW
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED REPORT TO
COME OVER TO OUR OFFICE HE OVER
SUPPORT OPTIONS RESOURCES
WHATEVER THEY MAY NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE PROCESS AND START
THEIR HEALING. AND THEN WE GO
OVER OPTIONS FOR THEM AS FAR AS
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO NEXT.
SO DID THEY JUST WANT US TO HAVE
THIS REPORT TO THE US WENT
SUPPORT ONLY AND RESOURCES WITH
ELECTION FOR WITH A FORMAL
INVESTIGATION ARE LIKE HIM FOR
THE CONFLICT RESOLUTION TO THE
LOWER LEVEL. SITUATION.
BUT IF THE BOOK FOR OUR
ESPECIALLY IN THIS TITLE NINE IF
WE HAVE MULTIPLE REPORTS WITH
THE SAME INDIVIDUAL. WE MAY MOVE
FORWARD REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
SURVIVE MAY WANT BECAUSE WE ALSO
HAVE AN OBLIGATION PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF OTHER
STUDENTS.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
.
FIRST OF ALL MISTER URBAN. BOB I
THOUGHT PRESENTATION ON THE
SYSTEM YOU ARE BUILDING IN
COLLABORATION WITH WE SAID
ENOUGH.
THIS WEEK IN SAN DIEGO ONE AS
IT WAS PRESENTED.
ARM AND AS I UNDERSTOOD IT.
IT WOULD BE A DATA COLLECTION
TOOL BECAUSE THE ARGUMENT MADE
WAS THAT WE DON'T HAVE DATA
COLLECTION WE DON'T HAVE A SET.
UNIVERSALLY OF THE NUMBER OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT VICTIMS ACROSS
THE BOARD.
AND SO.
THE TOOL BEING BUILT.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT IT
WOULD BE A TOOL THAT COULD
ACTUALLY LAUNCH INVESTIGATION.
CASE MANAGEMENT TOOL USED BY
EMPLOYERS SO TO GET BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMPS IS.
.
QUESTION ABOUT THAT WHO OWNS THE
DATA SO SO HELP CLARIFY FOR ME
WHAT THE TO YOU TOOL YOUR BILL
BECAUSE OUR BACKGROUND.
INFORMATION IS ON BRIDGET.
SO ON.
TOOL YOU ARE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY SAID ENOUGH
WILL BE TO DO WHAT OKAY.
THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS THERE TO
THE FIRST ONE IS WE BUILD A
PLATFORM TECHNOLOGY PRIDE. AND
ON THAT PLATFORM TECHNOLOGY IT
CAN EXTEND ANY COMMUNITY. I CAN
CREATE A NATIVE OUT FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURE IN SIX WEEKS TIME.
BOTH ANDROID AND YOU CAN UPLOAD
WHATEVER YOUR MATERIALS ARE AND
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO CAPTURE.
WE SELL ENOUGH CAME TO US
SPECIFICALLY AND ASKED US.
A WHAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT BUILDING
A MAP WHERE YOU WOULD NAME
PEOPLE AND ALL THAT AND WE WERE
LIKE. YOU WANT TO GATHER THE
DATA SO THE WHOLE IDEA BEHIND
THE WE SAID ENOUGH. WHICH IS A
SEPARATE APPLICATION IS TO DO
JUST THAT.
ANY USER. ANY FEMALE MEL
TRANSGENDER WHATEVER AFFILIATION
FATHER MOTHER CAN INPUT ANY
BOUNDARY CROSSING OUR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT THAT'D BE EITHER
EXPERIENCED OR THEY SEEM. LIKE
MY DAUGHTER HAS BEEN SEXUALLY
HARASSING POLYTECHNIC ROUTE
TIMES I COULD PUT THOSE AND.
AND WE GATHER NOT WE GATHER WITH
GREAT GRANULARITY THE TYPE OF
SEXUAL BOUNDARY CROSSING OR
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT THAT WENT ON
WE ALSO GATHER THE PERIODICITY.
SO WE GATHER WHAT TO DO STARRING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO BECOME
MIDDLE SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE GRADUATE SCHOOL THE
WORKPLACE BECAUSE THERE IS NO
GOOD DATA OUT THERE. ON THESE
THINGS AND SO THE IDEA WITH WE
SAID ENOUGH WAS TO LAUNCH THE
SAP TO THE WORLD FOR FREE.
STARTING PROBABLY PRODUCT IS
APRIL FIRST BECAUSE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WHERE THIS MONTH.
ALTHOUGH WE COULD DO IT THIS
WEEK IF WE WANTED TO. AND THE
WHOLE IDEAS TO HAVE EVERYONE OUT
THERE.
POPULATE THEIR EXPERIENCES THAT
THEY'VE EVER HAPPENED THAT
THY'VE EVER HAD AS LONG AS IT'S
ON TRIGGERING THAT THEY WANT TO
SHARE BOTH NOW AND IN THE PAST
OR FRIEND OR SOMEONE ELSE. TO
REALLY MAP A LANDSCAPE OF PAIN
HARM SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
BREADTH OF THIS ISSUE AND THE
DATA. ON IT WHEN I SAY PEOPLE
MEN WOMEN EVERYONE BECAUSE IT'S
UP TO ALL OF US TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS.
AND SO NOW I'M CLEAR BETWEEN WE
FIT ENOUGH APT THAT'S
FORTHCOMING AND.
BRIDGET AT THAT EXIST
SO SO YOU BUILD IT.
I POPULATE I GUESS I CAN'T NAME
NAMES BECAUSE THIS DATA
COLLECTION YOU CAN NAY NIGHTS IN
THIS ONE YOU CAN TIME
PERPETRATORS.
RIGHT AND AND.
AT IT IS THAT DATA GOAL YOU SET
YOUR INTRO POLICYMAKERS
THE PRESIDENT GOES INTO A LOT
ACCESS.
DO YOU ROLL IT OUT KIND OF TELL
THE WORLD IN THIRTY THEY ROLLED
OUT ON IT THE WE ROLLED OUT ON
THE DE IDENTIFIED EVASIVE SO
IT'S ALWAYS PROTECTED WE'RE NOT
SELLING THE DATA WERE NOT RE
DISTRIBUTING THE DATA. FOR ANY
OTHER REASON WE HAVE RESEARCHERS
WHO MAY WANT TO MIND THE DATA ON
A DE IDENTIFIED BASIS
BECAUSE WE FEEL AS THOUGH
THAT'LL BE BENEFICIAL TO
SOCIETY SIMILAR ACTUALLY WANT TO
DO THAT. WILL PUBLISH THE DATA
IN REAL TIME ON OUR MAPS. SO
THAT THERE'S A CONSTANT
AWARENESS OF THE PROBLEM GOT.
AS AS WE TALK ABOUT OUR OUR NEED
TO.
AFFECT CULTURE CHANGE AND
IMPLICIT BIAS KIND OF FOCUSED
THIS WOULD BE A DATA POINT THAT
WE COULD HAVE A.
BROADER UNDERSTANDING ABOUT UC I
THINK EVERYONE SHOULD TAKE THE
I. T. ON THE HARVARD WEBSITE
I'VE TAKEN FIFTY THIRTY. TWO
MANY TIMES WE'VE WRITTEN ABOUT
IT AND BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
THEIR IMPLICIT BIASES AND YOU
ALWAYS HAVE THEM IT'S LEARNING
HOW TO MANAGE YOUR EXPLOSIVE
BIAS. AND HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND BY THE WAY.
ORIENTATION AT EVERY LEVEL IS
THE ONE OF THE KEY FACTORS
DECIDING CLIMATE WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING INTO SIX GREAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME. WHETHER YOU'RE
JOINING THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WHETHER YOU'RE IN NEW LOBBYIST
WHEN YOU GOT UP STARTING OFF AS
A FRESHMAN AT SCHOOL THAT
ORIENTATION PERIOD IS SUCH A
CRITICAL POINT AT WHICH TO
ADDRESS THIS.
AND I WOULD CHALLENGE FOLKS.
TO AT.
THERE HAD BEEN A NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WERE INTRODUCED IN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT ANTI
BELIEVED I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN MANY THOSE BILLS
WERE DEBATED AND HEARD CITY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE. TALK
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE SHOULD JUST MAN
UP IN BUILDING WASN'T THAT BIG A
DEAL AND SO THE REASON I TALK
ABOUT IMPLICIT BIASES BECAUSE
THAT LIVED HERE AND EXPERIENCED
AND HEARD IT FIRST HAND. AND SO
NOW WE ALL SEEM TO BE SINGING
THE SAME THOUGHT ABOUT YOU KNOW
IN A SHAME BUT FOLKS NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE ABOUT. WHAT
THEY THOUGHT AND WHAT THEY
VIEWED A GREAT READ IS WHISTLING
VIVALDI FOR THOSE OF YOU HAVE
READ IT IT'S A GREAT READ? LET
ME MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ROBERT.
ARE IN TERMS OF.
HOW MANY COMPANIES HAVE ARE
ACTUALLY USING CANDOR AND WHAT'S
THE FEEDBACK YOU GET? WE ONLY
HAVE A COUPLE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE JUST LAUNCHED.
INTERESTINGLY MOST OF THAT.
YOU KNOW EMPLOYEE CLAIMS OF
COMING SO FAR ARE NOT ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AT ALL
PROBABLY NOT SURPRISING.
A LOT OF THEM ARE SHIITES.
MANAGEMENT ISSUES DATED DAYS.
THIS PERSON'S LOOKING AT ME OR
TREATING ME OR I WOULD EVEN CALL
THEM PULLING ISSUE JUST CONFLICT
IN THE WORKPLACE ISSUES WHICH.
BUT HONESTLY.
I THINK.
THIS PRESENTS.
GREAT PRESSURE VALVE.
.
THE FIRST CLIENT WE LAUNCHED
THAT IS IT.
CLIENT THAT I'VE HAD FOR YEARS
AND THEY HAVE A TRADITIONAL
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER HOTLINES.
AND THEY TOLD US THAT THEY
NORMALLY GET A COUPLE OF PHONE
CALLS A MONTH OUT OF THE EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER. AND THE AMOUNT
OF OF.
HICKS THEY GOT ON CANDOR WAS
QUITE A BIT MORE EVEN IN THE
FIRST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
SO THE ENGAGEMENT LEVEL WE THINK
IS GOING TO BE A LOT HIGHER. BUT
HONESTLY JUST
SORT OF.
DISGRUNTLED EMPLOYEES.
SORT OF THE GRUMBLING LEVEL THAT
I'M FEELING AMONGST MY CLIENT
EMPLOYEE BASE HAS BEEN GROWING
OF THE LAST FEW.
MONTHS MAYBE EIGHTEEN MONTHS SO
I THINK THIS COULD BE A REALLY
INTERESTING PRESSURE VALVE.
YOU KNOW STEAM HEALTH YOU KNOW
KIND OF THING THAT I THINK WILL
HELP. EVEN IF IT'S NOT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT JUST TO SORT OF LET
EMPLOYEES VENT. AND WHEN I'M
HEARING FROM PEOPLE USING IT.
THE THE HR PEOPLE LIKE IT
BECAUSE THEY'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO READ THINGS AND HAVE TIME TO
GET BACK TO PEOPLE IS WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING ME. SO THEY'RE
FINDING IT REALLY INTERESTING
LIKE I SAID WE'VE ONLY BEEN OUT
FOR A FEW WEEKS BUT STILL VERY
NEW. BUT SO FAR.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY ENJOYING
WORKING WITH IT BECAUSE IT'S
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO VENT ALLOWING
THE THE EMPLOYER TO GET BACK TO
PEOPLE.
YOU NO WILL HAVE TO SEE WHEN WE
GET IN SOME OF THE HEAVY LIFTING
AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S SO NEW. BUT.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S BEEN AND
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF REALLY
INTERESTING INTEREST FROM THE
EMPLOYER BASED NATIONWIDE YOU
KNOW I WAS SORT OF FASCINATED
BY.
THE THOU RETRIEVING THAT
GETTING.
BUT OBVIOUSLY LIKE I SAID THE
NEW APP BECAUSE IT'S NEW
TECHNOLOGY. BUT.
SO FAR VERY INTRIGUED WITH THE
RESPONSE AND AND. YOU KNOW WELL
WILL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT GOES BUT
VERY ENCOURAGING THANK YOU HOW
TO SAY MISS FLEMING YOU KNOW
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY WHEN I
THINK ABOUT MY FIRST DAY AS A
FRESHMAN NO ONE SAID. ANYTHING
ABOUT ANYTHING YEAH.
I REMEMBER WE HAD A RAPE CRISIS
CENTER ON CAMPUS AND I WE DID
KNOW ABOUT IT OR KNOW WHERE THEY
KNOW OR EVEN KNOW WHERE IT WAS
UNTIL SOME WITH RATE ON CAPITAL
ME TO FIGURE OUT SO IT'S
WONDERFUL TO HEAR. WHAT THE
EXPERIENCE IS NOW AND HOW PRO
PRO ACTIVE WE ARE BEING IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE STUDENTS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES THAT'S WONDERFUL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR?
WE HAVE A NURSE'S OFFICE.
MY COLLEGE CAMPUS CHECK WELL
YEAH YEAH CAPITAL THOSE ROOM ON
THE FIFTH FLOOR BY THE MEMBERS
ELEVATOR
I'LL TAKE IT SHOWS THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU. SOME STATISTICS WERE
SHARED AND.
CLEAR TO ME ANYWAY THAT THERE
ISN'T ENOUGH DATA TO BE ABLE TO
TELL WITH STIFF
START HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
BUT YOU TALKED ABOUT ONE IN FIVE
WOMEN RAPED ON KELCH COLLEGE
CAMPUS WHEN TWELVE MAN ONE FOR
TRANS.
THOSE DON'T NECESSARILY REFLECT.
OUR AND HERE IN THE CAPITAL
RIGHT THIS IS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES CORRECT SHE'D ALREADY
BEEN ABLE TO GATHER DATA TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT NINETY PERCENT
OF SEXUAL OFFENDERS ARE REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
AGAIN THAT'S DATA THAT HAS BEEN
COLLECTED YES THE STATE HAS BEEN
COLLECTED AND THAT'S NATIONAL
DATA THAT'S BEEN DONE AND SO
LIKE ORGANIZATIONS TO TIGHTEN I
LIKE A TEXT THAT. I'M VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE COLLECTED THE
STATE AND IT'S KNOWN I'M IT'S
NOT BUT IT'S NOT VISIT FOR THE
CAPITAL BUT AROUND COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
IN COLLEGE CAMPUS SPECIFICALLY
AT U. S. ATHLETE CLIMATE SURVEYS
THEY GO OUT TO OUR TO OUR CAMPUS
TO.
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
OUR CAMPUS TO GATHER THIS
INFORMATION BUT INFORMATION THAT
WAS SHARED TO YOU ON THIS
NATIONAL DATA.
DO THE TEXT ORGANIZATION TO BEG
THE QUESTION.
IF NINETY PERCENT ARE REPEAT
OFFENDERS WHAT IS HAPPENING THE
FIRST TIME THEIR FANDOM THE
SECOND TIME THEY HAVE FOUND.
YEAH AND MANY FROM COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WE KNOW STUDENTS ARE
REPORTING.
STUDENTS FEEL LIKE IT IS AN
ISOLATED EVENT AND SO THEY ARE
NOT REPORTING THAT INFORMATION
BUT THEN ONCE ONE PERSON THAT'S.
SUCH IN A COLLEGE CAMPUS SO WE
HAVE BEEN CALLED THE RUMOR MILL.
WHERE WE HAVE ONCE USES LIKE
I'VE EXPERIENCED THIS IN SOMEONE
ELSE'S I'VE EXPERIENCED THAT TOO
WE REALIZE IT'S THE SAME PERSON
SAME INDIVIDUAL? IS A THAT'S WHY
THE COSTUMES LOOK WE'RE LOOKING
AT CLIMATE. IS A CALLISTO ALLOWS
FOR US AND WE HAVE OTHER FORMS
OF REPORTING AS WELL SO WE HAVE
MAXI IT WAS A DATABASE FOR
STUDENTS CAN GO ON A REPORT
STAFF AND FACULTY CAN GO
UNREPORTED INCIDENTS. AND WE
TRACK BEHAVIORS SO I GET TO
INCIDENTS OF THE THING STUDENT
WERE OUT REACHING TO THE
INDIVIDUAL WERE SAYING. HEY
REGARDLESS OF IF THAT SURVIVOR
VICTOR WANTS TO COME FORWARD
SAYING WE'VE BEEN MADE AWARE OF
THESE BEHAVIORS.
WE NEED YOU TO COME INTO OUR
OFFICE WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WE MAY BE GOING TO
A FORMAL INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
WE WANT TO DO IF YOU WANT TO
STOP THAT BEHAVIOR. AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT IT DOESN'T
CONTINUE.
ONE COMMENT TENS OF THAT
QUESTION. PEOPLE SELECT VICTIMS
THAT ARE LESS LIKELY TO REPORT.
PEOPLE HAVE LOW SELF ESTEEM THE
GROOM THEM THEY MAKE THEM FEEL
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT WENT ON
YOU'RE THE ONE WHO GAVE ME THE
MESSAGES.
AND SO PART OF WHAT GOES ON WITH
PREDATION IS HOW YOU SELECT
SOMEONE AND YOU TO SOMEONE WHO.
IS LESS LIKELY TO COME FORWARD
THAT'S WHY WE SAID ENOUGH IN
SOME OF THESE THINGS EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO COME
FORWARD. THAT'S PART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
WONDERFUL.
IN THE BROCHURE.
TITLE TITLE MY FOR UNIVERSITY
SAN FRANCISCO.
IN THE MIDDLE SECTION OF SAYS
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT INCLUDES A
BROAD RANGE OF MOUNTAINS SOCIAL
BEHAVIORS FOCUSED ON SEX.
EIGHT ONE OF THINGS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM OTHER SPEAKERS OF THE
PRESENTERS. IS THAT IT'S NOT
ABOUT SEX IT'S ABOUT POWER NAY
GOES BACK TO BASICALLY GROOMING
THIS PERSON TO MAKE THEM FEEL
POWERLESS.
NEXT TO YOU.
TO THEM.
TO THAT TO THEM
SHIRLEY HARASS THEM.
GREAT OVER OUR BROCHURE HERE'S
FOCUS ON FACTS INTERGENDERTHAT
HAVE LIKE INEFFECTIVE STARTING
SO WE BREAK IT DOWN FOR EACH
POLICY SO SEXUAL RASCO IT
AWFULLY NO THAT'S MORE SO IT CAN
BE BASED ON HER POWER DYNAMICS.
SO MY FACULTY MEMBER ARE
PROFESSOR SAYS. HEY YOU NEED TO
COME OFFICE HOURS IF YOU DON'T
COME TO OFFICE HOURS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO PASS THIS COURSE WE
KNOW THOSE POWER DIFFERENTIALS
THERE BEFORE BASED ON WHO ARE
FEDERAL LIKE THE FEDERAL
GUIDELINES BASED OFF OF ITS ARE
DISCRIMINATION BASED OFF OF SEX
OR GENDER. IS ABOUT WITH THIS
LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY I'M
MISTAKEN FROM BOZEMAN OF SORRY.
I THINK SO.
IF YOU IS IT DIFFERENT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A FACULTY
MEMBER WHO IS SEXUALLY HARASSING
OR HAS RAPED A STUDENT.
VERSUS STUDENT ON STUDENT.
REGARDLESS THERE ARE PROCESS.
.
ALL PARTIES LIKE WE HAVE.
THE PROCESS STARTS WITH THAT THE
REPORT.
I'M IF THERE IS A FACULTY MEMBER
INVOLVED WITH A STUDENT. THAT
WAS GONNA GO THROUGH TITLE NINE
BUT ALSO EACH ARE.
I'M IF IT'S STUDENTS IF IT'S
ONLY STUDENTS OF ALL THE PROCESS
SINCE GONNA GO THROUGH TITLE
NINE AND THEN STUDENT CON.
BUT THE PROCESS AS FAR AS AND
SUPPORT SERVICES IN THE
RESOURCES. IS ALL GOING TO BE
THE SAME IT'S JUST OPINION WHICH
OFFICE IS GOING TO TAKE THE
LEAD.
I DIDN'T COVERAGE OF JAPAN
BECAUSE OF I THINK USED TO
REALLY IMPORTANT FACTORS HERE.
I'M ONE IS WE KNOW IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS NINETY PERCENT OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES ARE
SOMETIMES ABUSE BECAUSE THEY
MAKE SUCH BAD REPORTERS.
UP PART OF WHAT HAPPENED WITH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN COLLEGES
WHICH IS DRIVEN ALL THIS WAS THE
PROFESSOR WOULD SAY THE PERSON'S
EIGHTEEN THERE ARE COLLEGE.
AND SO THERE IS A SENSE OF ARE
YOU ABLE TO SAY YES WHEN THERE'S
THAT MUCH OF A POWER
DIFFERENTIAL THAT'S WHY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS FREQUENTLY DEFINED
IN FRONT. IN TERMS OF QUID PRO
QUO.
IS THIS CAN AFFECT YOUR GRADE
WOULD YOU GET IN RETURN. AND THE
SAME THING HAPPENS IN IN TERMS
OF THE ASSEMBLY WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN TO YOUR CAREER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN
POLITICS.
UNLESS IF YOU SAY NO IF YOU PUSH
SOMEONE AWAY WITH THE BE
OFFENDED. AND SO THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES THAT BRING IT IN TERMS OF
POWER. BUT THERE'S GRATIFICATION
BEING SADDAM MANY DIFFERENT LATE
LEVELS THAT ARE INTERSECTING.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS SO
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE FOCUSING
ON.
I'M ONE OF THE GROUPS THAT WORK
WITH HIS COMMUNITY MATTERS THE
DEALS WITH BOWLING.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE
MAKE REAL GENUINE CONNECTIONS
BECAUSE IF YOU MAKE A CONNECTION
WITH SOME OF THE HEART YOU'RE
LESS LIKELY TO HARM SOMEONE.
THE SHOOTINGS WE JUST SAW ON
PARK LAND INVOLVED A YOUNG MAN
WHO DID HAVE VERY GOOD
CONNECTIONS
YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE SOMEONE TO
AN OBJECT. IF YOU'RE NOT CAPABLE
OF EMPATHY WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER AND CREATING
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S APATHY
THAT HOUSE BE PART OF.
PART OF THIS DIALOGUE.
THE REASON FOR MY QUESTIONS IS
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFERENT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
CO EMPLOYEES SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BETWEEN EMPLOYEES HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
FROM LEGISLATOR SUPERVISOR
TOWARDS AN EMPLOYEE. BECAUSE OF
THE POWER DYNAMICS
AND I THINK THAT I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THOSE ARE DEALT WITH
DIFFERENTLY.
YEAH YEAH BUT WHEN YOU SEE
SOMETHING LIKE SURVIVOR YOU KNOW
THEIR CLIQUES THEIR FORMED
PEOPLE WANNA GET ACCEPTED. THAT
THERE A LOT OF RELATIONSHIP
DYNAMICS THAT GO ON EVEN WHEN
THEIR PEERS.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE REALLY FORTUNE
IN THE STATE THAT WE HAVE
AFFIRMATIVE CAN.
WHAT I YOU KNOW WHAT POSITION
ARE YOU AND HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT AT ARE YOU ABLE TO SAY NO?
I'M ALL THOSE THINGS BECOME
IMPORTANT THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE
TRY TO BUILD INTO BRIDGET WHERE
THEIR SUPPORT IF SOMEONE FEELS
THEMSELVES STUCK IN THAT
SITUATION.
WHERE PEOPLE COULD TALK ABOUT
WHAT HOW DO YOU HANDLE THIS WHEN
YOU'RE IN THAT TYPE OF
SITUATION?
AND AND IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE A
LOT OF THESE MEN WERE VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
THE REALLY HAVE NOT LEARNED
INTERPERSONAL SKILLS THEY KNOW
HOW TO SPEAK IN ME IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE BUT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO ASK SOMEONE WHETHER THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN THEM AND THEY
HAVE.
OF BOTH.
HIGH.
SILVA VALUE BUT LOW SELF ESTEEM
UNDERNEATH THE SURFACE AND AND
THEY DO THINGS LIKE EXPOSE
THEMSELVES AND DO THINGS YOU SAY
THEY'RE AFRAID THEY'RE GONNA GET
REJECTED.
THEY HAVE EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS SO
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE
THE PATHWAYS WERE THE SIGNS OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS HOW HOW CAN WE
HELP THEM CONNECTED A LEVEL
WHERE THEY DON'T LOSE THE SENSE
OF THE PERSON. THAT THEY ARE
HARMING.
BY THEIR CONDUCT AND DON'T
FORGET DON'T FORGET TO THAT THAT
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT CO
WORKERS THAT.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE A QUID
PRO QUO SITUATION YOU HAD A
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT SITUATION
BECAUSE IT TOO DIFFICULT IN THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT SCHOOLS I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE WORKPLACE
WHICH IS MORE RELEVANT. WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE HERE.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE A A HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT SITUATION YOU MAY
ALSO HAVE A PRESSURE NOT TO
COMPLAIN BECAUSE LET'S SAY WE'RE
TALKING NONTRADITIONAL MORE YOUR
FEMALES NOT COMPLAINING ABOUT A
MALE. BUT LET'S SAY YOU HAVE A
LOT OF MALE COWORKERS WHO ARE
MAKING COMMENTS ABOUT YOU KNOW
BEING IN VERY BROAD OUT THERE
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES. AND AND
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW SEXUAL
EXPERIENCES MAKING SEXUAL
LANGUAGE AND YOU HAVE A WOMAN
WHO WANTS TO FIT IN. AND IS A
LOT OF PRESSURE IN MANY CASES I
MEAN AND LAW FIRMS OFTEN LIKE
JUST LIKE HERE. SOMETIMES YOU
MAY BE NOT AS YOU MAY NOT BE AS
MANY WOMEN SO YOU DON'T WANNA
SAY SOMETHING BECAUSE YOU WANNA
ROCK THE BOAT AND YOU WANT TO
GET FORWARD. AND THEM MORE MEN
INVOLVED SO YOU MAY JUST DO YOU
KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'LL COMMON SITUATION.
YOU KNOW I SEE IT IN ALMOST
EVERY EVERY INDUSTRY WE DEAL
WITH. AND THAT'S THAT'S VERY
COMMON AND HE THAT'S MORE COMMON
THAN THAN ANY BY THE WAY WE
STONE TO SEE MORE WOMEN SPEAK
UP.
WITH THIS HOMIE TO MOVEMENT AND
TURN TO SEE MANY MANY MORE WOMEN
MAKE COMPLAINTS BUT IT'S STILL
THERE STILL PRESSURE DIGITAL
FEAR AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
IF I MAY UM MADAM CHAIR.
GOING BACK TO THE COMMENT.
YOU ALSO TALKED THERE WAS TALK
ABOUT RESTORATIVE DISCIPLINE.
BUT THAT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME AND
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RESTORED OF
DISCIPLINE. OR TALK ABOUT
STUDENT ON STUDENT BUT IF IT'S
FACULTY MEMBER ON STUDENT
WOULDN'T THAT BE DIFFERENT.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ASK
INSERTED ABOUT THAT FACULTY
MEMBER WHO'S USING HIS POWER OR
HER POWER OVER THAT STUDENT THE
STUDENTS GRADING THE STUDENTS
FUTURE. AS YOU WOULD HEAR ON
PETER I WOULD ASSUME.
OKAY SO WHAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMETIMES A SLIPPY SLOPE
OF RELATIONSHIPS PEOPLE FEEL
THEY. HAVE FALLEN IN LOVE WITH
SOMEONE AND SO.
IT DEPENDS WHAT THE BEHAVIOR IS
AND WHAT THE ACTION AS IF WE
COULD STOP SOMETHING EARLIER.
THEN THERE ISN'T SOMETHING LEGAL
AND SOMEONE HAS TO BE TERMINATED
OR PUT ON LEAVE. SO WERE TRYING
TO HELP BRING THE SORT OF
AWARENESS OF WILL PREVENTING AND
WHERE WE'RE STARTING THING
EARLIER IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
GOING ON RYAN A RELATIONSHIP.
WE HAVE TO BE REALLY CLEAR THAT
WHEN THERE IS THIS TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP.
.
THAT YOU CAN'T CONSENT TO THE
POWER DIFFERENTIAL.
LIKE THERAPIST CAN HAVE SEX WITH
PATIENTS DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE
AGE OF THE PERSON AS.
WE HAVE THAT IN A LOT OF OTHER
PROFESSIONS WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IN A LOT OF JOBS THAT IF
YOU HAVE A CERTAIN POSITION.
SOMEONE REALLY CAN'T CONSENT AND
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE FOR YOU
TO GET INVOLVED WITH THEM. SO
THAT IF YOU CATCH IT EARLY
ENOUGH
AND SOME SAYS YOU KNOW I THINK
IT'S OKAY THERE AND ADULT THE
NOT IN MY CLASS NOW. THAT'S WHEN
YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH PREVENTION IS HAVE
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT IN A
TIMELY FASHION BEFORE SOMEONE
HAS CROSS THAT BOUNDARY ALIGNED
WITH IS NO GOING BACK. SEWER
TALK ABOUT PREVENTION ONCE.
THEY'VE CROSSED THE LINE THEN
THERE HAVE TO BE CONSEQUENCE YES
THERE HAS TO BE CONSEQUENCES
REPEAT BEHAVIOR OF IT IF THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES IT CONTINUES
AND YOU WANT THE CONSEQUENCES TO
BE PROPORTIONAL. AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES WITH HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT THAT HAPPENS IS WE
HAVE TENDED TO LOOK AT IT IN
TERMS OF THE INDIVIDUAL CREATES
A HOSTILE WORK ENVIRONMENT. WE
ARE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
CULTURES
I WAS INVOLVED.
EVALUATING SOMEONE WHO USED TO
WORK IN THE TEXAS LEGISLATURE IS
A PAGE. THEY USE TO MAKE THE
WOMEN WHO WERE PAGES WHERE LOW
CUT TOPS AND TRY TO SEE WHO
COULD PUT THE MOST AMOUNT OF
QUARTERS IN THEIR TOPS BY THE
END OF THE DAY.
I MEAN THAT WAS THE SORT OF
CULTURE THAT EXISTED IN THE
TEXAS LEGISLATURE WE HAVE TO BE
AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
TERMS OF GOVERNMENT. AND AND
CULTURE AND AND WHAT'S
ACCEPTABLE.
MY HAS NOT SO PROUD OF THE WAY
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN PUT
TOGETHER AND THE VERY FIRST
MEETING HAD TO DO WITH CULTURE.
IN CHANGING THE CULTURE.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE IT BEGINS.
THIS CHANGE IN THE CULTURE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO ALSO ADD THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE IN YOUR EXAMPLE
WHERE YOU HAVE A PROFESSOR IN A
AND IT'S AND A GRADUATE STUDENT
OR STUDENT.
.
OBVIOUSLY THE PROSSER'S BREAKING
POLICY STEPPING OVER THE LINE IN
SO MANY WAYS BECAUSE OF THE
POWER IMBALANCE.
THERE NEEDS TO BE PUNITIVE
RESPONSE BUT THERE ALSO NEEDS TO
BE RESTORED OF RESPONSE.
AND THAT BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE NOT SOLVING THE LONG TERM
PROBLEM. AND IT'S A LONG TERM
PROBLEM FOR THE FACULTY MEMBER
BUT YOU STILL HAVE NOT RESOLVE
THE ISSUE FOR THE STUDENT.
BECAUSE THE PROFESSOR IT IN THIS
CASE.
HAS HE USED THEIR POWER SO YOU
YOU WERE YOU'RE WORKING ON
RESTORATIVE. DISCIPLINE FOR THE
PROFESSOR BUT WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE VICTIM.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT IN THAT
SITUATION THAT THE PROP THE
PROFESSOR NEEDS TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE COMMUNITY. BECAUSE THE
STUDENT CAN'T THRIVE OTHERWISE
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
JUST REMOVING THAT PROFESSOR
WHICH WE'VE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND THEN THEY GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE JUSTICE YOU SEEN IN THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH AND WITH PRIESTS
AND OTHERWISE. IT DOESN'T SOLVE
THE LONG TERM SOCIETAL PROBLEM
SO PREVENTION IS THE BEST
BUT WE HAVE TO BOTH HAVE A
DISCIPLINARY AND RESTORATIVE
BECAUSE IF YOU DO NOT RECONNECT
THAT PERSON. TO SOME COMMUNITY
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY CAN START
TO BEHAVE IN A NORMALIZED
FASHION THEN YOU WILL BE
FIGHTING THIS FIGHT AND YOU WILL
BE PUTTING MORE. YOUNG PEOPLE AT
RISK OR PEOPLE AT RISK IN
GENERAL AND THIS ALSO VICTIM
SERVICES THAT CAN HAPPEN TO THE
LATE SEVENTIES.
I MEAN IT WASN'T UNTIL VINCE IN
SOME OTHER CASES THAT YOU BREAK
SHOULD LAWS REPLIED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WERE YOU COULD ARGUE
HAVE SOMEONE WAS DRESSED.
BASICALLY WAS THE BASIS OF WHY
YOU COULD OF ASSAULT SOMEONE YOU
NEED TO SUPPORT THOSE WHO COME
FORWARD BECAUSE IT TAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF COURAGE.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE THAT
IN IN THE MIX
AND WE'RE VERY FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING THOSE TO COME COME
FORWARD AND ENCOURAGING THEM
THAT'S THE PUSH BACK TECHNOLOGY
THEY GET SOMETHING BACK. THAT'S
BEING ABLE TO SEE THE NUMBERS
THAT THEY'RE NOT ALONE THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE LATELY.
LET'S LET'S NOT FORGET THAT WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF INTERNS AND
FOLLOWS.
WE'RE NOT.
EXACTLY LIKE BROUGH.
FACULTY AND STUDENTS.
AND WE HAVE MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT ARE MARRIED
TO STAFFERS.
I'M OWE WHO START OUT IS CO
EQUAL STAFFERS AND SOMEBODY GETS
ELECTED OR SOMEBODY GETS A
PROMOTION.
SO EVEN THOUGH IT ANTI NEPOTISM.
OR CO HABITATION AYE OR WHAT IS
THAT.
WHICH THE TERM.
.
YEAH.
POLICIES IN WE SHOULD DISCUSS
IT'S ALSO PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
YOU ALSO DON'T WANT TO THAT
WHILE YOU DON'T WANT THE. YOU
KNOW CREEPY LEGISLATOR ASKING
OUT YEAH. COULD.
NOT NOT SAY ANY NAMES BY THE WAY
HAS ALSO YOU ALSO DON'T WANT
PEOPLE THAT HAVE LEGITIMATE
RELATIONSHIPS HAVING TO HIDE
THEM FOR FEAR OF SOMEBODY LOSING
THEIR ALL THE ICE. SO IT'S A
LITTLE TRICKIER THAN IN THE CASE
WITH FACULTY RIGHT REALLY
GETTING IS A BRIGHT LINE. WE
DON'T OF THE LUXURY OF THAT
BRIGHT LINE WITH SOME OF THESE
ISSUES HERE AT GOOGLE AND
FACEBOOK JUST PUT A POLICY IN
THAT YOU CAN ASK SOMEBODY AT
ONCE AND IF THEY SAY. NO THAT'S
THAT BIT THAT YOU HAVE A ONE
YEAR ONE STRIKE AND YOU'RE OUT
POLICY DOES NOT REALIZE THAT
SOME.
HOLLYWOOD I WAS A DEVELOPMENT
EXECUTIVE I WILL HAVE TO REWRITE
THE PLOT OF EVERY SINGLE ROMANCE
MARINO I KNOW OUR MAY I KNOW HOW
THE.
I HAD I HAD A CLIENT WHO SAID
THAT YOU KNOW HAVE YOU NOT
CHASED IS IS THE. IS THE FIFTH
THEN AROUND REALLY WOULD NOT BE
MARRIED TO THIS DAY I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S THE OLD YOU KNOW
THE OLD FORTIES MOVIES AND
INVEST IN THE MOVIE CABLE GUY.
WHICH IS A MOVIE ABOUT STALKING
HE SAYS IS THERE ANY CHANCE
WE'LL GET TOGETHER MAYBE ONE IN
A MILLION THAT I HAVE A CHANCE.
AND THEN HE THAT HE KEEPS KEEPS
MOVING FORWARD IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO CREATE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WE ALSO KNOW. THAT
YOU FOLKS WORK VERY HARD YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO MEET
SOMEONE ELSE IF YOU SIGNAL
SINGLE YOU OFTEN FUND RAISING
YOUR MEETING WITH CONSTITUENTS.
SOCIAL PSYCH RESEARCH SAYS WE
TEND TO MEET THE PEOPLE IN THE
CIRCLE OF WHERE WE'RE WORKING.
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT WITH WITH THE VERY
NATURE OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
COMMITTED.
SOME OF THEM ARE WALDRON.
MADAM CHAIR I'M WILL QUICK TO
THESE APPLICATIONS.
DOCUMENT AND TRACK PROGRESS I
KNOW WE CAN.
I CAN SAVE DETAILS YOU CAN
REPORT TO ANY OF THEM GIVE THE
VICTIM ANY KIND OF UPDATE. IF
THERE ARE THINGS RECEIVED YOU
KNOW WHERE IT IS ON THE PROCESS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT. WHAT WE
WE HAVE AN AUTOMATIC YOU GET
AUTOMATIC REPLY THAT IT MERELY
SAYS THAT IT'S BEEN RECEIVED A
THAT IT'S AT THAT POINT UP TO
THE THE EMPLOYEE HERE? SO
THERE'S A YOU KNOW IT'S A
COMMUNICATION DEVICE
SO GOES BACK AND FORTH THEN
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE EMPLOYER AND THE
EMPLOYEE.
SO IT'S.
THE FIRST RESPONSE IS AUTOMATIC
THAT'S BEEN RECEIVED AFTER THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE BETWEEN THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE TO THE
HAVING EMPLOYEE YOU'RE. LET THE
EMPLOYEE KNOW WHERE IT IT SO.
IT'S GOING TO BE DEPENDENT
OBVIOUSLY ON THE EMPLOYER TO
LIKE THE EMPLOYEE KNOW WHAT THE
FIRST. RESPONSE IS AND YOU KNOW
IT. IT SOME POINT BUT AS IT'S
GOING TO BE THE EDUCATION OF THE
EMPLOYER TO. TO COMMUNICATE I
MEAN JUST LIKE JUST LIKE REALLY
ANY HOTLINE THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THUS FAR. IT'S GOING TO BE
INCUMBENT ON TRAINING OF THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB.
AND THAT THEY'RE DOING AN
ADEQUATE JOB IN GETTING BACK TO
THE EMPLOYEE.
THAT THAT PART BEAT WE KIND OF
CAN'T CHANGE BUTTON THAT'LL BE
UP TO ME AND IN MY EMPLOYEE IN
MY ATTORNEY HAT ROLE. MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WOULD.
IN THE CALLISTO MAP.
WORD HAS THE WAIT FOR OTHERS
LIKE SAY THEY.
REPORT OR PUT THEIR.
AND THEY'RE WAITING.
GROUP I MIGHT BE A MONTH LATER
IS THERE SOME KIND OF A MESSAGE
BACK OF SOMETHING THAT THEY GET
THAT NOTIFIES THEM SOMEONE HAS
REPORTED AND THEN THEY CAN GO
AHEAD AND.
REPORT OF THAT RIGHT SO IF THERE
IS A MATCH THAT OCCUR SO FEW
THROW EVERYTHING IN YOUR WAITING
ONCE THAT ANOTHER PERSON RIGHT
TO SAME INFORMATION ABOUT YOU
WILL GET EMAIL. LETTING YOU KNOW
THAT THERE WAS A MATCH
THEN YOU'LL GET EMAIL FROM
MYSELF THAT HAD ACCORDING TO OUR
PROCESS IS STREAMLINED I'M THE
ONLY PERSON WITH ACCESS TO ANY
THE REPORTS I GET SUBMITTED. YOU
GET EMAIL FROM ME LETTING YOU
KNOW WHICH YOU'RE AWARE THAT
THERE WAS A MATCH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SUBMIT YOUR FOR YOUR FULL
REPORT WOULD YOU LIKE TO FORWARD
IN THE PROCESS A LITTLE CALL BY
MEN. ACTUALLY DO YOU NOTIFY
THERE'S A MATCH THEY CAN STILL
CHOOSE AT THAT POINT IF THEY
WANNA BE A PART OF A PROCESS.
THE ISSUES THEY DON'T WANNA BE A
PART OF THE PROCESS BUT THEN
THAT'S OUR COMMUNICATION WITH
OUR OFFICE START.
THE OTHER THING WITH THESE
APPLICATIONS.
WHAT'S SECURITY YOUR PROCEDURAL
DRAWBACKS ARE THAT I MEAN IT'S
DIGITAL WE KNOW THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF.
BUT THAT SECURITY.
AND THEN THE LEGAL.
I MEAN IS EVERYTHING THERE.
THE BILL TO BE OPENED UP TO A
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST OR YOU
KNOW SOMETHING I AND ONE OF THE
PROTECTION.
UP SO IN TERMS OF SECURITY WE
HAVE STANDARD MILITARY TO ON A
FIFTY SIX BIT ENCRYPTION.
WHEN REPORTS GO OUT THEY CAN
NEITHER BE SEEN AGAIN ARE NOT
SEEN OR BIOMETRICS WILL BE
SEALED IN TERMS OF OUR DATA
CENTERS. WERE APPROVED AT THE
FOR HAVE BUCKLED GLOVES PURPOSE
SUPER PATRIOT ACT COMPLIANT.
OUR ARE LEGAL COUNSEL WAS THE
HEAD LEGAL COUNSEL FOR BLOOMBERG
MEDIAN RIGHT THE INTERNATIONAL
HAVE BOOKS ON LOT PRIVACY IN
LIBEL.
SO WE'VE WRITTEN WHITE PAPERS ON
CHILD NUDITY ON DEATH AFTER
REPEATING A REPORT BEING FILED
AND NOT BEING ACTED ON QUICK
ENOUGH. SO WE'VE APPROACHED ALL
THOSE IN TERMS OF WHAT'S GOING
ON.
WE ALSO PROVIDE AND THIS WAS
BECAUSE OUR CLIENTS ASK FOR IT.
A DETAILED LIST OF EVERYONE WHO
IS INVITED TO WORK ON ANY
PARTICULAR REPORT EVERYTHING'S
DOCUMENT AND LOCKED TIMESTAMP
INSIDE OF WHAT HAPPENS.
SO EVERY REPORT IS ITS OWN
ENTITY AND YOU CAN ONLY BE
INVITED TO IN TO SEE IF BY A
MODERATOR WHO'S PROPERLY CHANGE
IN THE LAW AND AS WELL AS AN
RESTORED TO PRACTICE.
OKAY OUR INFORMATION IS NOT
PUBLIC. BELONGS THEEMPLOYER.
AND SO WE HAVE ALL PRIVATE THE
IN THE APPROPRIATE PRICE THE
THAT I DID NOT AFTER. HER EIGHT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY ATTORNEYS
DID.
BUT THAT DAY ON THE AYE IT TO
THE INFORMATION BELONGS TO THE
EMPLOYER IT'S ENCRYPTED OF
COURSE BUT IT BELONGS THE
EMPLOYER SO. OBVIOUSLY THEY CAN
BE SUBPOENAED JUST LIKE ANY
EMPLOYER CAN BE SUBPOENAED.
BUT IT WOULD BE GOVERNED BY. IN
OF SUBPOENA AND AND YOU KNOW
DEPOSITION REQUEST JUST LIKE
ANYBODY.
COULD BE GOING FORWARD.
AND YOU WOULD HAVE THE SAME
INFORMATION.
YOU WOULD HAVE THE SAME
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE YOU
QUIT YOU KNOW INFORMATION OR PER
PRODUCT PRIVILEGES THAT WE ALL.
NO USE NOW IT'S IT'S WE DO BUT.
YOU KNOW WE TOOK THOSE
PROTECTIONS AS. AS AS GOOD
LAWYERS DIDN'T DO NOT IN.
BUILDING THIS DECIDE DOCUMENT.
AND THEN I JUST HAVE TO REALLY
QUICKLY CAN.
CAN YOU UPLOAD VIDEOS OR AUDIO
RECORDINGS AND PUT YEAH YEAH
REPORTING YEAH YOU CAN FOR CLOSE
TO A SO YOU CAN UPLOAD VIDEOS
PICTURES ARE AUDIO RECORD.
AND FALLS ASLEEP.
Q..
THIS IS BUT A REALLY AMAZING
PANEL IT'S INCREDIBLE WHAT WHAT
COULD BE DONE.
THANK.
AND IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST
STICKING AROUND US IN CASE AFTER
THE NEXT PANEL THERE'S FURTHER
QUESTIONS IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
HAVE YOU DON'T. FEEL LIKE I CAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH HOW WITHOUT
WILL BRING UP OUR LAST PANEL.
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
WHICH IS PROVIDING VICTIM
SUPPORT THROUGH REPORTING.
MODEL SYSTEMS
AND FOR THAT WE HAVE MARY WITH
COME COUNTY COUNCIL FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND JP SHERRY
GENERAL COUNSEL OF LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
WELCOME AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AND STICKING WITH US THROUGH.
THE PREVIOUS TWO PANELS HOW
ALLOW AND THIS WITH THEM TO
BEGIN WHATEVER SHE'S READY.
THANK YOU.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK OF THIS AFTERNOON BEFORE
ALL OF YOU. I MY NAME IS MARY
WHAT COME ON THE COUNTY COUNCIL
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AND I'M
HERE TO DISCUSS.
THE COUNTY'S POLICY OF EQUITY
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS A BEST
PRACTICE MODEL.
THE COUNTY WHO'S GOING TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
ON THE MODEL AND HOW IT CAME
INTO EXISTENCE AND I BELIEVE I
HAVE HANDOUTS.
TO KIND OF WALK US THROUGH SOME
OF IT.
SO BACK IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS ARE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WAS UNDER A VERY
DIFFICULT.
FEDERAL CONSENT DECREE CASE
AND ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THAT CASE.
WAS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPED A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICY.
I WAS THE LEAD COUNTY COUNCIL
ON THE CASE THE TIME. AND MYSELF
IN A GROUP OF A SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS OUTSIDE COUNSEL SPENT
ABOUT. SIX MONTHS.
DEVELOPING WHAT WE NOW REFER TO
AS THE COUNTY POLICY OF EQUITY.
A LOT OF THOUGHT AND
DELIBERATION WENT INTO THIS
MODEL. AND I WOULD SUBMIT. THAT
FOR ANY MODEL.
A LOT OF TIME AND CONSIDERATION
MUST BE PUT FORTH IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE YOU GET A MODEL THAT
WORKS FOR YOUR CULTURE.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT YOU'VE
BEEN TALKING TODAY A LOT ABOUT
CULTURE CHANGE THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT IS AT ISSUE HERE.
UP IN THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
WHICH YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS WAS
NOT A EASY CULTURE TO CHANGE
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND. SWAT YOU
KNOW EMPLOYEES.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SWORN OFFICERS
UP UNDER A FEDERAL CONSENT
DECREE.
TO DO THIS STILL RESISTED.
I AND IT TOOK A COUPLE YEARS
BEFORE WE STARTED TO SEE A
CHANGE IN THAT CULTURE.
BUT THE CULTURE DID CHANGE.
AND TODAY IT'S A CULTURE WHERE
REPORTING IS THE NORM.
SO THAT CULTURE BUT CHANGE WAS
NOT LOST ON OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND IT WORKED SO WELL IN THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND BROUGHT
THEM INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL CONSENT DECREE WHICH IS
NO SMALL TASK.
THAT OUR BOARD WANTED IT TO BE
A COUNTY WIDE MODEL.
SO BEGINNING IN TWENTY ELEVEN.
MYSELF IN A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WERE ASKED TO TURN IT INTO A
COUNTY WIDE MODEL. OUT WHICH WE
DID AND AGAIN WE SPENT SIX
MONTHS.
IN YOU KNOW WITH A SMALL GROUP
OF PEOPLE WORKING IN. AND OUT IN
A WAR ROOM TYPE ATMOSPHERE
DEVELOPING WHAT IT DOWN THE
COUNTY POST YOU'VE EQUITY.
SO GIVEN THE LATE HOUR I'M JUST
TO TOUCH ON OF PUBLIC
CHARACTERISTICS.
OF THE COUNTY POLICY OF EQUITY
WHICH WE BELIEVE MAKE IT THE
BEST MODEL AND DISTINGUISH IT
FROM OTHER MODELS.
.
THE FIRST THING THE POLICY
ITSELF
MOST HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION POLICIES.
START WITH HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION.
IN THE COUNTY WHAT WE DID IS WE
ADDED HADN'T AN ADDITIONAL
STANDARD. AND THAT STANDARD IS
INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT TOWARDS
OTHERS BASIN A PROTECTED CLASS
THIS IS THE POLICY THAT
ADDRESSES MORE THAN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ADDRESSES ALL THE
PROTECTED CLASSES. AND I WOULD
SUMMIT ANY.
IF YOU IF YOU'RE GOING TO THE
EXERCISE OF PUTTING IN PLACE A
NEW MECHANISM YOU MIGHT AS WELL
JUST ADDRESS ALL PROTECTED
CLASSES BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
THE BEST PRACTICE IN TODAY'S.
TODAY'S WORLD.
SO THIS INAPPROPRIATE CONDUCT
TOWARD OTHER STANDARD BASED IN A
PROTECTED CLASS IT REQUIRES MUCH
LESS THAN WHAT IS REQUIRED TO
VIOLATE HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION POLICY. FOR
EXAMPLE THE INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT IN THE WORKPLACE NEED
NOT BE SEVERE OR PERVASIVE OR
UNWELCOME OR INTENTIONAL TO
VIOLATE THE COUNTIES POLICY OF
EQUITY. IT CAN JUST BE
INAPPROPRIATE BUT IT HAS TO BE
TETHERED TO ONE OF THE PROTECTED
CLASSES
SO FOR EXAMPLE AN INAPPROPRIATE
JOKE ABOUT SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
RACE OR SEX OR RELIGION. MAY
TRIGGER A POTENTIAL VIOLATION OF
OUR POLICY. AND RESULT IN A
COMPLAINT BEING FILED AN
INVESTIGATION BEING CONDUCTED AN
APPROPRIATE ACTION YOU KNOW
BEING TAKEN.
WHAT'S SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THAT
AND WHAT'S WORK SO WELL IN THE
COUNTY. IT'S BECAUSE THE
STANDARD IS LOWER THE EMPLOYERS
PUT ON NOTICE OF INAPPROPRIATE
LEVEL
DISCRIMINATION. YOU'RE ABLE TO
INTERVENE EARLY AND CORRECT IT
AND THAT RESULTS IN OFTEN FOLKS
NOT LOSING THEIR JOB BUT INSTEAD
MAY BE RECEIVING COUNSELING OR
WRITTEN REPRIMAND OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. WHICH IS REALLY THE
CULTURE YOU WANT. YOU DON'T WANT
THAT IF THE CONDUCT IS SEVERE
ENOUGH OF COURSE THAT MAY RESULT
IN SOME BE LOSING THEIR JOB BUT
WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT WERE ABLE
TO GET AT THE CONDUCT MUCH
SOONER.
AND OUR CULTURE IS ONE THAT
INSISTS THAT SUPPORTS FILING
COMPLAINTS
WE WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES ON AVERAGE WE RECEIVE
FIVE TO SIX THOUSAND COMPLAINTS
A YEAR.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M
OFTEN ASKED ABOUT WHEN THEY
DISCUSS OUR POLICY SOME FOLKS
STILL UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
IF YOU HAVE A LOT OF COMPLAINTS
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS
THAT'S NOT. THAT'S NOT IT IF YOU
HAVE NO COMPLAINTS YOU HAVE A
LOT PROBLEMS IF YOU HAVE SIX
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS YOU'VE GOT A
HEALTHY WORKPLACE WHERE PEOPLE
FEEL SAFE. TO COME FORWARD AND
COMPLAIN AND THAT'S THE MODEL
YOU WANT TO KIND OF MOVE
TOWARDS.
ANOTHER CRITICAL.
THAT ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO ANY
NEW POLICY THAT YOU ROLL OUT IS
THAT YOU MUST EDUCATE BEHIND IT
YOU MUST HAVE A ROBUST EDUCATION
ARM WHEN YOU INTRODUCE NEW
POLICY. SENATOR MITCHELL YOU
WERE DISCUSSING IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THIS YEAR HAS MANDATED THAT. ALL
DEPARTMENTS GO TO IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING AND THAT SORT OF.
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATING THE
WORKPLACE IS REQUIRED FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND IT'S A NEW DAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU THINK IT'S
FUNNY. A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT. AND
YOU HAVE TO EDUCATE AND YOU
CAN'T DISMISS THAT CONCERN.
I MEAN FAIR ENOUGH
FOR FOLKS TO THINK YOU MEAN I
CAN'T SAY THAT ANYMORE. AND THEY
NEED TO BE TRAINED THAT'S RIGHT
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ANYMORE A
RIGHT AND THAT TAKES SOME TIME
BEFORE WE INTRODUCE THE COUNTY
POLICY OF EQUITY WE SPENT THAT
TIME ON THE FRONT END. EDUCATING
OUR SUPERVISORS WHO DID RECEIVE
OUR SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
THEY'VE RECEIVED TRAINING
DIFFERENT
THEN THE REST OF THE WORKFORCE
IN THE LONG CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
THAT. SUPERVISORS MUST HAVE A
MUST BE TRAINED DIFFERENTLY IN
AND WHAT THEIR ROLE IS WHAT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE AND
WHAT THE LIABILITIES FOR THE
EMPLOYER IF THEY FAIL TO ACT.
BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA IF A
SUPERVISORS INVOLVED IN THE
CONDUCT ITS STRICT LIABILITY FOR
THE EMPLOYER YOU DON'T HAVE A
DEFENSE YOU'RE LIABLE. SO THEY
HAVE TO BE EDUCATED IN THAT.
ANOTHER KEY.
DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
ABOUT OUR POLICY IS THAT WE
HAVE A CENTRALIZED INTAKE UNIT.
THERE IS NO BARRIER TO FILING A
COMPLAINT UNDER A POLICY OF
EQUITY IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES DON'T HAVE TO GO TO YOUR
SUPERVISOR YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH OUR HR UNIT. YOU GO
DIRECTLY IN YOUR ENCOURAGED TO
GO DIRECTLY TO OUR INTAKE UNIT.
AND THAT'S WORKED LIKE A CHARM
BECAUSE YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID PEOPLE ONE PEOPLE GO TO
WORK TO EARN A LIVING GET A
PAYCHECK GO HOMEAND TAKE CARE
OF THEIR FAMILIES BASICALLY. IF
THEY'RE CAUGHT UP IN SOMETHING A
WITNESS SOMETHING THEY MAY NOT
WANT TO GET INVOLVED IN IT.
YEAH THEY CERTAINLY MAY WANT TO
GO TO THEIR BOSS WITH THEIR HR
DEPARTMENT IF THAT MEANS
REVEALING THEIR IDENTITY AND ALL
OF THAT'S IN THE COUNTY WE'VE
ELIMINATED THAT AS A BARRIER. GO
DIRECTLY TO THE INTAKE UNIT IN
THE INTAKE UNIT IN THIS IS
ANOTHER CRITICAL FACT AND AND
REQUIREMENT MY VIEW IS STAFFED
BY SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS.
MANY OF THEM OF EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS FOLKS WITH HR BACKGROUND
SO IN THE COMPLAINT COMES IN AND
THE COMPLAINTS ARE ALL BUILT ON
A.
BUT DATABASE YOU FILE ONLINE YOU
POPULATE A SCRIPT BASICALLY WE
WE WALKED THE COMPLAINING PARTY
THROUGH A SCRIPT SO WHAT COMES
IN IS A NARRATIVE. OF WHATEVER
THE INCIDENT IS THERE ALLOWED TO
IDENTIFY WITNESSES AND ALL OF
THAT THE INTAKE UNIT RECEIVES
THAT DIGITALLY YOU CAN ALSO
CAUSE YOU KNOW MAKE A PHONE CALL
OR COME IN PERSON. BUT ARE OVER
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
COMPLAINTS COMING ONLINE.
AND THEN OUR SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS OUR INTAKE UNIT ASSESS
THE COMPLAINT EVERY COMPLAINT
THAT COMES INTO THE INTAKE UNIT
GETS AN INITIAL INVESTIGATION.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
OFTEN THE COMPLAINING PARTY IS
SPOKEN TO SO WE HEAR THEM WE
HEAR THEIR STORY IF A WITNESS IS
IDENTIFIED WE SPEAK TO THE
WITNESS IF EVIDENCE IS
INTRODUCED. WE LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE IN THE INTAKE UNIT THEN
MAKES AN ASSESSMENT WHETHER
BASED ON THAT INITIAL COMPLAINT
THERE'S A POTENTIAL VIOLATION OF
THE POLICY OR NOT.
IF THEY DETERMINE THEIR REYES
THEN IT GOES FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION
AND THE FURTHER INVESTIGATION
INVOLVES INTERVIEWING THE
SUBJECT OR THE INVOLVED PERSON.
THAT'S ANOTHER CRITICAL
COMPONENT YOU MUST AFFORD DUE
PROCESS
TO BOTH SIDES OF THIS EQUATION.
IT'S JUST NOT APPROPRIATE TO
HEAR A BASE A DECISION ON ONE
SIDE OF THE STORY YOU HAVE TO
HEAR BOTH SIDES OF THE STORY IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE.
FOR THOSE COMPLAINTS THAT WHERE
THERE IS SOMETHING THERE IN THE
GOES TO FURTHER INVESTIGATION
THEN ULTIMATELY THAT
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT IS
PRESENTED TO IN THIS IS ANOTHER
KEY.
.
REQUIRED THAT ARE DISTINCTION
ABOUT OUR OUR PROCESS.
TO AN OUTSIDE PIANO OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS TO THE COUNTY HAS
RETAINED NINE THAT NINE. OF WHAT
WE CALL A COUNTY EQUITY
OVERSIGHT PANEL MEMBERS THERE
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS THERE HR
SPECIALISTS.
THEY WORK PURSUANT A CONTRACT
WITH THE COUNTY THEY'RE NOT
COUNTY EMPLOYEES AGAIN TERMINATE
THEM UMP AT WILL. AND THEY WORK
FOR BASICALLY IT'S ALMOST PRO
BONO THEY WORK FOR A FRACTION OF
THEIR NORMAL RATE. SO ANY
COMPLETED INVESTIGATION GETS
REVIEWED BY THIS FORUM AND EVERY
WEEK IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE.
C. E. O. P. HEARINGS AND AT
THOSE HEARINGS IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE COMPLAINANT IN THE SUBJECT
AT THAT POINT IT'S ABOUT THE
INVOLVED DEPARTMENT. THE
INVESTIGATION IN THE PANEL SO
THE INVOLVED DEPARTMENT SHOWS UP
FOR EXAMPLE THE TO COMPLAIN
AGAINST THE FIRE DEPARTMENT OR
THE FIRE CHIEF. THAT CHAIN OF
WILL BE THERE WE MEET IN PANELS
OF THREE.
EVERYONE'S EXPECTED TO REVIEW
THE INVESTIGATION BEFORE THAT
HEARINGS THAT THEY'RE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ON THE FACTS.
AND WHAT'S FABULOUS ABOUT THESE
HEARINGS IS THAT'S WHERE THE
DIALOGUE IN THE EDUCATION
HAPPENS BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
EXPLAINING. TO YOU KNOW THE
INVOLVED DEPARTMENT MEMBERS.
WHY THIS CONDUCT VIOLATED OUR
POLICY AND THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR FOLKS TO ASK QUESTIONS TO
PUSH BACK TO GET CLARIFICATION
ON BOTH SIDES?
BUT AT THE END OF THE PIANO
THEN MAKES A RECOMMENDATION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF WHAT THEY
THINK IF THE POLICIES AND
VIOLATE WHAT THEY THINK THE
APPROPRIATE DISCIPLINE SHOULD
BE.
AND NOT JUST GUIDED BY YOU KNOW
THE SEVERITY OF THE CONDUCT
INVOLVED. ULTIMATELY IT'S UP TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO ACCEPT THE
RECOMMENDATION OR NOT.
NINETY NINE PERCENT OF THE TIME
THEY DO BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE
THE RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
SPENT IN IN.
COMING FORWARD OR SUBSTANTIATING
THE RECOMMENDATION
SO THAT HAS WORKED VERY WELL.
ANOTHER DISTINGUISHING
CHARACTERISTICS SUPERVISORS IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
MANAGEMENT SUPERVISORS THEY HAVE
AN AFFIRMATIVE DUTY.
TO REPORT POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS
OF THE POLICY OF EQUITY.
SO IF I'M A SUPERVISOR A MANAGER
AND I WITNESSED SOMETHING OR
FROM PUT ON NOTICE OF SOMETHING.
A POTENTIAL VIOLATION OF OUR
POLICY AND I FAILED TO REPORT
IT.
I MYSELF WILL BE SUBJECT TO
DISCIPLINE FOR FAILURE TO
REPORT.
AND THAT HAS WORKED LIKE A
CHARM.
BECAUSE.
IF A SUPERVISOR SEES SOMETHING
AND SWEEPS IT UNDER THE RUG AT
THE EMPLOYER IS LIABLE FOR THAT
CONDUCT SO WE WANTED TO MAKE OUR
SUPERVISORS ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVE
SOME SKIN IN THE GAME. AND.
AND IT'S WORKED VERY WELL.
.
OTHER THINGS IN. THAT THAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND ANY BEST
PRACTICE MODEL MUST HAVE AN
HOUR'S HAS IS AN OPTION FOR
MEDIATION.
WE OFFER MEDIATION TO THE
COMPLAINING PARTY OR ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO THROUGH IT IT'S
VOLUNTARY. BUT IT GIVES ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEBODY TO BE
HEARD AND LISTEN TO AND HAVE
THEIR CONCERNS ADDRESSED.
AND. FINALLY. I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD CONCLUDE WITH THERE ARE
TWO POINTS.
ONE IS NO MATTER HOW SUCCESSFUL
YOUR MODEL IS.
IT WILL NEVER ELIMINATE. ALL
HARASSMENT OR INAPPROPRIATE
CONDUCT IN THE WORKPLACE I JUST
WANT.
BUT A WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
MITIGATED IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WE'VE CUT OUR EMPLOYMENT
LITIGATION COSTS AS A RESULT OF
THIS MODEL IN HALF.
FROM THIRTY MILLION DOWN TO
FIFTEEN MILLION OCCASIONALLY AT
SPIKE'S WE HAVE A BAD CASE BUT
IT DOESN'T ELIMINATED WE STILL
HAVE BAD CASES SOMETIMES PEOPLE
JUST DON'T COME FORWARD. BUT
WHEN WE PUT ON NOTICE OF IT WERE
ABLE TO INTERVENE IN AND
MITIGATE OUR DAMAGES AND ADDRESS
THE CONDUCT.
AND THEN FINALLY AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE BUT I'LL SAY AGAIN TO THE
I BELIEVE IT'S SO IMPORTANT HAVE
BEEN HAVING IMPLEMENTED THIS
MODEL INTO. A SIGNIFICANT AND.
ZONES.
THAT YOU MUST TAKE A MINUTE.
AND HAVE A GROUP OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS COME TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
YOUR WORKPLACE THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING YOU CAN JUST SLAP
TOGETHER. IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE%
FITS ALL A LOT OF WHAT'S BEEN
DISCUSS TODAY AND THERE'S A LOT
OF BEST PRACTICES THAT SHOULD BE
IN ANY MODEL. BUT YOU STILL NEED
TO LOOK AT YOUR WORKPLACE AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT WOULD WORK BEST.
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES OUR
BORDERS SUPERVISORS WHO ARE
ELECTED HAVE SUBJECTED
THEMSELVES TO THEIR POP TO THE
MOST OF EQUITY.
SO THEY HOLD THEMSELVES THEY
OPERATE UNDER THE SAME POLICY IS
THE REST OF US.
IF COMPLAINTS COMING AGAINST
THEM THEY'RE SUBJECTED TO THE
SAME INVESTIGATION AN OUTCOME AS
THE REST OF US AND THAT SAYS A
LOT TOO BECAUSE LEADERSHIP AT
THE TOP MUST SUPPORT IT.
MUST SUPPORT IT IF IT'S GONNA
WORK AT ALL.
YOU HAVE MOVED TO A MISTER
SHERRY NOW AND THEN WE'LL COME
BACK TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JP SHERRY
ON THE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
LOS RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO I
ALSO COORDINATE OUR GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS.
SACRAMENTO CALL ARABS ARE LESS
RISK ME BECAUSE DISTRICT IS MADE
UP OF THE AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGES
FOR SOME THE SERVER COLLEGE FOR
SOME MY COLLEGE IN SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE. WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN THOUSAND PLUS OR MINUS
EMPLOYEES.
I WAS ASKED TO COME TO YOU TO
SHARE WITH YOU OUR PRACTICES FOR
CREATING THE CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATE PROGRAM OF EACH OF OUR
COLLEGES. AYE AND YOU SHOULD
HAVE NO IN FRONT OF YOU.
THREE HIM DOUBTS ABOUT THIS IS
ONE HAND OUT A BELIEVER STAFF
MEMBER GRABBED ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE A THIRD ONE HERE. BUT THE
TO.
ONE PAGE HANDOUTS YOU HAVE ON
PAGE FIVE AND SEVEN OF THE
LARGER BOOK AND I'LL TALK ABOUT
THOSE IN A MOMENT.
I WAS ASKED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHY WE DID THIS AND THEN
WHAT IT IS AYE WE STARTED.
THIS PROGRAM WHEN MY BOARD
PRESIDENT PAMELA HANDS MANY OF
YOU MAY KNOW HER FROM HER YEARS
HERE AT THE AT THE LEGISLATURE.
WAS MEETING WITH BARBARA BOXER'S
OFFICE.
THE STAFF MEMBER AT THAT POINT
AND TIME IS ABOUT THREE YEARS
AGO ASKED WHETHER THE DISTRICT
HAD A CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE
PROGRAM.
AND WHEAT WE ASKED SENATOR
BOXER FOR SOME MONEY TO FUND
THAT AND SHE WAS NOT WILLING TO
PROVIDE THAT.
BUT IT DID MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
TO US.
THAT WE DID NEED TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF A PROGRAM IN PLACE AT
OUR COLLEGES AND WE STARTED THE
PRACTICE OF GETTING THERE FROM
HERE.
OUR FIRST STEP WHEN WE RETURN
TO CALIFORNIA WAS TO TAKE A VERY
CAREFUL LOOK AT ARE POLICIES AND
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE. OUR THAT
ALL OF THE REGULATIONS BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE AS WELL AS
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WERE
CORPORATE IT INTO OUR POLICIES
AND REGULATIONS AND MAKE MANY
CHANGES TO OUR POLICIES
REGULATIONS MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
APPROPRIATE AND REQUIRE
PROVISIONS WERE. INCLUDED FOR
EXAMPLE WE NOW HAVE POLICY THAT
SAYS ALL OF OUR FOLKS WILL BE A.
APPROPRIATELY TRAINED IN DEALING
WITH SEXUAL ASSAULT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND STALKING.
WE HAVE A CAREFULLY CRAFTED
POLICY ON CONFIDENTIALITY WHEN
WE CAN MAINTAIN IT WHEN WE
CANNOT.
I WE ALSO HAVE A POLICY
REQUIRING REQUIRING A PREVENTION
AND AWARENESS PROGRAM THAT WAS
BEEFED UP A LOT OF THIS REVIEW.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DID OUT
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO IS
WE CONTRACTED WITH A COMPANY
CALLED STUDENT SUCCESS DOT ORG.
THEY PROVIDE A PROGRAM CALLED
NOT ANYMORE NOT ANYMORE PROGRAM
IS AN INTERACTIVE ONLINE PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO PREVENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT. DIMMITT DATING IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND STOCKINGS
IT PROVIDES TRUE STUDENT. A
TESTIMONIOS WHICH ARE DESIGNED
TO FOSTER A EMPATHY AND
UNDERSTANDING IN THE IN THE
FOLKS WHO VIEW IT AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND. OF WHAT SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL VIOLENCE IS AND
HOW IT CAN BE PREVENTED AND WHAT
ROLES THEY CAN HAVE IN
PREVENTING IT EVEN IF THEY'RE
JUST A BYSTANDER IN THE
PARTICULAR SITUATION.
IN ORDER TO GIVE THAT PROGRAM
SOME TIEF WE'VE TASKED OUR
STUDENT GOVERNMENT LEADERS ARE
STUDENT.
PRESIDENT IN HIS CABINET ARE
STUDENT CLASS ATHLETES AND THEIR
FOLKS TO BE THE ROLE MODELS FOR
THIS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
SHOWING THIS PROGRAM AS MUCH AS
THEY CAN. THAT THEY'RE TELLING
PEOPLE THAT THEY'VE SEEN AS A
GROUP AND THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THEIR TRAINING
IS STUDENTS.
WE NEXT QUIRK TO CREATE A
PROGRAM WHERE STUDENTS FACULTY
AND STAFF HOW TO CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATE.
PRIOR TO THE ADDITION OF THE
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE OUR
STUDENTS FACULTY STAFF HAD TWO
CHOICES FOR HELP THEY COULD GO
TO OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT WHERE
THEY COULD GO TO ARE SPECIALLY
TRAINED TITLE NINE OFFICER
ANNOUNCED FOR HOW.
IF THEY DIDN'T WANT TO A GO TO
EITHER OF THOSE THEY DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE A CHOICE.
OBVIOUSLY THOSE RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN TRAINED PROVIDE A SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND STAFF AND FACULTY THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULT. BUT.
THOSE FOLKS DID NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT CONFIDENTIAL AND THAT
WAS WHERE WE WENT WITH THIS
PROGRAM.
WE STARTED OUT WITH THE IDEA
THAT WE WOULD APPOINT ONE OR TWO
OR THREE PEOPLE EACH OF THE
COLLEGES TO BE THIS CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATE.
WE QUICKLY LEARNED THAT THE LAW
WOULD NOT ALLOW US TO DO THAT
BECAUSE IT IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE DO NOT HAVE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRISIS COUNSELORS WHO ARE
EMPLOYED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
AND WITHOUT THAT UNDERPINNING
THE PERSON TO WHOM A STUDENT OR
FACULTY MEMBER OR STAFF MEMBER
WENT TO. WOULD NOT HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO REFUSE TO TALK TO
ANYBODY ELSE ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE REPORT.
GIVEN THAT IF A PERSON WHO
COMMITTED AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST ONE OF OUR FOLKS.
ACTUALLY DID IT AGAIN AND WE
KNEW ABOUT IT AND WE HAD SOME OF
THAT A PRIVILEGE TO REPORTED THE
COLLEGES ACTUALLY COULD BE
LIABLE FOR THE ACTIONS OF THAT
PERSON.
AS A RESULT WE DECIDED WE NEEDED
TO FIND THAT PERSON AND WE WENT
OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY AND WE
FOUND WE'VE WE'VE AS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY'S. PRIMARY OUR PROVIDER
OF CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THEY HIRE SEXUAL ASSAULT HOW
PREVENTION COUNSELORS AND WE
CONTRACTED WITH WE'VE TO PUT
SOMEONE ON OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES
TWENTY HOURS A WEEK. OF FIVE
HOURS A DAY ARE YOU EACH OF THE
COLLEGES.
WE PUT A WEAVE EMAIL IN PLACE
WHICH IS ONLY ACCESSIBLE TO THAT
PERSON THAT'S WE'VE GOT LOS RIOS
DOT EDU. HOW WE GIVE THEM THEIR
OWN PHONE NUMBER IT'S NINE ONE
SIX FIVE SIX EIGHT THREE ZERO
ONE ONE ONCE AGAIN THAT IS ONLY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE WE'VE
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE ON OUR
PROGRAM?
THE WE'VE CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATES
JOB LOS RIOS
TO PROVIDE ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
CONFIDENTIAL ADVICE.
THEY WILL NOT TELL ANYBODY WHAT
IS TOLD TO THEM UNLESS THE
PERSON WHO TELLS THEM THAT WANTS
THEM TO.
THEY WILL TELL THEM ABOUT OUR
POLICE SERVICES THERE WILL TELL
THEM ABOUT OUR TITLE NINE
OFFICER THEY WILL TELL THEM
WATER COLLEGES WILL DO IN TERMS
OF HELPING THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
AND DESCRIBE THE PROCESSES OF
BOTH THE CRIMINAL PROCESS AND
THE CIVIL PROCESS THAT RELATES
TO THAT CRIME THAT'S BEEN
COMMITTED AGAINST THEM.
BECAUSE THEY ARE SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR THEY HAVE THAT
PRIVILEGE REFUSE TO REVEAL ANY
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THEM BY
THE SURVIVOR.
AND.
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ALL OF THAT.
IS THAT THIS PERSON'S REAL JOB
IS TO SIT WITH THE PERSON.
WHETHER IT'S AT A HOSPITAL.
WHETHER IT'S AT A HEARING.
WHETHER IT'S WHEN THEY'RE GO
TALK TO THE POLICE WHETHER IT'S
PART OF OUR DISCIPLINE OUR
PROCESSES VERY THERE TO SUPPORT
THE PERSON WHO'S COME TO THEM
FOR HELP AND THAT'S WHAT. IS
MOST IMPORTANT TO ME ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM.
OBVIOUSLY ARE WE FOLKS
UNDERSTAND WHERE COLLEGE
PROPHECIES ARE AND WHERE POLICE
PROCESSES ARE IN MAY WILL
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
SOMEONE WHO COMES TO THEM SO
WE'RE GETTING THAT INFORMATION
TO THEM CONFIDENTIALLY. AND THEY
GET TO MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION
ABOUT WHAT TO DO ONCE THAT
INFORMATION'S BEEN REPORTED.
THE ONLY INFORMATION THE
COLLEGES GET IS VERY DE
IDENTIFIED INFORMATION AS YOU
FOR BEFORE WE S. COLLEGES HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SO WE HEAR ABOUT OR KNOW ABOUT
SITUATIONS WHERE VIOLENCE IS
BEING PORTRAYED HER SEXUAL
VIOLENCE IS BEING. PERPETRATED
ON OUR STUDENTS BY CLEAR STAFF
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHERE IT'S
HAPPENING HOW IT'S HAPPENING
WHAT. WHAT WHAT IS HAPPENING SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE PROACTIVE
MEASURES TO STOP IT AND SO WE
GET? THAT VERY GENERIC SOMEONE
WAS HURT IN THIS PARTICULAR
PLACE AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME.
POSSIBLY.
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE VICTIM
IF IT'S APPROPRIATE AND.
YEAH I ANONYMOUS ENOUGH SO THAT
IT WILL NOT GIVE AWAY THE
VICTIMS IN IDENTITY TO US IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY PREFER. SO THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT THIS TO MAKE SURE
TITLE NINE OFFICERS HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING OUR FOLKS.
.
IF OUR WE'VE PERSON IS AT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE IN THE
PERSON WHO NEEDS THEM AS A CRC
THEY WILL TRAVEL.
IF THE PERSON NEEDS THEM AFTER
HOURS OF THAT NUMBER IS A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN NUMBER THAT EMAILS A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NUMBER AND
WE'VE OBVIOUSLY HAS IT'S OWN
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NUMBER THAT WE
PROVIDE TO OUR STUDENTS.
.
ONCE THIS PROGRAM WAS UP AND
RUNNING ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
WE DID IS WE MADE SURE THAT
EVERY PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT
WERE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE EITHER
UNDER LAW. OR IT'S GOOD
INFORMATION.
TO ARE A PERSON WHO SUFFER FROM
SEXUAL VIOLENCE RELATIONSHIP
VIOLENCE OR STALKING WHO WAS IN
ONE PLACE PENCIL WE CAME UP WITH
THIS BOOKLET.
IT'S THIRTYFIVE PAGES FRANKLY
IT'S TOO LONG AND IT HOW IT IS
AS COMPREHENSIVE AS
COMPREHENSIVE COMES BUT YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU NEED TO GET SOME SLEEP
ONE O THESE DAYS TAKE A READ ON
SOME OF THESE PIECES.
BUT WE THOUGHT WHAT WAS REALLY
MORE IMPORTANT WAS TO GIVE
PEOPLE.
MANAGEABLE INFORMATION
AND SO WE WENT TOGETHER WE
CREATED THIS INFOGRAPHIC WHICH
IS YOUR CHOICES FOR HELP
BASICALLY SETS FORTH THE THREE
CHOICES OUR STUDENTS FACULTY AND
STAFF HOUSE. HAS THE
COMMUNICATION INFORMATION THEIR
EMAIL OR THEIR PHONE NUMBERS.
FOR TITLE NINE OFFICE I'M SORRY
ARE FOR A TITLE NINE OFFICERS
THERE'S A YEAR OR YOU ARE EL SO
THAT THEY CAN GET BECAUSE THOSE
FOLKS CHANGE FROM TIME TO TIME
SO THEY CAN GET ALL THAT
INFORMATION. ON THE BACK THERE'S
PHONE NUMBERS TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ALL THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN PART. SO THAT WAS AN EASY
DOCUMENT WE WILL SHIP THIS TO
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY WHO WANTS
IT WE POSTED AS FAR AND WIDE AS
WE CAN ON THE COLLEGES. AND DAD
THIS IS OUR SECOND VERSION OF IT
I HAVE TO BUY GIVE KUDOS TO MY
PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICE
BECAUSE HE TOOK THE FIRST
VERSION AND JUST MADE IT WAY
BETTER AND WAY MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR STUDENTS.
THE SECOND PIECE OF INFORMATION
WE CAME UP WITH WAS YOUR YOUR.
KEACH KEY POINTS AT A GLANCE
DOCUMENT THIS DOCUMENT PROVIDES
IN SHORT SIMPLE PLAIN LANGUAGE
TO SOMEONE WHO'S JUST SUFFERED
FROM SERIOUS ARE. A TRAUMA WHAT
DO I DO AFTER THIS HAPPENED WHO
ARE REPORTED TO WHAT IS
CONFIDENTIALITY MEAN ONE OF THE
LEGAL RIGHTS AND WHAT WILL THE
COLLEGE STUDENTS WE TRY TO DO
THAT IS SHORT AND SIMPLE AND
PLAIN AS WE COULD IN A SINGLE
DOCUMENT.
WE'RE PRETTY PROUD OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS IT TOOK A LOT OF WORK
FROM OUR.
POLICE DEPARTMENT OR TITLE NINE
FOLKS OUR STUDENTS SERVICES
FOLKS I ENTER PUBLIC RELATIONS
FOLKS ON AND AS I MENTIONED ALL
THREE OF THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR YOU.
WITH THAT.
I WOULD ALSO INDICATE THAT THAT
THIS IS OUR.
SECOND YEAR OF HAVING A WE'VE
CONFIDENTIAL ADVOCATE PROGRAM IN
PLACE. I DURING THE FIRST YEAR
WE HAD REPORTS OF TWO ON CAMPUS
SEXUAL ASSAULTS THAT PASSED FOR
SERVICES FROM THIS PARTICULAR
PERSON. AND WE ALSO RECEIVED
INFORMATION ABOUT EIGHTEEN OFF
CAMPUS ASSAULTS FOR WHICH WERE
THE WE FOLKS WERE WERE BEING
HELPFUL TO THE VICTIMS OF THOSE.
SITUATIONS.
I SHOULD SAY SURVIVORS EXCUSE
ME.
THE WE'VE CONFIDENTIAL
ADVOCATES OTHER ROLE IN OUR
COLLEGES IS ALSO TO HELP US WITH
SEXUAL AWARENESS AND SEXUAL
AWARENESS PREVENTION.
OUR AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
PREVENTION.
THEY ASSISTED WITH FORTY TWO
PREVENTION EDUCATION TRAININGS
PRESENTATION PRESENTATIONS AN
OUTREACH EVENTS AND ATTENDED A
TON OF MEETINGS IN EACH OF OUR
COLLEGES HOPING OUR FOLKS TO PUT
OUR SEXUAL SO PROGRAM INTO PLACE
AND WE HAVE A. A SECOND BUT DIED
LOOKS VERY SIMILAR TO THIS ONE
WHICH IS OUR SEXUAL ASSAULT
PREVENTION.
A PROGRAM IN WHICH ARE EACH OF
THE COLLEGES ARE UNDERTAKING
ACTIVITIES ON A DAILY ON A
YEARLY BASIS. ADDRESSING SEXUAL
PERSON.
ASSAULT PREVENTION SO WITH THAT
I'LL ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RUNNING
SPEAK THANK YOU DESERVE VERY
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
DOCUMENTS BY THE WAY. VERY
CLEAR SAID UNDERSTAND I DO I'M
GONNA START OFF WITH A QUESTION
FOR MS Y. COME.
I AM VERY INTERESTED KNOW AS WE
SORT THROUGH ITS WERE TALKING
ABOUT REPORTING BUT ALSO OF
COURSE THE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
YOU REPORT. PART IS.
ELIGIBLE PARTS OF IN THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE GETTING INTO AND
SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS
BUT YOU DID TALK ABOUT THE MODEL
THAT LA COUNTY HOUSE WITH THE
PANEL OF. JUDGES THEIR CURRENT
JUDGES NO THERE THERE OUGHT
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WHO OKAY
SUBJECT WE HAVE SOME RETIRED YET
WE JUST ADDED A RETIRED JUDGE
OKAY.
BUT.
MOSTLY EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS AYE
THOSE OF HR BACKGROUND OKAY SO
LET ME ASK YOU IT WILL BE.
FIRST.
THE OVERSIGHT PANEL.
THANK YOU.
SO WOULD LAST HERE AND A FEW
CHANCES HERE BUT WE HAD AND
RAVEL A FORMALLY OF THE A PPC.
WHO WAS HERE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
ROLE AS OVERSIGHT OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND AND
OTHER AREAS CAMPAIGN FINANCE?
ON SOME SOME TYPES OF ETHICS
VIOLATIONS
AND SHE DID WARN ABOUT THE. OF
THE.
PARTICULAR.
.
FLAVOR OF ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
WHAT THE THE SORT OF THE PULL
THE POLITICAL PRESSURES THAT
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE UNDER AND
SHE TALKED ABOUT ON THAT. THAT
YOU KNOW. INVESTIGATING AND
HAVING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
EMPLOYEES. BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICIZING VARMINTS THAT THAT
WE OPERATE IN.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING.
IT GIVE A IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THAT.
AS THIS IS WORK I YOU MENTIONED
THAT.
THE SUPERVISORS ARE UNDER THE
SAME UMBRELLA WHICH I APPRECIATE
BUT I IT ALSO SEEMS THAT THEY'VE
NEVER ACTUALLY BEEN INVESTIGATED
BY THIS PANEL.
SO I'M UNLESS I'VE AYE WELL I
MEAN THAT THE PANEL OF REVIEWS
THE INVESTIGATION RIGHT THAT
MAKES AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT.
BUT.
YOU KNOW DOES.
THE ELECTED ARE SUBJECTED TO THE
SAME YOU KNOW REQUIREMENTS AS
ANYONE ELSE WE'RE MINDFUL THAT
IN WE WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
OUTSIDE. RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
REACH OUT TO DEPENDING ON YOU
KNOW WHO THE COMPLAINT MIGHT BE
AGAINST.
YEAH AND DEPENDING ON THE FACTS
SO BUT IF IT'S A YOU KNOW A
SIGNIFICANT SET OF FACTS OR A
SIGNIFICANT INDIVIDUAL THE
COMPLAINT IS BEING MADE AGAINST.
MAYBE WILL BRING AN OUTSIDE
COUNSEL TO THAT INVESTIGATION
COULD SO IT IS GOODS GET
FINISHED COULD JUST GET TO THE
QUESTION ACTUALLY JUST I'M A.
YOU KNOW WHAT SHE BROUGHT UP WAS
THAT SHE FELT THAT THE F. PPC
WAS VERY WELL POSITIONED TO DO
THIS KIND OF WORK BECAUSE THERE
ARE. YOU THERE ARE ALREADY
AWARE.
LET'S SAY OF. KIND OF. THE WORLD
IN WHICH ELECTED OFFICIALS
OPERATE I AND I'M JUST
WONDERING.
IF YOU FEEL THAT YOUR YOUR PEER
OVERSIGHT PANEL GIVEN THAT. I'D
SAY NINETY NINE POINT NINE
PERCENT OF WHAT THEY'RE DEALING
WITH OUR EMPLOYEES THAT WHEN
THEY MAKE THAT SHIFT DO YOU FEEL
THAT THERE'S ENOUGH GUIDANCE FOR
THEM OR ENOUGH UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CONTACTS WITH WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS. AND THE GOVERNANCE
ISSUES.
THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS.
ARE UNDER YOU KNOW IT'S WE'RE
NOT EMPLOYEES OF THE LEGISLATURE
WILL YOU KNOW IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AND AND KIND OF HOW
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY WOULD HAPPEN
WHICH WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW EITHER FOR THE VOTERS
OR FROM OUR COLLEAGUES YES SO DO
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT IT
THAT. WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING
WITH THE ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
THE SAME MODEL WOULD WORK WELL
ARGUED THAT THIS DROP ACTUAL
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER
IF WE KIND OF WENT DOWN THAT
ROAD.
AND AND TRY TO PURSUE SETTING
UP A SIMILAR.
KIND OF OF PANEL TO DEAL WITH
THE LEGISLATURE
I MEAN A IN MY EXPERIENCE NOW
WORKING UNDER THIS MODEL FOR YOU
KNOW A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
YEARS.
ARMADA WORKS LIKE A CHARM
WHETHER THE INVENTIVELY ON
PLANES AGAINST ELECTED PERSON OR
NOT I MEAN THIS IS AN AREA OF
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE THIS IS
EMPLOYMENT LAW.
AND THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THE
LAWS WELL DEFINED.
AND YOU KNOW IT MAKES IT EASIER
AT THE ELECTIONS JUST SUBJECT
THEMSELVES TO THE POLICY WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THE ANALYSIS
ON WHETHER THEY'RE. YOU KNOW
WHEN EMPLOYEE ARE NOT THEY JUST
PUT THEMSELVES INTO THE PROCESS
BUT THAT ANALYSIS COULD BE DONE.
AND I MEAN THIS IS A WORKPLACE.
IN IN TODAY'S CLIMATE I WOULD.
SUGGEST MOST ELECTED MAY WANT TO
SUBJECT THEMSELVES TO THIS MODEL
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT THEY
FEAR FEEL AND THAT WE DELIVER.
FAIR OBJECTIVE MODEL.
OUT WHERE THE INVESTIGATIONS OF
FARO WELL DONE AND THAT WE GET
TO YOU KNOW. THE THE TRUTH.
I AND THAT IT'S FAIR.
AND THE YOU KNOW. OVERSIGHT IS A
BIG WORLD A BIG WORD OUR EQUITY
OVERSIGHT PIANO IT'S REALLY JUST
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WHO COME
IN AND LOOK AT THE WORK PRODUCT
AND MAKE A RECOMMENDATION AS TO.
A BACK TO THE COUNTY A WHAT THE
RECOMMENDED DISCIPLINE SHOULD
BE.
IT'S NOT OVERSIGHT IN LIGHT THE
FTP SEE SENSE OF OVERSIGHT.
AND IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
DISCIPLINE AS OF. A AN EMPLOYEE.
DISCIPLINE YOU KNOW CAN LOOK
LIKE A SUSPENSION OR TRAINING
WHAT WOULD TYPICALLY LOOK LIKE.
IN THIS MODEL FOR ELECTED
OFFICIALS SOMETHING SHORT OF
REMOVING FROM OFFICE WHAT OTHER
TYPES OF. OF DISCIPLINE.
YOU KNOW WOULD YOU SEE
ENVISIONED THEM OVERALL
RECOMMENDING AND IF THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING WHO IN OUR MODEL
WOULD THEY RECOMMEND TO IF ANY
THOUGHTS OF HOW HOW DOES THAT
WORK WITH THE COUNTY.
I AM IN THE MODEL FOR ELECTED
THE WRECK OF DEPENDING ON YOU
KNOW THE SEVERITY AND THE
FREQUENCY AND I AND ALL OF THAT
BUT IF IT'S THE FIRST TIME YOU
KNOW SOMEWHAT INNOCENT.
I IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS MEN
THOUGH THE RECOMMENDED
DISCIPLINE COULD BE. COUNSELING
IT COULD BE MEDIATION.
I MEAN IT YOU KNOW AND WE'RE
MINDFUL OF THE NEED TO KEEP
THINGS CONFIDENTIAL IT WE VIEW
IT AS A PERSONNEL MATTER AND
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
CONFIDENTIALITY.
AND WE GO TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
GIVE THEM THAT AND PROTECT THEM.
AYE AND IT'S YET THE DEPARTMENT
HEAD LEVEL AT AT AT THE ELECTED
LEVEL.
SO THAT'S HOW WE'VE HANDLED IT
AND IT'S
IT'S IT'S RARE.
THAT IT IS AT THAT LEVEL BUT IT
HAS THE IT MAY BE AT THAT LEVEL
AND WE'VE HANDLED IT I BELIEVE
WELL AT THAT LEVEL.
AND THEN THE WHO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BEING MADE TO
THE REST OF THE SUPERVISORS.
WE HAVE A A SCHEMATIC SO IT JUST
DEPENDS ON WHO'S INVOLVED AND IT
MAY. DEPENDING ON THAT AND MAY
GO TO THE CHAIR MAY GO TO THE.
YOU KNOW.
THE
C. E. O. AT TO DELIVER ANY WE
HAVE A WE'VE WORKED IT OUT BUT
AGAIN THOUGHT WAS GIVEN TO THAT
POINT. ON WHO DELIVERS THAT
MESSAGE ME YOU HAVE TO STARE AT
SOME ORG CHARTS AND YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT.
OF THE HIGHWAYS THIS GOING TO
WORK.
FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE THAT TRUST
IN.
TURNING THEMSELVES AND
SUBJECTING THEMSELVES TO THIS
MODEL AND THAT IT'S IT'S FAIR
FOR FOLKS TO DEMAND. THAT.
AND THAT WE HAVE TO DELIVER THAT
THAT'S FAIR.
HI SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL MOST
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR.
COMING FROM SUNNY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THEM I DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE KNOW THAT I NNOVA.
IS IT BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE IN
OZ.
THANK YOU FOR THAT
WELL FIRST OF ALL SENATOR MORE
ALIVE AND.
FOR A COPY OF YOUR POLICY AND
STAY IN STAFF HAS IT BUT I JUST
WANTED TO. A STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT HE MADE THAT
REQUEST.
SO I APPRECIATE COUPLE THINGS ON
YOUR CHART I APPRECIATE THE CASE
CLASSIFICATIONS A. B. C. M..
ALL BUT THAT BUT I WAS KINDA
TICKLE BECAUSE THIS ALMOST LOOKS
LIKE OUR HOW A BILL BECOMES A
LAW CHART. PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK IS
HOW LONG DOES THIS TAKE IT AND
GO WELL WITH WELL I'VE SAW
WILLIE BROWN GO THROUGH THIS
WHOLE PROCESS IN HALF A DAY ONCE
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AGO ORANGE
TO TO EUROPE. SO MY QUESTION IS.
IT AND I KNOW IT'S NOT REALLY A
FAIR QUESTION BECAUSE IT DEPENDS
ON IF IT'S ABC OR A AND. BUT WE
ARE.
.
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
IMPATIENCE.
AROUND WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
THAT THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW
AND I GET THAT. ALL MEN THERE'S
ALSO DANGER IN ARTIFICIALLY
RUSHING A PROCESS.
AND SO BASED ON THAT I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD GIVE ME A
GUESSTIMATE.
SINCE YOU'VE GOT KIND OF TO
BETWEEN YOUR INTAKE SPECIALIST
UNIT AND THE OVERSIGHT PANEL
LOOKING AT ALL OF YOUR.
CIRCLES.
YOU KNOW HOW LONG IT COULD TAKE
RIGHT GENERALLY JUST TO GIVE US
A FRAME OF REFERENCE SO THE
INTAKE THE COMPLAINTS COME IN IN
REAL TIME AND WHAT WE DO AT THE
INTAKE UNIT IS WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED. YOU KNOW A FEW FOLKS
EVERYDAY WHO LIKE WORK THE
HOTLINE KIND OF SO THEY'RE
REVIEWING IN REAL TIME ON OUR
DATABASE. THE COMPLAINTS AS THEY
COME IN AND THEY FLAG THE ONES
THAT ARE MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN
OTHER ONES I MEAN A LOT THAT
COMES IN.
WE KNOW FROM THE BEGINNING IS
JUST NOT JURISDICTIONAL OR NOT
REALLY GONNA WARRANT MUCH.
FURTHER INVESTIGATION BUT THE
ONES THAT WILL WE FLAG EARLY ON
AND THAT WE EXPEDITE THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
NOW WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND WE'RE GOVERNMENT. SO
YOU KNOW IF IF
DEPENDING ON THE SEVERITY MEAN
OF COURSE IF IT'S SIGNIFICANT
AND DEPENDING ON WHO'S INVOLVED
WE WILL EXPEDITE THOSE AND GET
THEM. THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS
IN BACK IN AS
QUICK A PERIOD OF TIME AS WE
NEED. IF ITS A MORE RUN OF THE
MILL KIND OF SITUATION THATYOU
KNOW WAS A POLICY VIOLATION BUT
MAYBE CO WORK ON CO WORKER. YOU
KNOW WE INTERVENE IN MAYBE
SEPARATE THE INDIVIDUALS
IMMEDIATELY WE TAKE THAT ACTION
IMMEDIATELY BUT AS FAR AS THE
INVESTIGATION GOING THE FULL
DISTANCE COMING BACK TO THE
PANEL. IT COULD BE EIGHT MONTHS.
SO YOU TRIAGE WE TRIAGE WE
TRIAGE PLAIN AND SIMPLE. DO
TRIAGE ON HOME.
I'M SO I DIDN'T INTERRUPT YOU
KNOW THAT THAT'S IT BUT THE THE
SIGNIFICANT ONES GET PULLED OUT
AND EXPEDITED THROUGH.
AND SO HOW DO EMPLOYEES KNOW WE
HEARD IN THE TECHNOLOGY PARA
HALT IMPORTANT INTO THAT
STUDENTS TO DO SOME OF THE APPS
THAT EMPLOYEES.
GET THE AUTOMATIC RESPONSE THAT
YOUR POINT HERE. CLAIM IS
RECEIVED.
THAT WE'VE HEARD A LOT HERE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
IF ANY ACTION IS TAKEN OVER
JUSTICE BLACK HOLE OF
INFORMATION. AND SO IF YOUR
TRIAGE TEAM RIGHT HOT Y. NO ON
THAT ACTION IS BEING TAKEN WHAT
WHAT EVIDENCE OR WHAT.
HOW DO I KNOW CHAR SO AGAIN THIS
IS ALL BASED ON A DATABASE?
AND WE'VE BUILT INTO THAT
DATABASE ALL OF THE NECESSARY
FORM LETTERS NOTIFICATION
LETTERS.
WEARING MY GENERATION THREE NOW
WITH THIS DATABASE SO YOU KNOW
WE WE IT'S IN A GOOD PLACE.
AND OUR INTAKE WORKERS YOU KNOW
CAN PUSH BUTTONS AND LETTERS GET
GENERATED INFORMATION GETS BACK
TO THE COMPLAINING PARTY TO THE
INVOLVED PERSON WHO ULTIMATELY
MAY BECOME THE SUBJECT.
SO WE TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE EQUATION NEED TO KNOW. AND
WE'VE BUILT THAT INTO OUR SYSTEM
AND YOU KNOW ALL THE FOLKS CALL
US SO WE COMMUNICATE THAT WAY
BUT ALSO WE JUST HAVE A LOT OF
STANDARD FORMS. THAT GET
TRIGGERED AUTOMATICALLY THROUGH
THE DATABASE SO THAT TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THE LOOP.
SO.
HOW LONG?
YOU KNOW COUNTING WORKERS STATE
EMPLOYEES. THINK TANK.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT REALLY
TOOK FOR YOUR EMPLOYEES TO BUY
INTO THE SYSTEM AND AND AND HOW?
WAS IT APPEAR TO YOU THAT
CULTURE SHIFT HAD BEGUN TO
HAPPEN.
SO I'LL TALK ABOUT THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
.
IT TOOK.
THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
FOR THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO
BUY ONE.
AND.
THE DAY I KNEW IT CHANGED.
WAS THE DAY WHEN ONE OF THE
FIERCEST OPPONENTS.
CALLED ME AND WAS ABOUT TO FILE
A COMPLAINT.
AND WAS NOT ALLOWED HIMSELF BUT
ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE AND WAS SO
HAPPY THAT THERE WAS A PROCESS
IN PLACE THAT THEY COULD JUST
REFER THINGS TO.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE LEARNED TO
THIS PROCESS WELL INITIALLY
THERE WAS RESISTANCE.
THE COUNTY LEVEL TO DEPARTMENT
HEADS OUT WE SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
WE SHOULDN'T BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS JUST
XIN APPLIED WHAT'S WERE
DIFFERENT.
AND WE WENT TO THAT TRAINING
EXPLAINING YOU'RE NOT DIFFERENT
NOT DIFFERENT UNDER THE LAW.
BUT.
ULTIMATELY UP THEY THEY YOU
KNOW THEY GET ON BOARD BUT AT
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THE DAY
THAT CHIEF CALLED AND TOLD ME.
HE WAS HAPPY THERE IS A PROCESS
WAS FOLLOWING THE PROCESS I KNEW
THINGS HAD CHANGED AND A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE WHO'D BEEN
INVOLVED IN BUILDING THIS
PROCESS IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. WAS ON AN AIRPLANE ONE
DAY AT A FEMALE DEPUTY SHERIFFS
THAT NEXT TO WHERE SHE DIDN'T
KNOW WHO SHE WAS AND THE FEMALE
DEPUTY SHERIFF WAS GOING ON AND
ON ABOUT HOW HAPPY. AS SHE WAS
TO WORK IN A CULTURE.
WE'RE REPORTING WAS THE NO ARMOR
YOU'RE ENCOURAGED TO REPORT. AND
MY COLLEAGUE FRIEND.
WAS JUST ELATED BECAUSE WE HAD
BEEN THERE WHEN THAT WASN'T THE
CULTURE.
SO I WOULD SAY THREE TO FIVE
YEARS BEFORE YOU SEE BY EN.
NOT TO NOT TO SUGGEST THAT.
IT DOESN'T WORK FOR THREE TO
FIVE YEARS.
BUT BEFORE IT FOLKS KINDA
SIMMER DOWN AND IT'S JUST
ROUTINE IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IT IS THE NORM IS TO
FILE A COMPLAINT.
THAT'S THE NORM.
THAT
FOR THAT TIME FROM TO BE
REFLECTED IN A MALE DOMINATED.
HIERARCHICAL ENTITY LIKE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS
IMPRESSIVE.
THEY DON'T YEAR.
WE JUST WANT CLARIFY ONE THING
WHEN YOU SAID EIGHT MONTHS AGO
THE PROCESS IS THAT INCLUDING
SORT OF A WAIT TIME BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A BACKLOG OF THESE ARE IS
THAT YOU START. DAY ONE
INVESTIGATING AND THEN THE TAKES
EIGHT MONTHS WE KNOW WE HAVE A
BACKLOG ANYWHERE TO LISTEN TO
YOU START DAY ONE HOW LONG WOULD
THE PROCESS TIP I KNOW EVERY
CASE IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT BUT
LET'S SAY YOU'RE KIND OF. ON
EIGHT WEEKS THE OKAY.
OKAY LET ME THAT ARE NOT IT'S
NOT AN ELABORATE IT'S NOT ROCKET
SCIENCE IT REALLY ISN'T. IT'S
BEEN UP AND RUNNING FOR MANY
YEARS MOST PLACES.
IT'S JUST BUILDING A MODEL THAT
WORKS AND IMPLEMENTING IT AND
THEN RUNNING IT. WITH SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE
YOU NEED TO HAVE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE
I CAN'T TURN IT OVER TO JUST
ANYBODY. JUST ISN'T A CITIZENS
COMMISSION.
NOW.
IT IS NOT.
THE OTHER PIECE
FOLLOW YOUR QUESTIONS ON AT THE
SEE.
LALATE HOW THE RELATIONSHIP IN
TERMS OF OVERSIGHT OVER ELECTED
THEY'RE NOT SUBSCRIBER EXPERTS
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE YES I
HEARD LOUDLY.
ABSOLUTELY.
ANYONE FROM THE SENATE THAT. THE
DIETS.
SOME REMEMBER IT.
THANK YOU.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU HAVE ON
STAFF THAT TAKE CARE OF THIS
PART OF?
FOR THE LA COUNTY.
THE INTAKE UNIT.
EMPLOYEES ABOUT TWENTY.
MY RECOLLECTION IS TWENTY I
DON'T I DON'T I'M NOT OVER IT
ANYMORE I'M DOING THE COUNTY
COUNCIL WORK NOW BUT ABOUT
TWENTY. IN THE COUNTY DE HR OF
WHO DOES THE FURTHER
INVESTIGATION THEY HAVE ABOUT
ANOTHER TWENTY INVESTIGATORS.
A PANEL OF THE OVERSIGHT PANEL
WE HAVE NINE MEMBERS THEY
CONVENE IN GROUPS OF THREE.
YOU KNOW MONEY IT TAKES MONEY
TO OPERATE THIS MODEL. BUT YOU
SAVE MONEY ON THE BACK AND I
MEAN WE'VE AND YOU CHANGE THE
CULTURE.
I AM IN THE PROCESS THAT'S KEY
IT MANY EMPLOYEES TO JUST SAY
YOU HAVE.
SO I'D SAY ABOUT TWENTY IT WORK
THE INTAKE UNIT THEN I'M SORRY.
HOW MANY PLOY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND?
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND OKAY.
AND IT IT.
THOSE REELS.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT IN
OUR PROCESS WE HAVE INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE EACH OF THE COLLEGES
THERE'S ONE EQUITY OFFICER EACH
COLLEGE.
PLUS A THREE FOLKS SUMMARY CHART
APARTMENT THAT ARE SPECIALLY
TRAINED.
WHEN WE GET BEYOND THAT LEVEL
WE HIRE OUTSIDE FOLKS TO HELP US
AND SO TYPICAL INVESTIGATIONS
TAKE NINETY DAYS OR LESS.
IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
AND I'M SORRY THAT FOR THE
FIRST FOR YOUR QUESTION.
WITHOUT A AYE MANY EMPLOYEES HOW
MANY PLACE TOTAL DO YOU HAVE.
WELL NONE OF THEM DOES THIS FULL
TIME SO THERE'S ABOUT TWELVE
FOLKS INTERNALLY THAT HANDLE
THIS ON AND ON A PART TIME BASIS
THEY HAVE OTHER JOBS AT THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW WE
WE WHERE MANY MANY HATS AS WE DO
OUR.
AND HOW MANY EMPLOYEES TOTAL DO
YOU HAVE THE AT THE AS. ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND PLUS OR MINUS
PLUS REMEMBER WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN OUR PROGRAM DOES ENCOMPASS
BOTH STUDENT COMPLAINTS AS WELL
AS FACULTY AND STAFF
ADMINISTRATION COMPLAINTS.
WONDERFUL AND I'D LIKE TO GO
BACK TO THE WE'VE YES BUT FIRST
I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH THE.
THAT THIS WAS A.
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION BRINGS
IT BACK TO. SOMETHING THAT IS
CLOSER TO WHAT IT IS WE DO. OWN
HAVE YOUR SUPERVISORS SEE UP THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS AS WELL AS
EMPLOYEES AND SUPERVISORS AT ARE
YOUR BOARD OF TRUSTEES ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS YES MA'AM THEIR
LOCALLY ELECTED NOW I WOULD TELL
YOU IF A BOARD OF IF SOMEONE
MADE A COMPLAINT ABOUT ONE OF
OUR TRUSTEES OR CHANCELLOR. ONE
OF OUR EXECUTIVE STAFF WE WOULD
GO IMMEDIATELY OUTSIDE COUNSEL
THAT WOULD NOT BE HANDLED BY
INTERNAL FOLKS IT'S.
THE POWER DYNAMIC IS JUST TOO
LARGE FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND I BELIEVE IN OUR SITUATION
WE WOULD BE REPORTING BACK TO
THE FULL BOARD WHICH IS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT THAN YOUR
LEGISLATURE OF THE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOLKS I DON'T SEE HOW
THAT WORKS FOR YOU BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE WOULD BE DOING. WE DON'T
KNOW YET EITHER.
WHAT WE'VE I WANT TO GO BACK TO
WE'VE BECAUSE AT THAT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED HERE AS WELL AND I
KNOW THE QUESTIONS?
HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED
SO.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR IN MY MIND.
WHEN YOU HIRE A SEXUAL ASSAULT
COUNSELOR.
THAT PERSON IS NOT A MANDATORY
REPORTER THEM.
AND THE WORD MANDATORY REPORTERS
LOADED IN THAT CONTEXT AND IT
MAKES A PERSON WHO IS A MINOR.
WE ARE ALL MANDATORY REPORTER SO
THERE IS NO CONFIDENTIALITY IF
YOU CAME AND SAID YOU WERE
ASSAULTED AS A MINOR. WORTH YOUR
MINOR CHILD CAME AND SAID I WAS
ASSAULTED SO LET'S JUST PUT THAT
IN THE PARKING LOT FOR A MOMENT.
.
EVERYONE ELSE THAT WOULD COME TO
OUR WE'VE CONFIDENTIAL REPORTER
THERE IS NO REPORTING THAT THEY
MAKE AT ALL.
THAT VARIAS AYE THAT'S A HUNDRED
PERCENT REAL IT'S ESSENTIALLY A
A PATIENT AND COUNCIL OR
PRIVILEGE BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM.
AND IF THE PATIENT SAYS I'D LIKE
YOU SHARE THIS INFORMATION OR
YOUR AUTHORISES SURE THIS
INFORMATION THEN THE COUNSELOR
MAY IF THE PATIENT SAYS NO.
THEN I AS I READ THE LAW THAT
COUNCIL HAS APPROVED THE
PRIVILEGE AND IS REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN THE PRIVILEGE OF THE
PERSON WHO BRINGS THE REPORT.
YOU SAY THAT YOU RECEIVE.
DE IDENTIFIED INFORMATION YES.
DOES THIS PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO THAT IF YOU
RECEIVE INFORMATION THAT THERE
WAS A RAPE A CRIMINAL. ACT.
IS THAT BEEN TURNED OVER TO THE
POLICE SO THEY DO THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION.
THE INFORMATION THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IN THAT PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD NOT BE
ENOUGH TO TURN ANYTHING OVER TO
THE POLICE THE POLICE WOULD BE
ADVISED OF THAT BECAUSE AS
COLLEGES WE ALSO HAVE OUR CLEARY
OBLIGATIONS TO REPORT CRIMINAL
ACTIONS THAT HAPPEN ON OUR
CAMPUS.
AND THAT'S ONE REASON WE ASK FOR
THE DE IDENTIFIED DATA TO MAKE
SURE WERE FULFILLING THAT
FEDERAL OBLIGATION.
ON THE OTHER REASON IS TO MAKE
SURE WERE IDENTIFYING PATTERNS.
OR PATTERNS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
BEING VICTIMIZED PROBLEMS OF
PLACES THAT ARE WERE
VICTIMIZATION IS OCCURRING.
PATTERNS WHERE WE WE CAN DO
SOMETHING AS A COLLEGE TO SAY
WE'RE GONNA STOP WHATEVER'S
HAPPENING OVER IN THAT SPOT.
THAT'S THE KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT WE MIGHT GET FROM SOMEONE
ON DE IDENTIFIED BASIS BUT THERE
BE NO WAY FOR OUR POLICE
OFFICERS. AYE GIVEN THE DE
IDENTIFIED REPORT TO DO ANYTHING
BEYOND THAT.
IN MY FINAL QUESTION IS.
MOST OF MOST OF THIS HAS TO DO
WITH SEXUAL ASSAULT AS OPPOSED
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BOB IS SEXUAL HARASSMENT HANDLED
DIFFERENTLY.
I BELIEVE THAT IF SOMEONE WERE.
SEXUALLY HARASSED HIM AND
WANTED TO ACCESS OUR WE'VE
PERSON THEY WOULD HAVE THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT AND IT WOULD
BE HANDLED THE SAME WAY.
TYPICALLY THEY DON'T ASK FOR AN
ADVOCATE IN THAT CONTEXT.
ENDS OR NORMAL PROCESS YOU ARE
SCARED XIN AND DISCIPLINE APPLY
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF YOU THE QUESTIONS.
WITH THAT THANK YOU WANNA THANK
THE PANEL VERY VERY MUCH THIS
WAS REALLY REALLY HELPFUL.
AND WITHOUT A MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS WOMAN ASK ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT.
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
ANYBODY. CARE TO COMMENT.
OKAY SEEING NONE I DO WANNA
ANNOUNCED THAT NEXT TUESDAY WERE
HAVING OUR NEXT HEARING. AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE JOINED WITH.
SOMEONE WHO I THINK WILL BE
FASCINATING FOR ALL OF US AND
THAT'S RETIRED CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CARLOS
MORENO.
IT'S GOING TO BE CONTINUING TO
DELVE INTO THE ISSUES AROUND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A DUE
PROCESS.
I WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED